[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
wild results shook up the standings at
the feed a candidates in madrid spain
former challenger fabiano carawana
gambled with black for a chance to grab
a crucial point against yong kristoff
duda that backfired allowing fellow
american hikaru nakamura and chinese
star ding loren to catch him in a
three-way tie for second place after
winning their games ian napomiacci has a
point and a half lead over the field
with three contenders in hot pursuit
round 11 of exhilarating chess coming up
next
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our
coverage of the 2022 candidates
tournament
live from madrid spain as things are
really heating up after 10 rounds of
play we are ready for round 11.
and dorsa as always good morning
wonderful hello everyone
nepo
is doing what he has done from the very
beginning he is leading and he extended
his lead to one and a half points
yesterday but in his wake
there's a huge fight for second place
and let's take a look at the standings
and to see who's in that fight for a
second dorsa do the honors well nepal is
running away with a solid seven points
then we have
three super grand masters fabiano the
naka and
dingley ran with five and a half
wow wow yeah it's great stuff remarkably
enough after 10 rounds of play the three
rookies in the field are all sharing the
10th place and dorsa our format
it's a very very special format it's an
eight player double round ribbon
and the timing is very very
special too because you get 120 minutes
for the first 40 moves followed by 60
minutes for the next 20 moves and
finally you get a 15 minutes plus 30
second increments for the rest of the
game three time controls no draw offers
before black's 40th move
500 000 euros in prize money and let's
take a look at our remaining schedule
dorsa
well today is the last day in june oh
god
round 11 then we have around 12 tomorrow
july 1st free day on saturday yes
and then we play to the finish wonderful
absolutely and we're very fortunate to
have alejandro in a studio uh to dig
down deeper on this pretty important
fight for second alejandro good morning
good morning yasir good morning
dorsa and you've said it it might be an
important fight for second place usually
when we talk about the candidates we
really don't care who finishes second
because it's all about who gets first
this year it's a special type of
tournament because magnus carlsen has
hinted not confirmed hinted that he
might not play the world championship
match if he is playing a repeat opponent
of course the leader currently is janet
pogniacci and that might mean that
magnus doesn't want to take those six
months to prepare so strongly that takes
so much out of him for the world
championship match the cycle is of
course grueling but let's take a look
then who is fighting for a second
because second place eventually would
play nepo if magnus is not there after
three rounds it was very clear that
there was a
fight for first famine carrana janet
with two points had already separated
themselves from the field slightly
hikaru nakamura had bounced from a bad
round one with against team of rajab got
to 50 percent dingley rent absolutely
nowhere to be found in the cellar let's
take a look at how this changed after
round six bobby's still there half a
point behind nepal a full point ahead of
hikaru nakamura and a full point and a
half
ahead of dalaran and how
the
tournament has changed how the
acceleration
has changed for some of these players
because take a look at hikaru he's
caught up with fabian take a look at
ding liran surging through the standings
all the way there from the bottom to
second place dingleran is the person
that is catapulting himself he is
currently tied for second with the
americans and they have everything to
fight for i know that they say they
don't care but the back of their minds
they might be thinking you know what if
nepal wins this tournament there's still
a shout for me to be world chess
champion and that's magnus declining and
me getting second and beating nepo when
it comes down to the matches still a lot
to play for for all of these three
players thank you alejandra which of
course means that today's pairings dorsa
are
so important uh lay the table for us and
do the honors what can our viewers
expect well naka has a devil white wow
he's playing against rockwort then we
got firoz john nepo a very key match
absolutely followed by raj apple versus
doodle and there it is now they're
enough fight for sex
another super key match up with fabi
versus thing how does bobby and dingler
in do in their head-to-head matches well
through the magic of television there's
the graphic dorsa wow fobby has two wins
they have total of seven draws including
a previous matchup but ding does have
three wins not bad very very close super
super competitive
as we get ready and of course the the
fight
uh that they're all fighting for is the
prize pool of half a million dollars
five euros pardon me
yeah i always mess that up oh well
the first place does go home with a nice
48 000 euros followed by second place 36
000 euros and finally third place 24 000
euros as alejandro said these events are
winner takes all because it's all about
becoming challenger to the world
champion this man magnus carlson the
2023 world championship match is slated
for next year at a site to be determined
maybe 2 million euros in prize money and
that's why becoming the challenger is
such a big deal if magnus declines
however
wow that fight for second
sure becomes so very very interesting
now again
we're looking at two marquee matchups
alireza versus our tournament leader
nepo and fabi versus ding laren
fabi coming off
well i want to say just back bad brace
of games he lost twice with black pieces
and yesterday's game in particular
that must have been very painful
alejandro
i have the feeling fabi's running out of
gas what's what's your take
that is
not a bad take yasser because this is
such a long tournament it's been a long
tournament for a lot of these players
and it's been a long summer for a lot of
these tournaments i know that favi
hasn't been in st louis
for what feels like months finished the
american cup packed up went to the grand
chess tour and hasn't been back since
he's been in uh
in europe since bucharest
either preparing or playing and it's
true for a lot of these players
some of these players they're not in
their early 20s anymore yeah it starts
to affect you this is an already 11
round tournament we have three more
rounds after today these games have been
exceedingly long notes not just the
amount of games but the type of games we
have seen games go to the seventh hour
and i feel that that game that
favi put all in against timor rajabov
that was such a long and brutal game
with so much calculation where both
sides had queens on the board after
their kings were so exposed
man those are rough games right we're
tired here analyzing them with an engine
and commentating between the three of us
but they have to sit down and figure out
all these nuances themselves i am sure
that they are tired but so are the other
players and that's how we see a lot of
mistakes we see a lot of games open up
how many decisive games have we seen in
the last couple of rounds precisely
three two three three
and a draw versus what was happening
earlier 11 draws out of 12 games and
suddenly now everybody can can land a
punch yeah the thing is who is going to
be the best prepared for the last rounds
who is going to be the one that still
puts some fuel in their tank to finish
up this tournament strong remember nepal
still has to finish this event we've
already kind of given him a 94 90 plus
percent chance of winning this event but
he still has to do it right he still has
to finish it one of the main problems
that nepo's always had during events is
that he gasses out he still has such a
comfortable lead right now right that we
are thinking it doesn't really matter he
should be able to cruise control
but for the rest the tournament just
started
for favi ding
this tournament just started and they
have to fight for first place among them
right now we're not really giving timor
uh a chance to fight for second it's a
full point with not that many rounds to
go timor has a lot of difficult pairings
ahead of him and a lot of these people
on the seller
we expected them to do better
but
hikaru and ding have win behind their
sales right they are surging hikaru just
destroyed alireza they just beat
rockwood with black
favi he just lost he needs to get his
head in the game
and come back and that's one of the
toughest things to do in chess
yeah he's certainly facing quite the
battle there but
i was looking once again at our current
standings i'm thinking to myself dorsa
you're having this you're alireza you're
having this terrible tournament
uh you want it to be over with but guess
what you're playing against the
tournament leader wow and you know
the word redemption you know if you beat
the tournament leader everybody in the
event is going to come over and say hey
dinner's on me you know like here's my
credit card go and have a good time so
what does this mean and this is how
they match up not too many games between
them but quite a number of decisive
games well don't worry about the number
of games between them
what i'm worried about is the amount of
games that laresa has
today
what if you guys don't know what i'm
talking about it was the buzz of the
internet while we were at sleep
alireza actually stayed up until 6 00 am
playing chess on leeches
against the certain grandmaster
commentator
dania naradiski and take a look at this
marathon madness this all happened
yesterday they played a total of 250
bullet games
count it up 250
bullet games just yesterday night they
started around 1am they finished at 5 47
a.m
108 points for farouz 142 for naraditsky
of course i were just not playing the
tournament
but ali reza perhaps a little tilted
perhaps blowing off some steam there
online
but nepal must be looking at that and
saying wait this guy stayed up until 6am
playing bullet
and i get to play him
all right all right i agree
whoa
that's a huge
that's exercising quite a number of
demons there i mean
boy uh 250 games at six in the morning
but we do have moves and as expected uh
um
nepo at least defended one e4 with the
petrov the russian defense knight f6
which he has done throughout the
tournament remaining ultra solid as
black and against knight takes e4
we have knight c3 is a modern variation
a lot of grandmasters are tilting
towards that the old and very well
established d4 has not brought
much success to nepo's opponents i mean
he's the only player undefeated in the
tournament after all so we have a
different approach by alireza c2c4 just
to try to make it a little bit more
awkward for white for black pardon me to
play the move d5 knight c6 d3 get out of
here the knight drops back d4 and we
have caught up with the players
i
never thought much of this they played
um i've always played either d4 or
knight c3 right i'm not very um
i'm not very comfortable i i i have a
lot to understand when it comes to c4
because c4 is just such a
uncom uncommon move that i mean i get
that it stops d5 but
i mean i might need some help from my
coach on this one
[Laughter]
well he's not been your coach for much
longer as you're uh transferring
universities but yeah so the idea of c4
i think from um ali reza's point of view
is he want just wants a fight he wants a
game that is not going to be 20 moves of
theory but he's probably not going to
get it frankly because people have
looked at c4 as well so again the idea
is
in the petrov as white normally speaking
you're trying to take advantage of the
knights
being exposed in the middle of the board
so like if you wanted for example in
this position to play queen e2 your your
chances of getting an advantage
is the fact that you're playing against
the knight so here you're threatening to
compromise black's pawn structure with
queen
bishop takes f6 so this is how you
get something a slight slight slight
advantage when you've played the move c4
knight c6 d3
the knight goes back and then you play
d4 it's sort of like well you forced the
knight to go back you didn't get
anything in particular
as a
as white against the exposed knight and
d5 that's kind of what i'm thinking my
default is black is going to happen at
some point not necessarily right now so
i'm
trying to understand how does that
actually change um white's uh move
because white was most if if white
played pawn d4 they would probably
follow it by pawn c4 probably bishop d3
short castle knight c3 all those good
old classicals so how do i'm
okay that doesn't make sense there we go
right there we got the d5 yeah if you
for example just as you were about to
say if you play the good old knights e3
and black plays d5 it sure looks like
you're in familiar territory
so what white is doing now with the move
d5
is saying okay i'm expanding i'm
grabbing a little extra space in the
center and after
95 for example we could play bishop e2
which all of course begs the question at
this move at this moment
black could easily have played the move
d5 and after knight c3 i don't see a
better move played bishop e7 and ruled
out exactly uh d4 d5
okay so here we are and uh d5
um ali alejandro uh is there many games
in the database from this position and
by the way we do
do have some not bishop e2 95 94. has
ali reza
discovered something in the dusty parts
of the chess library
not exactly dusty but it is pretty rare
there is a game that i see with the move
d5 extremely rare only played twice in
my database but the important game that
i see is a game between two former world
champions in women here alexander
costelli played against tanzania both of
them former world champions and
kostanyuk won this one so
i don't know exactly where they played
but if they played against each other it
must have been some important tournament
because they are not geographically that
close right they played 95 in this
position and knight takes e5 kind of
shatters the structure but it doesn't
help
the fact that this bishop becomes so
powerful right so you don't really want
to play knight takes e5 instead of the
rest of plays the move knight d4 i don't
see this move on my database anymore and
it challenges black to figure out what
to do with this lack of space
on the other hand black has development
you got the knights out you got the
bishop out you're going to castle short
this guy is not castling anytime i
haven't moved any pieces
it does seem a little silly to play like
this for white but it has its dangers
for example if you castle in this
position and both sides just finished
development happily let's put some
normal moves right already the engine
doesn't like black very much why because
you don't have space and your brakes are
very reduced if you ever play the move
c6 in this position i can play knight c3
and hold on to that pawn
so what the engine wants to do at least
from an initial impression is to break
immediately
break right away so that on knight c3
you can develop this bishop you want to
trade pieces when you're down space
this very typical idea in chess try to
force white into some kind of
concessions take on d5 take on d5 and
once you've weakened this you've
exchanged the
dice chord bishops you can use
this pawn as a target
with the light squared bishop still on
the board it's not going to be as easy
because this bishop on c8 doesn't have a
good way to target d5
you want to exchange these bishops
before
white plays and with bishop b2 very rare
perhaps although has a few ideas in this
position we're gonna have to wait and
see but nothing really theoretical and i
think alireza got the surprise that he
wanted in against nepo
and we'll see if it pays off a quick
question for you because uh alejandro
you're playing the move c7
c6 for nepo and challenging the center
and white's reacting by knight c3
can nepo be a little bit more incisive
and play c7 c5
and uh boot that knight gain some tempe
you could the problem is that you'd
never break right
your break becomes b5 which is hard to
organize in this particular structure
you'd rather have the bishop on g7 in
this structure okay
not a big deal i understand the bishop
can always return right to g7
it's not a bad way of playing but it
does feel that white gets to consolidate
you got the knight to c2 the knight
comes to e3 at some point this knight
comes out to c3 bishop on e2 castle and
one day i'll play f4
right not anytime soon i leave a lot of
weaknesses behind my structure when i
play f4 because everything down the e
file becomes weaker right but it does
become hard
for black to utilize that fact as long
as his bishop is on e7 and he has no
space and at the moment that's the main
problem for black no space it's pawn on
d5 giving white the little edge on the
position that was actually castled and
immediately in the move knight c3 not a
big deal here still you can still play
c6 the engines don't like white that
much
but i feel it's uh already gets a little
something something from the opening and
might be might be in a position to press
well i mean whenever you can surprise
your opponent in the opening some kind
of success going on there
very very good news for us
as we we want to see a close fight at
top let's jump to the game between fabi
and ding loren because
so much is riding on the outcome of this
game and boy dorsa the players are just
snapping out the moves the first thing i
saw was ding had already touched both of
his bishops
he couldn't continue uh from uh
yesterday uh chess curiosities okay rui
lopez fabi could explain expect pardon
me that ding loren would be playing the
black side of irui
and this particular move order in the
old days everybody used to play d7 d6 c2
c3 castles
h2h3 this wasn't even the
tabia position
but
the modern players have all realized
that the marshall gambit move order is
the right way to go
because with this martial gambit move
order you're threatening the immediate
d7 and d5
as
magnus played against nepo for example
in their world championship match in
a284 the anti-marshal
fabi very very familiar
with this position this goes back
alejandra i want to say to the streak
bishop c1d2 didn't bobby play this
originally against
um
[Music]
are you talking about the 7-0 streak in
the hill cup yeah with bishop d2
didn't he play it against lavonne must
have right who else would play in that
tournament yeah exactly i think it was
against lavon so bishop d2 the thing is
i've seen fabi play bishop d2 so much i
forgot which one was his first time and
which one was his uh
because he's played this line yes bishop
d2 before not exactly in this position
again kind of like the italian kind of
like in the spanish the subtleties
whether the bishops on b7 the rooks on
b8 the slight little differences the
bishop on d2 is normally played when the
rook's on v8 more than when the bishop's
on b7 right but
same kind of ideas nice
knight g3 so the players oh
i've just been told uh verusion big
shout out to var and uh
in the truck there the production talk
knight h4
a novelty i have to ask there was
another game um i think he was when phi
was playing nepo that she played another
knight h4 i believe another novelty so
this is the second night this word
novelty exactly yeah
okay uh knight h4 is a novelty and the
first thing i'm looking at you know
you're looking
yeah can i grab a pawn
and
uh wha what is that because uh the
bishop
on issa i mean if you recapture with the
pawn
or the knight the bishop over here
grabs this knight
on h4 so
do we have some trickies like knight you
have a tricky and i'll just give it to
you since it's early morning it's d
takes e4 okay
and it's surprising how lost black is in
this position you take an h4 knight f5
so you're threatening the bishop so the
bishop has to drop back and now i start
queen g4 is the beginning
okay you're threatening to take my queen
i see you're right first of all good
morning everyone
you are threatening to grab my queen but
i can deal with that right good luck uh
i can
oh he's gonna play bishop hc yes i'm
gonna play bishop g5 oh okay okay
let me get my king out of dodge
and now i have to find a way to win
correct all right good morning good
morning
um what is the way to win here well you
do have the rookless looks nice bishop
g5 looks nice
uh
bishop okay rook i'm coming to d6 that
looks scary rookie 3 looks scary yeah
rook e3 looks scary uh bishop g5 you're
getting rid of my good defender
of course you're also
kind of i don't know if this is much of
a help but i do get to
win a tempo defending g7 you said a rook
lift yeah
yeah
i must say there's not a lot of
palace guards and uh we could we could
choke on this extra pawn
uh this looks dangerous it's just mate
yeah
yeah
rookie three is just winning nice uh
nice uh one there dorset that rover
ma'am
yesterday we had so many amazing games
we had three decisive games
but we have a reporter in madrid
who talked to some of the players had
interviews after the games with the
players including uh anastasia with
ding lehren coming up let's see what
ding said about his victory it's always
interesting to play against a richard
since here we always
come with something very interesting
they move nice before very
spectator
uh
yeah it's a move that confronts
all his pieces and
but i'm lucky that i i can
hold myself with root c6 and pc pc7
i think overall the game
was
a good game by me and i think i would
better throughout the game
so maybe at some point it's closely
equal but
i don't think i'm in any kind of danger
so i'm very happy with my performance
so just there was some noise in the
background there i'm picky i'm drawing
the game that ding spoke about against
uh
his opponent
richard rapport
and what he was talking about in the
interview with anastasia he said
that when he's playing against richie
he's expecting something really unusual
and he said when you know if richie
found knight c4 it was like oh my god
[Music]
sounds reported here comes report but he
said that he was really really happy
that he could find this move rook c6
king c7 he was able to defend hold off
the pressure and eventually win a
crucial ending and a crucial point uh
alejandro i mean
what a victory with the black pieces in
the candidates they don't come easy or
often as black that was a tired
dingleran but a happy thing lorena
relieved dingler and he feels like he's
back in the tournament he's back
fighting for the places that he should
be fighting for right now let's go to
the games today dingleran i think is an
important game to watch of course he's
playing against favi game of the day in
my opinion this was an important one
because hikaru is in second and he's
playing ritchie rapport richie just lost
right richie has not had a very good
tournament and we know how self-critical
he is of his play and sometimes affects
his play in later games
this one it seems like he's caught he
covered by surprise of course this
particular position is not catching
anybody by surprise doesn't catch
anybody at all this is the main line of
this fashion cup sicely but wait a
second
richard rapport playing this fashion
cuff system what what he doesn't do it
he doesn't he doesn't play sveshnikov
he's completely uh taimanov sicilian
player in this tournament he played e4
e5 wants to surprise his opponent and we
get another surprise he's done falling
for preparation
he's learned the special eco for this
game i guess and after a long thing
hikaru deciding between these lines of
95 that we saw very sharply uh pretty
much exhibited for the first time at
high level chess between fabiano caron
and magnus carlson in the match of 2018
or the main line bishop g5 which is what
he's playing we're going to leave this
one alone because there's tons of theory
in this version code that's vegeta has
theory that's super long there are some
variations that
no lie and no exaggeration go 3235 moves
long wow oh before we move on alondra
quick question do you think it's
possible that dropboards played slash
nicole because hikaru was white
yesterday and got a swishnikov type of
position even though he didn't exactly
like it wasn't special if it started
this night or but it turned into a
swishnikov
well it wouldn't i don't think it was
because of yesterday's game because
hikaru showed that he understood that
structure pretty well at least much
better than his opponent he knew how to
get a knight to f5 in checkmate so i
don't think so uh we're also not gonna
get this typical gtx f6 type of smashing
cuff uh sicilian we're gonna go for this
bishop g5 bishop takes f6 i've seen
hikara play the move c4 before he played
against fabiano caruana in the u.s chess
championship of 2018 and uh but the main
line is c3 it's what most people are
playing theoretically it's equal but
race or edge equal where black needs to
find a lot of precise moves to fully
equalize this kind of end games in many
variations black has been shying away
from some of the main line theories and
throwing in a very early rook b8 without
castling us with v8 display
without castling at all uh knight c2 is
almost what everybody else play what
everybody plays in this position
i'm gonna put that in for hikaru and
uh castle used to be the main line no
full stop uh
bishop g5 has become much more popular
at the moment and it goes into all very
long variations a4 becomes a move a3 is
a move and we're gonna have to again
wait and see what they have in store for
each other
because richard obviously just looked at
this and hikaru he must have had some
plan against this fashion cough because
it's just such a popular opening exactly
but that being said nobody in this
tournament is a special golf player yeah
not specialist i'm sorry aleandro i
really really wanted to interrupt you
and jump to this game between fabi and
dinglerin
i've been told that the move knight h4
is a novelty um
but it
certainly did not surprise dingler in
because he answered
rather quickly g7 g6 obviously this
knight wants to come to f5 the move g7
g6 is the prescription the antidote
against the knight landing there bishop
again the players are playing
very quickly bishop h6 rookie eight and
are you ready for this as the dutch
would say varasing
surprise
bang
here we go you just played the move g7
g6 stopping me from landing on the f5
square you know that one no you didn't
you know that was coming but look what's
coming next cause this is remarkable
right right okay you're catching up with
me so
everybody normally would sit there and
say holy smokes the bishop on h6 is
bothersome i will play the move bishop
f8 i'm not going to take this knight but
i am threatening to take the knight then
suddenly look at this
bishop to d8 first of all again
very quickly played by dingler this is
and well what is the knight doing on f5
well well just before we go into that
variation yeah why couldn't you play
bishop f8 exactly thank you
you can just put it on your board and it
should be obvious once you put it bishop
f bishop g5 your knight's trapped
is it that simple
it is there's no
there's no defen and walking into the
pin is not what you wanted to do you
don't even have bishop g7 because i take
a knight h6 oh that's just terrible no
no no you don't even want to even think
about this one takes and as you say
knight h6 check not to mention
probably
yeah i was going to tell you i'd take
that bishop but the bishop on a2 hitting
the f7 so all of this happened rather
quickly and now that you've achieved
this as white you kind of think well
i'm ready to play i don't know queen f3
or maybe i just have to lick my wounds
and say well the knight's actually
pretty good on
e3
no
knight g7
and i'm reeling i'm uh
i need help alejandro well it's a top
move of the engine that's no surprise to
anybody okay lorena is finally thinking
he played bishop d8 very quickly it
feels that he is remembering his
preparation remember that he does this a
lot he's done this in this tournament
before where he gets a position that he
knows
but he takes his time finding his moves
remembering his variations he analyzes
all of these things very very deeply
it's trying to figure out what's going
on in the preparation mine of both
players 97 on the board you attack the
rook there's not that many options the
rook can go to e7 or f8 the engine wants
to go to f8
looks a little logical to me right and
now we have to ask ourselves what is the
follow-up queen f3 doesn't do very much
and when you start getting your pieces
stuck like this right you run the
problems that if something comes off the
board or you get a proper attack as
black the game is just over in this case
the move knight g4 for example
attacks the bishop on h6 and it's the
only defender of this stuck knight on g7
uh even more precise will be ideas of b3
to play knight g4 later but first kill
that bishop
don't let this bishop participate in the
attack this will be a common resource
throughout the game right to play b3 to
kill the bishop at least for this
important tempo rook fair by the way
played
let's see what else he has he that's the
move h3 which is already played
which is it's a logical move it prevents
knight g4 right it also prevents queen
g4 training the queens allowing me to
play queen f3 pretty soon how exactly is
favi planning to kill
the opponent's king i'm not entirely
sure just yet i need to figure this one
out because black's pretty solid
this knight on g7
every bug house player knows
this knight on g7 does not threaten the
king no it's in the way it's in the way
it's actually safeguarding the king in a
way and it's totally stuck i mean you're
not bringing it back unless you
sacrifice it right so we're gonna have
to figure out exactly how he's planning
to do that uh the engines at the moment
are giving the move bishop c6 as the
best move i like it because it attacks
pawn on a4 prepares to move b3 okay but
it is a little bit slow
so you have to have a pretty uh
pretty strong nerves to play a move like
bishop c6 something that's more logical
to me just play b3 right you've got your
knight stuck there i don't should not
care as much for material right if i can
just kill your bishop off from the
attack that should help me a lot that
way then when you sacrifice a knight
eventually on f5 i could consider taking
it well alejandra i just want to you
know bring that up because um i think
it's nice to have it on the board can we
go like two moves back after 905 and
just show what happens if thing did take
take that much
i think he gets put it from the
candidate
i mean
i see checkmate that's coming up you
know you just bring your coin to g7 and
it's bye-bye go home but but let's
actually have it on the board i want to
see if there's yeah there's just nothing
it it it really is that simple you're a
queen of three queen g3 and it's game
over there's there's nothing you can do
about it okay i move like bishop f8 i
still have bishop g5 but in this case i
also have an evil easier way queen here
defends this uh bishop and threatens
queen g5 so you just can't take
the the knight is taboo
you can't open up the g file you'll get
married like alireza did yesterday don't
want to do that
h3 is now on the board and we're going
to have to wait and see if digloran
knows all of this
because fabi does and i'm sure that
having prepared for fabi before i know
that fabi has many more moves from this
position if dingleran follows the engine
recommendation so at some point dangling
has to figure out things on his own he
might be on his own already
and it's it's a fight guys it's it's
exactly what we want to see well let's
see this fight for a second a little bit
deeper because i think the move
b4b3
is suggests itself i like the bishop c6
bishop takes a4 but c3 just to kill this
bishop and to make sure that that knight
has a difficult time extracting itself i
think all of these moves really kind of
play themselves right knight c6 and you
better play b4
right alejandro otherwise that bishop
will remain buried
on a horrible square like b1 now after
b4 knight takes before for example
suddenly this bishop can emerge
and
i you know i you're right this knight on
g7
is a little bit weird to say the least
but
i can imagine that
this is a this is a kind of game that
fabi would love to play as white
therefore
going after the pawn bishop c6 strikes
me is the most challenging if you can
take and then play b3 you kill two birds
with one stone and you got a pawn in
your pocket so bishop c6 feels like the
most challenging how would fabby respond
to that one i'm still trying to figure
it out because this is what i want to
know if black passes passes passes yeah
how does white set up on the king's side
to kill black let's say that you don't
make a useful move right right i
understand bishop c6 is a useful move
because attacks the pawn and him somehow
prepares b3
but let's pretend it doesn't do anything
yeah so we go queen f3 right you go
bishop a whatever right right
so what black just takes a a wait and
see approach
yes how do i kill you obviously this
can't be good
no
it must be good for white it must be
good for white but at some point prove
it prove it you'll have to at some point
right how do i
if
if i just simply recharge because one of
the things you've been pointing out is
this knight on f6 actually
isn't that very well protected uh bishop
g5
i might not even have to move my knight
from f5 perhaps
i leave it on f5 because it's so taboo
right i don't think you can ever take
this knight agreed so start with a move
like bishop g5
bishop g5 remember the knight on f5
has the square on h6 and because the
bishop is not dead yet on a2 right there
will be tricks with knight h6 bishop to
except seven i think this is i think
you're discovering what uh fabi wants to
say he's prepared for his opponent you
know get the knight to age six
dorset
f5 how do i feel about tonight's h5
ideas not necessarily in this specific
position but that might work right it
might work right i might just win
if you could get yeah well let's take a
look dorsa because if you
we we've kind of been seeing that any
time you open up the g-file
uh life's terrible for black so
capturing with the knight
and captures with it this looks really
dangerous i mean the knight threatening
is still let's say made along the g file
yeah that's easy
easy peasy and then the knight could
come to f6 that might be it queen f3
knight h5 uh that's the okay well let's
let's have a look then
bishop c6 queen f3
bishop takes a4
welcome to munch that looks like an
accident waiting to happen and then
night age five
that might be it right that might just
be uh i'm over a smack
smack unless i can sacrifice an ex no
i was about to suggest sacrificing an
exchange
with a move
uh a pass move i don't know um
well
there's a bigger threat than bishop then
here yeah
knight f6 i'm i feel like
earlier b3 for black might be
forced i want to say i mean probably not
the only move but pawn b3 just to blind
this other bishop okay or even before
bishop c6 to not lose the
tempo um
this is okay uh either way you've got
this knight h5 coming so
now in this position you do have
a knight f6 check and that's
causing me
to wait
queen e7
you can win an exchange
i don't know
these are
some pretty nice bishops i don't think
this is what
what uh white has in mind alejandro
um
bishop c6
queen f3
uh
pardon me uh
b3 yeah you take that take that knight
takes okay and now uh door says knight
h5 is
is a frightening move but i don't
think it refutes black's position but
try the other night
well either one right it's the same
thing
and we go queen e7
yeah that's not not easy you do have
very strong bishops that's what i'm
saying i and maybe i'll get upon
two bishops very i if ever i beat back
the attack in this fashion
then the knight is really suffering
right okay sorry i gotta take the
exchange sorry bishop takes rook takes
knight g3 i've got two bishops
and
likely i'm i'm a favorite to win a pawn
your favorite but it's important if you
don't get that pawn no way i don't
believe you have enough right i i will
certainly
take uh
um yeah
the the i'll attack the pawn on is on d3
it's very sharp it's extremely sharp it
comes down to tempo by tempo right even
at that final position if i have rookie
three and it works if you take on b2 but
i get my knight to c4 for example right
yeah the knight suffers right now but if
one day this knight gets to c4 yeah just
saying you're grooving b3 was play b3
immediately right yeah
i have to sound a little impressed how
dang is playing so quickly even though i
don't believe
this is his opening yeah these are
crucial decisions and i agree with you
wholeheartedly dorsa he is playing them
like he's familiar with this whole
knight h4
construct uh
how did the how did the engine like the
immediate b3 i thought bishop c6 was no
it's fine yeah completely fine yeah both
bishops e6 and b3 but going down down
the line right bishop c6 with the idea
of preparing b3 or b3 immediately the
end just think both are good now i
expect five to take with the pawn i
can't imagine somebody taking with the
bishop but the engines don't think
there's a difference okay because
engines
i expect knight c6 with the strategical
humongous threat of knight before
killing this bishop right the engine
wants to repeat but i don't care what
the engines say knight seven five is
what he wants to go uh g takes is now
playable but not the best okay rookie
eight is playable and then now that you
did all this
you have ideas uh the engine wants to go
queen d2 maybe try to threaten something
on the king's head still not really sure
what it is
doesn't like the move b4 very much not
in this move and not in the move before
the idea is that if you take and go d5
anyway you start suffering with this
knight here wants to bring the knight
immediately back
because at some point of course if the
attack dies we're not talking about a
position where the attack dies the game
goes on this attack dies this knight
dies
i mean this this coordination in the
king side will not last forever it's not
doing anything except defending each
other so you're giving me a free hand in
the rest of the board this attack needs
to work right or you retreat the knight
at some point b3 currently on the board
favi might be thinking for a little bit
maybe he's just walking around i expect
him to take on b3 quickly whatever his
decision is
fascinating game guys absolutely
fascinating game absolutely and
yesterday
we want to say that for you we're very
happy that we had a very special guest
mvl coming up we also have another
special guest today and his name is
jonathan tisdale now i first met the tiz
back in 1976. we played in memphis
tennessee together in the u.s
junior championships and what
a junior championship it was it was
eight player round robin
the winner was a fellow by the name of
mark diesen
mark diesen went on to win the world
junior championship
that year in 1976 and today they give
the grand master title to the player
who's the world junior champion in those
days it was very very hard
to become a grand master
and from the group of eight players
six became grandmasters wonderful
two became iams
one of the im's funnily enough was mark
deason he passed away early in life he
had an accident
but
it was an amazing junior championship
jonathan thistle became a grand master
today jonathan tisdale lives in norway
where he's seen
the magnus carlson boom and he is the
captain of the norwegian open
team
and he's written some absolutely
marvelous books the first book i ever
wrote
was five crowns and i
he was my co-author
and he will be our guest at 10 30. you
don't want to miss tis because we have
been talking about magnus carlsen will
he
or won't he
uh play for yeah well that's the guy
that says
interviews
uh anastasia now in madrid will be
feeding us more interviews during the
broadcast but we also would like to
invite you
our audience to join us uh social media
ask questions to any of our panel
members we we know all tell little so
we'll share as we can
and we have one right now let's go for
it dorsa do the honors
youtube user
um dollar sorry
dol rita i don't
yeah well you did it good though sorry
if magnus opts not to defend his title
is he doing a disservice to the game or
is he making a good strategic decision
living while on top well i have to say
jump right in we talked about that a
little bit yesterday because i had a
similar you know i asked what would you
change if you had all the power in the
world and what would you change about
this format and you kind of decided with
magnus's stand that the format does need
to be changed so i feel like i don't
think magnus is quitting chess by any no
he's just asking for a specific like hey
guys i'm done with this format i want it
to be different so i don't think he's
doing a disservice he's just standing up
for what he believes now will that hurt
or her will that help or hurt his cause
only time will tell well
but the question was also is he doing
chess at a disservice because let's face
it magnus is
the talk of the town he's the biggest
star in the world of chess he withdraws
himself from a world championship with
match with 2 million euros you've got a
lot of angry sponsors saying wait a
minute wait a minute
i'm paying millions of euros to get my
name my product out in front and if
magnus walks away we're going to get
half
of the audience members and we're going
to lose the whole of norway jump right
in alejandro your thoughts about this
very salient question
i don't think it's a salient question
because this
am i doing a disservice to chess never
crosses magnus's mind
he's worried about himself as he should
be i think the cycle is grueling
i think that at some point he needs to
stop
and if a world champion doesn't step
down at some point and say guys this is
ridiculous it's never going to change
it's never ever going to change
i it might even be a service to chess
honestly that you have a world
championship match and at some point we
just get rid of it
of course there's a lot of controversy
around it
we love our matches we've been having
matches since the game started
but we have to modernize there are some
things that we need to do differently
this match format as attractive as it is
for us and having this crown jewel is so
cool
but man if even the world champion
doesn't want to defend it
how realistic is it
and magnus himself has said that
sometimes you're too smart to be a chess
player you have so many other interests
the problem with the world championship
match is not the match itself is that
the preparation leading up to it usually
takes four to six months
and it's every two years not to mention
that you're preparing for other
tournaments playing other tournaments
you do not do anything in your life
except chess
until the world championship ends world
championship itself is going to take an
extreme toll on you
so
yeah i understand why we love it because
it's our pinnacle but man the players
they don't love it when i talked to fabi
after the match
he was of course disappointed about the
result but man he was relieved it was
all over he just felt that the amount of
work the amount of stress i mean we felt
it and i wasn't even playing i was just
coaching right uh it was it was tough so
i'm not surprised magnus was other
interest i mean the guy is right now on
a flight to vegas to play the world
series of poker night really cool
so he he definitely has other interests
that are not necessarily chess and i
think one of our guests brought up that
you know he at some point might want to
have a family and you think about the
world championship but you're just gone
forever right how do you do that so i
don't know i don't think it's a
disservice to chess i don't think it
should be part of the question that
magnus has to himself he needs to look
out for magnus carlsen that should be
his priority number one
yeah
okay well i think that's uh really uh an
important uh issue and we'll be talking
about it more i just wanted to say this
one story quickly i'm going to go to the
duda game in just a moment this one
story jonathan tisdale
was the reporter
for reuters in the world championship
match 1984
1985 gary kasparov anatoly karp off
their first match it lasted six months
oh
and it was aborted after 48 games with
no result
jonathan he explained that he had been
in moscow for six months he lost his
apartment he lost his girlfriend
he learned to speak russian
all by reporting on
the world championships
as meatloaf would say two out of three
ain't bad now let's just go to the dude
again
i'm so sorry because i i was reading
just i'm i'm i'm like in so many
different chess groups on facebook so i
was just reading up a little and there
was a new format about the women's world
championship that was i believe
announced yesterday now alejandra will
probably know more than that than i do
but i believe that um because there was
in the recent years they were like uh
women's world championship was the
knockout event so the winner of the
knockout would take all and then they
were like well we don't like that format
why don't you do candidates like the
guys right and i believe they did that
for a cycle and they still didn't really
think that was enough so they they
finalized a different decision i believe
that's like two different groups and the
winner of those two different vita can't
say it
so i'll go ahead and say it thank you
there is no official position on why
this happened but what they did is they
took the candidates from the women's
which worked exactly like this 14 rounds
everybody plays each other winner plays
julian june who is waiting as the world
reigning champion right uh the issue was
that you have russian players and you
have ukrainian players which is not
happening in this tournament so they
separated them into knockouts and
surprisingly the russian players none of
them are playing ukrainian players and
somehow they wouldn't until the finals
i missed out on that part so thank you
for clarifying that for me because i was
wondering why did they change it they
just finalized a different decision like
with the year before
so thank you coach
i'm sensing politics
you know
one of the things that i find really
funny in trust forums is when they say
that politics should be taken out of
chess we're not political in this show
because we like focusing on the chess
sure but to think that politics doesn't
affect chess is ludicrous
right here we've been having political
discussions and politics have been
affecting the world of chess
forever and sports or
ever specifically in our game
yeah but especially our game yeah
because it was uh during the cold wars a
political hot potato and the soviets
prided themselves on
their
dominance of the world of chess they
said
our communism is better than the
capitalism and as proof positive look at
our formidable grand masters western
grand masters hahaha so when bobby
fischer came along one of the problems
that the soviets had is the common man
in the street in moscow said
what's wrong with our system
that the american capitalists can beat
us at our game
so chess has always had a very very
powerful uh political
component in it i just wanted to turn
our attention to a game we haven't seen
at all timor
timor showing his flexibility as white
he plays this quiet ready
yeah with the double fianchetto with b3
something that i've been witnessing a
shack
amongst others playing and again a very
very quiet four versus four
pawn structure on the king side two
versus two these kinds of pawn
structures you get very often from
queen's gambit accepted um slight
advantage for white i think white's
pieces are actually e it's it's easier
for white to play but so this is so big
this is the change between the 80s the
90s and the early
and the 2022 engines right yeah i mean
zero zero they just said nothing but
white has nothing in this but why why
should white have anything in this
position the knight is going to come to
d7 i must much develop the cur yeah
there's nothing and usually you can say
that this bishop on g2 has pressure
against the pawn structure on b7 and a7
that bond structure sailed i have a
bishop on b7 there's nothing that duda
should be worried about yeah all right
and again yesterday this remarkable
three victories one draw
and
you know there is young christophe duda
comes in the tournament all guns blazing
and just has a terrible event
until he plays fabi and he plays his
best
game of the tournament anastasia caught
up with duda yesterday and asked him
about his first victory in the
candidates let's hear what he had to say
first of all congratulations on your
victory today it's a so weighted victory
for you what can you say about the game
against fabi
yes i'm of course very extremely happy
to win the game because i don't have a
feeling i've played particularly well in
this tournament
i'm not that pleased with the style
wall because i think i was
basically crashing at some point after
like 30 moves and
kind of ruin it i mean
i i could have done something uh
something better for sure earlier and
but then i decided you know just to
develop and play natural moves and but
somehow i mean i didn't see a follow-up
and
yeah and i mean i i got low on time it
was kind of tense but
um fabiano was in bigger um bigger china
than me and
yeah i started playing since she was
some tricks which was uh
i mean like a very i mean a decent try
for sure
and and he uh
i mean just blended
in 14 months or 39 so he was kind of
lucky actually
but overall a part of that weak moment
it's kind of
yes it's very nice because i also was
the last player not to win
i mean who won actually so
yes i mean it's a nice nice feeling of
course do you feel that they catch this
tournament
and there we go so what uh
we we again had some problems with the
sound there but what uh yandudo was
saying is that around move 30 he was
just killing it he said i was crushing
and then he kind of came up with a time
wasting
maneuver where he
let me start so right around here he
said
i'm killing it
and
then he kind of came up with this time
wasting maneuver of moving his queen
and fabi somehow is crawling his way
back into the game and then comes this
move f2 f4 where he explains he has to
play for some cheapos and after knight
c5 boom
this huge move knight f3 and he's back
in the driver's seat he goes on to win a
very nice game
and alejandro
i mean if you're in fabi's shoes you're
just sitting there saying to yourself
what a blow i mean
i he's playing against a guy who hasn't
won the won a game and suddenly duda
puts it all together
oh that's the thing about this
tournament everybody's so strong
you just can't mess up like this right
and the way that favi played yesterday
was a little too happy i mean g5 h5
let's go
you can't do that against duda he will
sit down and defend he will sit down and
find the best resources we know that
when he started playing like this g5 h5
then just hated it right they just hated
it and dude have found all the good
moves he's such a good player
duda is and it's
surprising to us that he didn't have a
single win before yesterday because the
style that duda has is risky he plays
active chess he loves his complications
he can beat anybody he's beating magnus
on more than one occasion it's because
he likes taking those risks the fact
that he only had draws or losses more
was more of a testament that he was not
in shape that he wasn't able to finish
off good games that he was blundering
away into bad positions like he did
against richard rapport
and speaking of form let's take a look
at this game between fabi and dingler
because after b3 which i expected five
to respond instantly to bobby actually
thought for 17 minutes whoa to take on
b3 so i'm not sure about that one they
took with the bishop he took with the
bishop you gotta take this is the only
point of the move
c takes b3 i think that's all very
logical and now the question will be how
do you proceed for white we've seen some
ideas uh involving knight seven f5 but
it has to come at some point remember
i'm worried this will get stuck forever
right uh for now i don't see a real
threat i would expect this bishop to go
somewhere just so i can attack b3 uh
what other logical moves do i have i
have bishop a5
attacking the rook i'm a little worried
of leaving this knight undefended though
perhaps the bishop is fine where it is
on d8
i think that's where i would go i would
either go bishop c6 i would start
considering a move like d5 right i don't
know if it's a good move or it's a bad
move but i would consider this move
right it starts putting pressure on e4
it starts asking questions from the
knight on g7 the engines think it's a
stupid move of course
but it's the type of moves that you
start looking at i have the pair of
bishops you're stuck here let me open up
the center
this is certainly a direction in which
diglern is going to look at now it might
not be a good move right now but it
might be a good move eventually where
you liberate all of your pieces no
matter the pawn structure
because yeah of course if you get a
knight here tonight here after d5 you're
great but this knight on g7 isn't coming
to c4 anytime soon the dynamics of the
position might mean that d5 at some
point will be a good move for now the
engines just want to move the bishop off
the b-file and attack not attack
directly but put pressure on b3 i think
that's a very logical continuation
and
again their head-to-head lifetime
match-up score is two wins for fabi3
for a dingler in and a seven draw so
these players are very very very tight i
just wanted to ask you about that
position
again i'm with you alejandro i think the
knight on g7 the longer it stays there
the more likely it's just going to not
move ever
if if white goes knight f5 and tries to
redirect his knight to e3 how do the
computer like bishop a8
knight f5
uh if you go rookie eight i don't know
if you do and then knight e3 yeah and
then you reposition that did i just
think of this as equal equal yes the
black has compensation for the pawn but
no more you can't even attack my pawn
further with queen v7 but the engines
even though you can't give it away you
can play queen d2 and knight c4 or
something like that right you can just
say look your rooks they're not doing
that much anyway okay this is an ugly
move yeah it's like greedy as it gets
right
but it defends the pawn right and more
importantly it kills the activity
of the rook on beating the queen on b7
specifically on the b file the game kind
of goes on finally the engines think d5
is a good move thank you engines for
finally yeah and validating
as i'm being told bishop c6 was played
but these are the kind of things we
might see the knight eventually returns
right this is a little bit weakened and
this knight can now finally head to c4
right where it has a purpose bishop c6
is on the board right now um
i think knight 7f5 still makes a lot of
sense to me and knight e3 followed you
still can't take on f5 i think that's
very clear right and yeah that's one of
many possibilities the end just want to
play a5 nobody's ever going to play that
ever right and watch five played but a5
doesn't make any sense to me well i
guess it just takes care of bishop a5
i'm worried that bishop a5 will come
with bishop take nine five that's what
i'm worried about right
uh we're gonna have to wait and see
bishop c6 the position according to the
end just is just equal it's a mess i
have to ask what if queen of three right
now quid f3 is a move i mean you you
could take right well
didn't like taking it don't lose the
board that was the board take i assume
that you have to go back knight three h5
doesn't work
knight
takes e4
that's a visual disgusting wait so if i
take with the rook at five i guess right
jesus jeez
yeah it kind of works you're missing
that bishop on a2 i can tell you right
you're right
it's a big difference this is why the
move b3 is so good right you might be
thinking what was the bishop doing the
bishop does don't worry about that
uh after rook takes b3 the engines say
you just should just repeat
knight f5 or k8 knight g7 black could
play on with rook takes b2 and they felt
like it uh but
either way i don't think queen f3
is the best move in this position just
because rook takes b3 comes with a
direct threat yeah that knight takes e4
is such a strong threat in that position
that you don't get the chance to build
up on the king side the way that you did
in other variations but yeah salient
question right you we've looked at this
queen f3 movement so often right it
makes sense to look at it here
well
and once again why is this
uh game so important because there's a
huge fight dorset wow for second place
these three are just
i think uh by the end of today we should
have a better idea for the who's gonna
be second yeah no question about it and
fabi versus ding it's dominated
pardon me it's dominating our discussion
but there's one other guy
in the field hikaru nakamura who's
saying my game's important too guys
don't ignore me let's jump to see what's
going on in the game between richie
and hicaro it seems to me that the
players are actually playing
all the
lines of theory the main main main lines
and it's it strikes me that uh
we've been here before
in
other games alejandro i've played this
fashion cop all my life i can tell you
that this is not a theoretical position
it cannot looks like a theoretical
position
but it's not but it's not it's combining
little pieces and parts of different
fashioning cuffs and putting them
together this idea of playing g3 and
bishop g2 is actually not very common in
this move order if we go back a couple
of moves when hikaru did play the move
g3 which he played after a think
is because he's shining away from the
main lines i mentioned the move a3 it's
become very popular this move a3 just
print one b4 uh i could argue team in
the main line nowadays bishop e2 is very
very common you just can you can develop
the bishop immediately just develop it
immediately and the old main line is to
play a4 super sharp stuff you go a4 take
on a4 knight c b4 you take here you take
with the pawn bishop d7
dozens and dozens of games hikara
himself has played this with white
against duboff more than once
and
it's just a line it goes on and on and
on and on as far as i know it goes to a
draw
right now theoretically it goes to a
draw but you know with certain traps
here and there for black
g3 is very uncommon in this position
it's common when you have the pawn on c4
and the pawn on b4 yes that's what i was
just going to say because i'm a c4
player
so if you go back here and you go c4 b4
knight c2 bishop g5 here the move well
not bishop g5 immediately but you get
the idea that you play bishop g5 at some
point
and g3 is going to be very very common
that allows white to play h4 and bishop
h3 to trade that bishop yes or to put
the bishop on g2 and just chill
both which are good but
playing the move c3 and g3 is very rare
to the point where after castles bishop
g2 a5 which is a logical move castle's
on 97 we only have like 15 games
on the database already so very well
known players including virginia
zvezhnikov himself played this with
black against irwin lamy wonderful and
in a clash of generations we have a lot
of uh interesting battles here
particularly gufault against devretsky
back in 1980
wow so
it's been seen but it's very rare
because supposedly this is completely
fine for black knight ce3 was played and
everybody takes on e3
richard thought for a little bit play
them with bishop e6 which looks fine to
me as well
and after knight takes e7 which hikaru
has played
i don't exactly see why compared to a
normals fashiony cuff white would have
anything in this position normally this
is like this
yep c4 and b4 and then you can argue you
know d5 is so strong and there is no
counter play whatsoever
down on the queen side because you can
always block that position up that gives
you a free hand on the kingside to go
even go h4 maybe go f4 or just maneuver
around in this one in particular i'm i
feel that at some point i'll get in b4
and if you don't have control over c4
because i can always take on e3
why is white better now for example if i
take on e7 and even if you go like
knight d5 and i just got queen b7 this
is exactly a dream svashnikov right were
you threatening to take on d5 and you
must take with the pawn at some point
right
you cannot take with the pieces the
point on d5 that i'm going to be
threading some rook to c8 and b4 and
then for now i have the pair of bishops
so any opening of this kind of stuff
will favor black right yeah i have two
bishops and i can always chop off that
knight on d5
knight take c7 played i don't
think white has anything
but
it's a long game i think hikar was just
getting richie out of theory out of the
specific theory that he had and he's
going to say
richie you're not a special golf player
show me that you understand the
structures well this is a kind of a
sorry dorset oh no i was just gonna
mention the black's main idea i believe
is either b4 or f5 so
is there a specific timing on which one
to go first never f5
never f5 because there's a bishop on g2
when you have a bishop on e2
then you can consider the break f5 but
remember this bishop is currently
stifled
this pawn is right there so you don't
want to play this in the structures of
g3 and bishop g2 to the point where g3
is a common answer to the g takes f6 f5
variations when f5 is in you play g3
well but if knight d5 is played bishop
takes pawn takes then f5 for black does
become
yeah absolutely if i if the thing is
allowing takes on d5 is a disaster true
there's a disaster strategically for
white because this bishop is just better
than this one as long as the spawn on d5
exists this bishop is not a very good
bishop then i have a freehand boss on
the king side with f5 and on the queen
side with b4 so this is why i think if
you take on e7 id5 is already a mistake
if you don't have knight d5 though
what do you play here well that was my
question uh alejandro
this bishop's of opposite color i agree
when the pawn is on e4 in the current
position if we imagine queen takes e7
uh i've played knight f5 the idea behind
knight f5 obviously is i'm forking the
queen on e7 as well as the pawn on d6
i'm kind of encouraging you to capture
now this is a different position
if this e4 pawn was on d5 i hear you
loud and clear alejandro i think that
position with the e4 pawn on d5 favors
black because of dorsal what you're
saying you get to play f5 as black
you've got a better
bishop than
than white does now on the other hand if
i can capture with the f pawn and on a
good day play queen d3
and my bishop comes to d5
then this bishop isn't going to be as
good looking as my queen on d3 my bishop
on d5 i'm not saying that it's
wonderful and i'm just going to blast
you off the board or anything you will
if you get that bishop to d5 right
exactly i don't think there's a doubt
about that and i think this is where
sveshnikov understanding comes in this
pawn on d6 is
white's target right and black's bane
because you have to keep defending it
exactly what ends up happening very
often in the special cause where you
have everything except for the weakness
on d6 is that sometimes you just don't
defend it you just let it go just let it
go if you play a move like queen let's
put it on a7 it doesn't really matter
where the queen goes but i like a7
because it prevents f4 i think that
would be good understanding and you take
on d6 yes you want a pawn
but if you don't get f e5 i play
something like bishop f6 it's a bit
passive for now but it will kick out
your queen eventually and i have this
pair of bishops right is white actually
better right that's the question that
comes up very often and that's the
reason that richard is thinking because
he could take with the bishop it loses
the tempo in a way because you want to
return with the bishop to g5 right
the other thing richard might be
considering is that after queen takes
knight f5 he might not consider
to give up a pawn what he could be
considering is to take take and go e4
it's very direct and it's very concrete
i get my pawn to e3 i start bothering
you
on the king side and the question starts
looking at these kind of positions is
this pawn
a liability or strength right not so
easy to understand fully right away
right if you get your bishop to f and c5
yeah of course it's a strength but that
bishop is not getting there any time
soon right do i have the time to do it
right and that's where
richard is thinking in this position
exactly
a student
old old student of mine queen takes e7
knight f5 queen a7 daniel stalwagen uh
a top grandmaster from
holland
would say that black is happy
losing the d6 pawn why is black
happy losing the d6 pawn knight f5
queen a7 queen takes d6
bishop f6 well from daniel's point of
view
show me the weakness
in black's point in black's hand
there's no weaknesses in black's camp
two bishops
rook comes to d8 and he says as soon as
black plays b4
this bishop
those rooks on b8 the queen on a7 all
look really good and again no weaknesses
save king
he daniel thinks that this is a kind of
a dream sajnikov where you have a very
easy life as black a remarkable insight
but uh daniel's perspective as daniel
stelvalgen's perspective was was that
when you
get rid of the center the two bishops
really uh exercise their muscles
and uh give great compensation
uh alejandro uh throwing it back to you
we love to fight for second place guys
but remember there's somebody that's in
first let's take a look at his game see
how that was going we lost uh
we lost nepo
after the move knight c3 we had bishop
g4 a move that i like you could exchange
bishops but alireza was like nana i
don't want to change anything today f3
this bishop has to go back of course
it's nice for black to encourage this
move f3 look at the weakness that's left
around the square e3 for example we'll
see shortly that this diagonal is also
weakened bishop retreated to d7 bishop
e2
c6 this break that i was talking about
making this soft on the center no c5
solidifying the center instead c6
weakening it
castles c takes d5 c takes d5 queen v6
this is kind of annoying on the diagonal
king h1 and after rook academy is taking
a long thing probably just out of
preparation and we know how he loves his
long things
it looks like white got some space
advantage but black has his own punches
in knight c4 might be coming at some
point this rook is obviously going to
come to e8 it doesn't feel like his
pieces lack purpose they actually have a
lot of coordination together if you can
get this bishop on e7 participating in
the in the game whether it's on g7 or
somewhere else you wouldn't even think
of a black advantage but we're pretty
far from that the bishop is still stuck
on e7 white does have a lot of moves to
play in the meantime and that's why
leresa is thinking the engine move f4 is
probably the most challenging of course
you have to consider what to do against
knight c4 uh
i think b3 takes rook takes e3 is not so
illogical for both sides because after
bishop g1 bishop f2 is a computer
movement height who plays that bishop g1
you got the same kind of ideas black
successfully traded a couple of nights
which is usually usually good when you
have less space usually you want to
trade pieces when you have less space
that way you can maneuver the rest of
them around a little bit easier however
that was the price knight that black had
in the center on e5 so you have the
strategical concepts right you want to
trade pieces but do you really want to
trade your knight on e5 the enemies
evaluate this as even after the move
queen a5 i think it's still a mess i
like white's chances with so much space
the potential of bishop c4 and trapping
the rook so this is certainly something
that alireza is considering
i don't think he's better but he got a
type of fighting position that he might
like
well that move f4 sure looks like a
challenge uh to be sure but coming in
today's round uh it's a fight at the top
for second place three players in that
fight jan running away with the
tournament can he hold the draw with
black but these three players bobby
versus dingler in today key match up in
this fight for second dorset
and well it's definitely going to be
interesting game but
on different news we have something
special for you oh cue boutique
somebody gave me a board i thought that
was very very nice of them i think i
want to keep this this is really special
what is it uh you know cuba tech has a
lot and a lot of beautiful chess boards
this one in particular is a 2021 st
louis rapid and blitz autographed vinyl
and you can take this piece of chess
history home
it is very beautiful very autographed
and there is a huge selection so you
don't have to just get this one but any
of our um signed chess boards do come
with the certificate of authenticity
takes my english a second yeah okay it's
a challenge for sure but yes it said
only at q boutique no discounts right i
mean
[Laughter]
very very nice vinyl board uh very uh
artistic i've seen a lot of players
uh keep these boards and they put them
in a um
i want to say like a picture case you
know like with the glass
seriously a piece of history you can get
your own history go to q boutique and
we're going to see you on the other side
of the break
oh we leave toward break and we are
about to get unplugged to take this
short term in a break yeah
whoa whoa whoa wait what
g4 by alireza and with that let's go on
break
he came to play
are you guys on the other side
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
[Music]
that's our show now go start yours at
this moment.com
[Music]
you may have heard about st louis's
world-class museums art history science
even
magic
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top
don't let all this family fun slide by
you
whose kids it is
st lou is always exploring anybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
standings before round 11 we had a clear
tournament leader nepo cruising the
victory with four rounds to go he has
seven points but the fight for second
and potentially a world championship
match should magnus now play is intense
bobby playing ding lorin in this round
11 and hikaru playing richie
top chess going on as dorsa i got to
tell you the players in that hikaru game
are following our
formula to this exact moment now the
question is will knight f5
produce
an advantage or not
hikaru
what a roller coaster ride he's had i i
believe in his last four games he's won
three and lost one
and it's been a roller coaster ride
throughout but this move knight f5
is getting our attention and our
thinking
is that you should not be capturing even
though alejandro said you could play
like this
not for the bishop on g5 if the bishop
was on the a7 e g5 g1 you'd be more
you'd be more impressed
in my mouth i never said that
i said it was possible right it was just
complicated i don't know if it's good
liability or an asset yeah i'm just
thinking that even if you did get this
uh
i don't know i just feel like it might
be a little bit easier for for uh to
play for white whereas i really liked
alejandro's move queen a7 just saying go
ahead
uh hikaru if you like
win the pawn on d7
what's your next target after the move
bishop f6 you're a pawn up but look at
these bishops they're looking very very
good the rook is ready to go to d8 the
pawn is ready to go to b4 and you're
going to have a very difficult time
proving that your extra pawn is
meaningful so that's that's a very
exciting game going on but for me the
fabi game with dingler in uh
alejandra i want to say the last move
king h8 is a clear and definitive
statement by ding he wants to play rook
g8 and evac and you know kick that
knight uh get that knight to uh lead the
square g7 what is the computer's
assessment of the move king h8 excellent
move excellent move the engines are
saying and let me explain why i was
trying i was hitting myself against the
wall because here after the move bishop
c6 right i saw the top engine moves and
i didn't get him
i didn't quite understand a5 and i
certainly did not understand rookie 2.
top engine move
didn't get that move at all right and i
finally realized it
when fabi played the move rook c1 the
engines were saying king h8 and now i
understand why it wants to move the rook
out of b1 because after king h8
there's this tactic knight e6 okay
if i move my rook
there's problems rookie 8 knight e takes
d8 and no matter what you take with i go
bishop g5 and i pin you on the diagonal
that's unpleasant easy
so you can't move the rook that part is
clear take it with the pawn doesn't make
sense might as well take with the queen
bishop takes f8 and in this position
this is an exchange sacrifice except
black has to move bishop a5
you attack this bishop which has to move
right and you can attack you're
attacking this rook right so you go back
i take and i take and at the end of the
day i take on b3 what's happened i got
all the initiative yes i have weak dark
squares but your pieces aren't hitting
those squares just yet i'm hitting this
pawn this one and this pawn
you are the one that's weak in this
position as white material is completely
even
some issues of course on the dark
squares this is not a game over by any
means i think if this panos on g7 and
this bishop would be somewhere else then
maybe you can think about a clear black
advantage as it is right now because of
the weaknesses on the dark source
there's counter play right but at that
point we're talking about counter play
with the rook on e2
none of this is possible
you go king h8 96 here here this bishop
has no discoveries right rookie two i
think is a completely inhuman move
but king hate now
forces white to find a direct way of
play because if you wait one more move
i'm gonna put my rook on g8 and take
that and i'm gonna take that knight man
if i'm greedy i'll play knight g8 and
i'll take that bishop right so there's a
direct tactical
uh problem for white to solve either one
of black's pieces coming to the g8
square do i want to play knight seven f5
and sacrifice my knight like we have
done in pre in many occasions here i
couldn't move my rook
or do i want to play 96 and go straight
into that variation i think that favi
must feel his position is unpleasant
because he comes in with the novelty he
comes in with knight h4 he sticks knight
on g7 and he's 24 minutes down
compared to dingley run in this position
certainly as a fabi fan i'm worried okay
uh
dorsey did you have a question because i
have a question oh we'll go ahead yeah
the question that i have for you after
king h8 you've been prescribing this
move
knight e6
uh queen takes e6 wonderful explanation
of why
rookie 2
is a top engine move to sidestep bishop
a5 but for just a moment i'm looking at
that bishop on f8 and if i didn't have
the move bishop a5
i would be worried that the bishop is
potentially trapped after the move
knight g8 i wouldn't want to play
a position where
i i i play bishop takes d6 uh i'm saying
that uh black would be in my opinion for
choice after bishop is knight g8 a scare
it's definitely a scare but i don't see
how you're trapping my bishop if i go
queen d2
queen d2 ah
and i think that in the position that we
have in the game the move d4 should be
considered
but like d4 i think is just very strong
unless i'm missing something d4 yeah and
then you continue with e5
uh to rescue the bishop and rescue the
bishop this way but i think we need to
also rescues the bishop i think the
bishop is
a little bit scary on f8 but i don't
think it's actually trapped
okay good good
good because i was getting uh more
concerned
uh for uh fabi's position
so again knight e6 queen takes e6 bishop
takes f8
bishop a5
the bishop drops back to h6 you capture
capture and at the end of the day queen
takes b3 we understand why uh fabi
might
have some doubts about his previous play
you know by the way i was i was saying
hikaru was doing really well dingleran
right if he ends up winning this will be
his third to win in a row wow that's an
uh what a hat
what a what a hat trick that would but
wait a minute if ding were to get three
then
fabby would be the one coughing up the
points that would be his third loss he's
had to
he had black and he had some
difficulties uh back-to-back losses but
uh this is huge uh where did w where did
did something go wrong where the edges
don't think anything has gone wrong okay
even that position after queen takes b3
we go down this line
okay the engines don't think this is a
clear advantage as i was saying they
just think it's messy even the move
queen a5 is playable okay where you
should probably play queen b2 if you
start pawn hunting this queen gets to c7
yeah this queen might be hunting pawns
this guy is going to be hunting the king
nice you don't want to you don't want to
allow that with a bishop on h6 you
really need to retreat at this point but
then we play it out queen d2 yes you can
take on b2 in this position but again
i'm going this way right yeah
this is kind of stuck the angel's saying
this is lost for black so because there
are dark square resources against the
black king white isn't supposedly worse
or at least not too much worse
in this position after queen takes b3
both sides with chances we're not
talking about any advantage for black
just yet nothing has gone wrong for fabi
okay uh dangler has played good moves
five has played decent moves the engine
wasn't in love with roxy one but they
didn't think it was a bad move okay now
i moved to the engines do you think is a
bad move
already ferruccio's g4 that's when we
left
him a long time to come up with this
move and i'm going to put up that
graphic because i made a producer make
me a graphic i'm going to use it again
what did alareza do last night he stayed
up till 6 a.m playing 30 second chess
against dania nardinski in a marathon
250 game match 108 to 142 those are
unreal numbers bullet or 30-second
they're both considered bullet i think
on leachate so technically they are
under the same time control
i agree that they should be different
time controls perhaps in leeches they're
different wow i have to i have to
actually check that out but those are 30
second games so you start with 30
seconds your opponent starts with 30
seconds no increment no nothing nada
108 to 142 i mean they would they must
have driven each other crazy
and i think a move like g4
that's a 30-second move
30-second move that's a 30-second chess
move wow where you go g4 and try to made
your opponent well i have a question why
did he go g4 f4 i mean i just despised
that knight on e5 was f4
f4 as we saw before uh he played g4 yeah
it's a top engine move but g4 is very
direct but
well g4 opponents will play h6 they're
not going to let you play g5
well yeah no i understand what you're
saying dorset yeah you go to g4 the guy
goes h6 okay what's your next move uh
we're going to have to find out because
alireza is doing a very already thing
that has not worked for him in this
tournament he plays a committal move
his opponent plays the only logical
reply you really can't allow g5 in this
position this knight doesn't have
squares right g5 you have to play h6
right and now lereza is in another long
think 17 minute think after an empo
played h6
yeah the only logical follow-up to my
eyes is rook g1
so that you can play either
f4 or g5 i think rook g1
is playing for g5 uh
it's it's it's the type of move i would
make g4 is the type of move i make if i
had to burn all my bridges and i
absolutely absolutely had to win yes
you know like everything else is death
uh g4 is
frankly an overreach i i think it's a
bad move uh f4 yeah i could get behind i
actually could get behind a4 yeah i
think a4 is a typical move for the
structure too right because what happens
in this positions very often is that
black runs out of squares right this
queen is ideal on b6 it is it doesn't
have a better square on the entire board
than on b6 after you play a4 you want to
get rid of it you want to get rid of
this queen you want to force it to c5
where it's easier to hit with maybe a
rook to c1 later on you want to force it
to b4 where it can be hit by knight c2
you want to force it to a square where
it can be hit on b6 is very difficult to
hit right so a4
encourages this queen to go away and if
you play the move a5 for example thank
you for the b5 square bingo exactly so
a4 would have been a logical move i i
don't see anything wrong with it i think
f4 is also a logical move with a
different approach to chess
and g4 is just the let's go nuts so it's
going crazy right it's a move of course
you calculate it and you analyze it
because it could just be very dangerous
for black especially if you don't have
h6 this knight might just be trapped
but you do have h6 and even if you do go
with the move rook g1 what's your follow
up rook fv8 is the engine move i think
that's very logical you want to just
want to put the bishop on f8 right use
the fact that you have the g file g5 for
example
thanks the engine hates this so much
no i do too i i mean especially with b2
hanging your queen is on b6 no i don't
like i i i have to play knight f5 yeah
you have to play knight f5 go for this
initiative but nobody is forcing me to
take this no that would be a terrible
move that would open up the g f i don't
even know how bad this is the engine
thinks it's equal wow
yeah but i i don't think i don't think
anybody takes an f5 when it's not
mandatory just take on a fade keep this
on the back of your mind and ace up your
sleeve eliminate the knight when you
must
for now i don't have to the bishop on f8
covers everybody here i'm not
threatening g6 because knight takes h6
and i actually don't even know if i want
to play g6 i'm just chilling on the on
this side of the board i might even play
the move knight g6 cover up
right and use the fact that you've left
yourself a lot of weakness i got the
active rooks on the proper files
i'm going to start hitting this pawn on
d5 at some point at some point i might
even hint that i'm just going to take
that knight and then take on d5 right
and then i don't care i'm up down i'm
down the exchange the position is so
loose for the white pieces that it might
fall apart
easily easily
okay after g4 sorry
i mean i'm trying to
make the follow-up of rook g1 uh if you
have another suggestion for ali raza
beside rook g1 i'm all ears uh chief let
me just put it the only thing that i'm
thinking about is you know in the last
two days we've been talking about the
the lazy grand master chest
i feel like poor he's not there yet he
needs he still has too much ambitions
too much calculation too much energy
you know he instead of doing something
like a4 a5 and just harassing the queen
or f4 harassing the night he's i think
his level of harassment
okay again i i'm looking for a move
uh so i'm trying to be consequent to g4
if i don't follow up
soon with something
excuse me if i don't play right now
something concrete g4 is just simply
terrible it's like a bad move that
lifts my pawn shield that makes
weaknesses so
in the words of somebody famous let's go
crazy uh f4 now uh the idea is that in
case you do take on g4
you're walking into maybe a trap with
h2h3 it's not the end of the variation
by the way there
there could be
some tactics going on but g4
f4 if you move your knight as something
we saw a moment ago without the move g4
we did see a trade now again put this
pawn back on g2 put this pawn back on h6
we were actually looking at these
variations with the bishop maybe coming
to g1 now in this position if i've
actually got in the move g4 you got in
h6 i played f4 you played knight here
here i might again
trying to be very consequent about
what's going on in the position i might
be looking to play the move g5 i feel
like i'm forcing tactics when i'm not
well developed by the way i mean black's
development is clear i'm sorry how did
we get here uh the f4 immediately in
this with g4 h6 f4 aha
um
again uh i'm i'm forcing the tactics
when black's development is complete the
r my as white my rooks are not connected
so i can easily imagine
that something going wrong here for
white but i'm trying to follow up for
ali reza if he doesn't play
right now i mean this is going to be
another score for nepo
where he just re
reacts you know it's like
people
are forcing nepo to beat themselves
it's like a suicide it was what he did
the first time like alireza came with
this idea in the night or right he
forced napo to sacrifice
material which he loves doing anyway
right and then ella reza got blown off
the board right
so uh i'm thinking
he's going to play f4 uh
what's the computers and i i don't doubt
there is a refutation alejandro but i'm
trying to justify no knight c4 is very
strong even knight f takes g4 blundering
the piece
yes h3 knight e3 the engines say that
even this is fine for black better for
black just straight up down a piece
you're yeah but you got two pawns and
i've got a
i've got a traffic and the main thing is
that d5 is hanging once d5 hangs
everything kind of falls apart i go like
a move like yeah knight takes and that's
the third
pawns yeah yeah
you sure are that's the problem so
um i'm trying to find a
right now a justification for
g4 and i tried i already gave you the
justification for g4
i'm sorry 250 games played overnight
until 6am
groggy
punch drunk
wow
guys
this is napo's tournament
yeah it's just like
everything goes together so well in
order to win a tournament
you need luck and not just a little a
lot of it
you got a gallows and gallons i mean
at some point he's going to look at it
like why didn't i just buy a lottery
ticket
why didn't i go to vegas and play in the
super bowl of uh poker well that's where
that's where magnus is that's where the
top chess player of the world is he
might be looking like he knows what he's
talking about wow by the way just on
that note i have seen something on
youtube
where magnus had played in a norwegian
poker tournament got to
what they call the final table wonderful
got knocked out of the final table but i
mean qualifying
uh shows some skills um
what's his what what's the over and
under on magnus's performance in vegas
what's the expectation i have absolutely
no idea how you play alejandra you're my
top agent with these matters you know
jonathan tisdale around soon yes
yes we will put the issue too and by the
way jonathan chistel i think he's coming
up at 10 30 our time i don't know what
that is uh european time by the way but
uh i do uh stand to stay around for tiz
he's quite the storyteller as well uh
some good stuff we'll keep an eye
because i want to see what ali reza is
going to do
uh against one g4 i want to go to the
hikaru nakamura just going to ask thank
you you can read my mind
how about that
queen
d8 okay we i
think we're thinking about queen a7
queen d8 um
something about that move i find
remarkable of all the squares i could go
to
like i would be very tempted to lay the
trap queen d7 nice queen d6 double
question mark
no it's not even double question mark
you actually get up oops i apologize uh
yeah i would imagine queen d7 queens c7
i might uh i might convince myself i
don't know how or why wait the the did i
that line worker did you bluff me queen
d7 queen takes d6 yeah bishop takes a
five queen takes e5 right
i mentioned that yeah
that i wouldn't you wouldn't want it it
does work actually right yeah
i i thought i saw a trick for black but
i yeah isn't that amazing that you don't
really see those two bishops yeah being
kind of lined up just perfectly like
that shish kebab there you go
uh queen d8 okay again
we might see this uh queen takes d6 and
in this line
uh maybe this is a little bit easier for
black
this might be easier for black but i
think it's even better if you throw in
g6 instead of knight takes f5 let's keep
the bishops uh pardon me right g6 here
g6
ah me like
yeah
four's the trade yeah there's no way you
can sacrifice this knight right right so
you force the trade keep the bishops and
then you go rogue detour anyway right
well in the words of borat i appreciate
very nice
rook takes yeah this looks like a very
comfortable game i'm gonna say equality
maybe plus
equality for black so queen d8 on the
board and in this case then if i take
with the knight
you have you have choices you have rook
d6
i don't know uh okay you might even be
wondering if you lose a piece right
if i go g6 yeah
i just trap your knight i say your
knight is not going anywhere well g6
what if i mean what if white just goes
f4 yeah baby
dorsa all right
love your aggressive uh
you're such a nice person where does all
this hostility this is
like like you're out there killing it
look at this glove f4 f4 okay
okay i got dorsal on my side you got
your chest engines let's go you want you
want that
i like my chances there i got dorsa g6
f4 yeah the engine's saying this is
nearly winning for black but
literally yeah but you can kind of do it
you go check
ping h1 only move right takes takes
bishop b7 and again oh rook f38 first
bishop b7 is also good but rook fd8
forces you to go e5 okay this is kind of
ugly don't want to go there don't want
to go there so you go e5 and then bishop
e7 and again the issue with the knight
not moving because you're queen stuck
the rooks can't join the fray you're
going to lose that pawn and you're going
to lose it for free and the remaining
structure is just better black better
black i like the move queen d8 it's not
the top engine move the engine just very
coolly evaluates that the pawn wasn't
worth anything and gives it up for free
he it doesn't need to play the move g6
or anything like that but the top engine
move is also to just say you know what i
don't want that pawn
go h4 no way even bishop e7 is playable
you can still play bishop f6 and just
sacrifice it like that and it says this
pawn
it's on your way you want to play rook
fd8 and control the default don't touch
it just go queen d2 or something like
that put pressure on the point and only
take it once it's a nicer
pawn for with and he's taking on d6
immediately i'm a little surprised about
this um
he must be planning f4h for if you go on
id3 you're just worse right yeah yeah
this is actually even bad for black for
what
this bishop's trash right and you can't
play like this
no he will have to play something along
the lines of f4 or h4 in this position
try to use some tactics while the bishop
on g5 can be hit but i feel you yasser i
feel this is a position in which only
black can be better exactly we just kind
of pass that eq equality into advantage
black and again for hikaru who i would
love to see his line score because he
has been on some kind of a roller
coaster ride he's got demons uh that he
has to deal with look at what's going on
here he could be on his fourth decisive
game in a row dorset yeah yeah he had
the scene see as soon as i joined the
stream all the draws stopped
want to perform for you i mean he scored
two out of three which meatloaf would
say bad but uh it's all about today and
what is he going to deliver
uh for richie by the way
he's had
well also ups and downs more downs of
lates than ups and you know once again
uh he could play the role of a spoiler
to hikarus like i want to play for the
world championship
um boy queen d8 and quite question my
apologies like let's say point x we just
you know exchange everything either with
g6 or with queen i think it's g6 i think
it's g6 so we all like g6 and it's hard
to resist g6
you can go for a peace sacrifice for
three pawns but in the words of ben
larson nobody believes you the two
bishops in that position will overwhelm
the three pawns so
we've got a trade yes so let's say we
would do that too okay and now we're
back to
either
h4 93
alejandro is already dismissed like get
out of here bishop takes e3 rook to d2
uh black is for choice
f4 looks terrible what else do we have
what i'm trying to understand this are
we thinking so because i know the
engines are like uh zero zero or black
is just a little bit better are we
thinking realistically is black going to
push for a win or is it compensation
slash if white plays bad i'll i'll gain
something i'm trying to need some more
evaluation well
give me a move for white uh
we know rook d2 is coming so how are you
going to deal
as white
against rook d2 f4 or h4
okay so you i think either one is you
got to do something about that bishop
because knight c3 is off uh 93 can't
happen right so okay so imagine you go
f4 just for a second right
and now we
[Music]
something about the structure is going
to be really ugly at the end of the day
i can imagine that white is going to be
in the words of
johnny walker cruising for a bruising
let's imagine we take
you take
i move my bishop and we just ask you
where are you going to move your knight
if you move your knight backwards
rook d2 i'm playing you a visit
with the move rook d2 don't forget
again daniel
stellwagen will be the first to tell you
that when black gets to play b5 b4 these
bishops
are razor sharp
i'd almost be tempted as
as white here to return the pond at once
and
uh
you know
try to make a draw or run out
of the tournament hall i'm not happy
with uh what what's going on in this
game for hikaru help me out uh if you
will uh alejandro is it
is
is there a safe route to equality for
white i'm looking for it now the engines
are saying that there is let's take a
look okay g6 takes takes and it does
like to move f4 i don't like this move
h4 the engine say it's also okay i just
don't like this structure
where if i ever pick up this pawn
that's not nice it's really not nice
this bishop again it's it's a septic
bishop it just never improves right uh i
think that hikaru's looking at this line
with that f4
okay uh the engines are saying taking on
f5 is fine you can do something like
this but at least here the bishop's
alive
right you have compensation as black
probably not much more than compensation
okay uh f4 instead let's try to take on
f4 right take on f4 and save the bishop
right again you can take and take equal
bishop f6 looks logical to me with the
idea that after knight e3 i have this
move rook d2 if you go rook f2 in this
position i'll take take and why did i
trade off the rooks so i can go b4 and
without the rooks on the board
when you play e5 i can take on c3 why
did i get rid of the rooks so that when
i take i take on b2 and i promote my
pawn nice you don't have two rooks to
defend the b1 square so this is
unplayable and after b4
e5 takes takes check white is up a pawn
and nobody ever
takes white in this position right pair
of bishops this pawn on a2 might be
hanging spot on a5 might just promote
you have an extra pawn that's not worth
anything because it's stuck there this
bishop is going to run to c5 great
position for black right so the engines
are saying that after the move bishop f6
93 is not good play e5
keep
an attack on the bishop of course this
looks ugly
but the angels are saying it's okay
you'll go rook d6 doesn't matter if you
throw in rook d2 first okay
let's discoordinate the rook let's say
and then you take on f6 but because of
all the time that you take on taking on
this pawn i can play a3 cement my pawns
on dark square go bishop f1 start
hitting f b5 perhaps you would take
black a little bit because f4 is weaker
than most other pawns right but it
should really not be a big deal at this
point you would imagine that this is
high probability of a draw unraveling
towards a draw i would say just grab a
link towards a draw absolutely yes we do
have a few moves played yep yeah g6 and
only move of course rook ftxd8 let me
just point out why this is forced why
you couldn't start with a move f4 is
that if i take on f5 here when you take
on d8 i don't take with the rooks yep i
think with the bishop right so you have
to take on d8 that's why this is such an
easy line to calculate g6 you have to
take on d8 right and that indeed has
happened by the way
uh ali reza followed up with a move
that i just didn't even consider i just
thought it was so bad i didn't even i
put rook g1
yeah i put rook g1 on the board i even
tried f4 a moment ago but h2h4 you know
it's funny it's a move that you make in
like 10 seconds right right like if it
doesn't work who cares i played it on 10
seconds my opponent can figure it out
but you think for 40 minutes
you go g4 h4
40.
well between the two moves i think the
combination of the two moves it was 36
between the two so i wasn't too far off
no that's pretty good uh
alejandro i'm sorry this this move is
almost painful right that looks like
real
uh garbage uh
i mean on earth as always okay i can
move my knight which i'm very very
tempted to do by the way because it sure
looks to me like that's a tempting pawn
i don't think you can afford g5 you're
pawn eating yeah
yeah yeah yeah the spidey sense
how about a difference
please which one nepal played instantly
pardon me i was thinking about the
knight c4 idea because knight c4 yeah
okay going after this guy potentially
guys netball doesn't believe anyone yeah
no there is a played h4 deadpool looked
to the left he looked to the right what
on earth does h4 do
g5 is not a threat trust me g5 is not a
threat that destroys your position total
the knight gets to h5 and yeah all the
last moves by white were terrible so
that doesn't have a thread h4 does not
have a thread on hand right so nepo said
okay if you don't have a thread i'll
develop by rook
open files work on open files this is
how we were taught to play charles
this is terrible no decisive advantage
block no this is the combination of
these moves g4 and h4 i remember i was
in
new york the world champs championship
match uh kasparov versus karpov and a
very very tired exhausted after a
13-hour flight from moscow juan michael
tull
came into my room where he's doing
commentary and ordered himself a drink
and he completely jet lagged
gary kasparov makes a move and and
michael tall just looked to her
like
like that was like
the ugliest movie
and
that's when i'm saying this move h4 i
look at this move and i go oh my gosh
that's uh i have to say painful that
exact face that you made sometimes i do
like little volunteers because i'm
pre-health program and i work with like
tiny babies and one of the things we did
was we're trying to like get there um
feed them like different things see how
they react that exact face was for lemon
oh i feel like that that's fizzl
that that exactly that exact place was
when a baby made for lemonade that's why
they called them lemons when i was young
i couldn't stand lemons later i love
lemonade but at first the first time i
tasted the lemon
somebody
somebody needed to die
if it was bad i never understood when i
read chess life as a kid yeah growing up
in costa rica you know english as a
second language i wasn't really
very familiar with the idioms
there was this in chess like they're
very commonly called a mistake a lemon
yes and i was like why lemons are
delicious
why are they calling them lemons yeah a
lemon was for me always a blunder it was
apparently it was a blunder but terrible
lemon i'm very glad that this got out of
the chest it's not on our chest look at
this
reaction
yeah there you go
oh my god
but what is this young man doing
yeah that's london yeah that is a bad
thing thank you thank you for the
beautiful if you need if you need a baby
replacement you just you just call me
i'm right down the street uh
i am seeing a lemon a blunder i don't
like h4 uh who likes h4
nobody ever no matter what commentary
you're tuning in to no matter who you're
asking no matter which engine no matter
which grand master will tell you that
the move h4 can possibly be any good in
this position right it's so overly
optimistic
yeah you can just throw your pawns in
front of the king without developing
your queen side with the weakness on d5
with the possibility of rook takes c3
opening the center whenever black once
right i mean
i'm actually shocked rook c3 is not a
good move right it probably was
yeah like rook takes c3 you had
mentioned this idea of
sacrificing an exchange because after
knight takes d5 first of all you have a
pawn and minor but thanks
to the pawn going to h4 at the end of
the day
white is the one who is exposing his own
king the bishops are going to naturally
come to their long diagonals i think
rook takes c3 might have been a complete
refutation it just it just thinks that
rook fba is is better yeah but also
i mean again we're piling on here and
sorry to ali ray's fans that we're doing
that but after the move h4 just clear
the cobwebs a bit knight h7 just looks
really
like
does white have to play h5
knight
oh no do you play g5 apparently this
works g5 yeah because if you take and
you take you can't really you can't you
can't even give up the piece if you feel
like oh yeah knight h5 f4 in the game h4
rook f8 well you said a b and you said c
doesn't matter how bad c is
gotta say it why why why dorsa oh i
think i'm um i think my brain got broken
yeah what happened g5 no but a5 is
logical right you play g4 h4 you don't
play g5 what are you doing the the the
g3 square is winking at me so badly yes
it sure is me too i'm gonna have to play
rook
after knight h5 in view of knight g3 i'm
going to have to play rook g1 uh
protecting as you say the g3 square a
ali raza is like he's gambling
he's all in alejandro and i think
he's gonna he's cruising for a bruising
is it as bad as it looks yes yeah yeah
the engine thinks this is terrible you
take on g5 at some point you can take
immediately or before you play knight h5
right but the idea is that you don't
want to allow the opening of the wild
that's pretty clear you cannot take with
the bishop because the moment b2 hangs
that's lights out the position collapses
right you have to take with the pawn but
then you've kind of killed your own
counter play here the engines do think
there's only one precise move to have a
winning advantage everything else is
just a clear advantage okay knight g6
which is not a hard move to find logic
knight hf4 is coming bishop f8 revealing
the rook on the e-file it all comes
together
for black very nicely the only danger is
that this knight ever gets trapped but
you can calculate your way out of that
right f4 never works because just knight
h h takes f4 and it takes very long time
for white to actually defend the square
it's a very weakened square
the knights can't jump to e2 there's a
bishop there the knight actually wants
to stay on d4
terrible
terrible terrible all-around position
for white i have to mention i'm i'm
looking at different websites too so i'm
seeing the nepo's face and he's like
looking at like
he's like looking around a little in the
little camera he's looking at the boards
i think he's
i think he's like this might be a
christmas morning for him exactly gifts
but another another christmas uh morning
because it's been christmas oh yeah it's
been christmas for two weeks of
christmas it seems like
wow
he
currently
seven out of ten a 70 score four games
remaining magic number of nine and nine
and a half to clinch the tournament
and again sorry uh
because i i
i really just i believe made a move yeah
i really thought that the move h4 could
have been refuted there was a line here
we didn't fully
go down the line which was knight back
to h7
g5 basically box i was
actually trying to play the move knight
g6 takes
knight takes
takes and
i just thought that
white's king at the end of the day was
just going to get hunted
was that a variation that was favorable
for
nepo uh alejandro how did the engines
like that out of all the variations that
we looked at they liked that one at
least the least the least it's
it looks terrible to my eyes it looks
like white's
king is under duress
it kind of reminds me of the game of
hikaru against fabi where you could have
a very strong advantage in the position
that you have right now or you could
have a very strong advantage without a
pawn on g7 in your face right just
choose the one that doesn't have the
pawn on g7 in your face you get the same
type of attacks it's a little slower
but you have no risk whereas at least
when the pawn gets to g7 you know i
don't know you can claim something and
this one is just very strong rookie one
is force i don't see another position
right
and as um
nepo
pinches himself yet again thanking his
lucky stars that he accepted his
invitation
uh we are going to leave this game and
go back to the game uh between our uh
two players who are fighting for second
lots they went right down that variation
that you prescribed
some time ago alejandro 96
queen takes e6 bishop takes f8 there was
a reason why the engine's number one
move was rookie two and we're just now
discovering it
the move bishop a5 with a double attack
against the bishop on f8 the rook the
bishop on f8 had to retreat and suddenly
it was one of those opposite color
bishop
positions we were looking mainly at
queen takes b3
queen a5 queen b6 that was our main
variation
uh ding decided well capturing the rook
sure makes a lot of sense
uh i'm hitting uh two
peskys at once
and
if my king's in danger i've got my queen
and my knight
ready to
kick back the attack
queen a5 and we're up to date with the
players
and uh first impressions
are that black is for choice uh
that
it's the way it appears to me
what says the engines alejandro zero
zero
also would you prefer rook takes p3 or
queen takes p3 i think winter sp3 is
just
a little too risky fair queen a5 and you
have to retreat the queen anyway right
in this particular position it thinks
that black is of course
having all the strategical trumps right
but the immediate initiative the
immediate threats that white has
forces black to react
so
queen d8 not an immediate mate right but
an awkward move to meet okay so for now
we don't want to really deal with it now
more pressingly at the moment the pesh
key right right this is an important
pawn because this one is just running
just played though so he plays knight g8
kicks out the rook a bishop
good morning
the bishop which moves diagonally the
bishop can retreat all the way to d2 it
can go to e3 i like it on d2 just so
that i can go bishop c3 right and one
day f4 might weaken you and i hold on to
all my pawns very nicely right right his
bishop on c3 monster defensive bishop so
we might go into a line where you take
the pawn if you don't take the pawn i
will defend it forever bishop c3 rook a2
and i could even consider taking on a6
i could consider going f4
f6 in this position and then taking
opening the file might be useful for me
and yes you're up a pawn
but it's hard to prove
you have this weak
king pretty much forever right i can
play something along the lines of rookie
one the engine wants to bring the knight
to e3 first and then go rook f1
and it does give white enough counter
play now if you don't want to go into
that play bishop e3 the more human move
don't allow this rook takes b2 or allow
rook takes me two without giving up
uh the pawn on a4 and i think that
it's just a game
i mean you have this pawn i don't know
if it's a weakness or it's a strength
this knight on g8 will come back to the
game but it's going to take some time
black is very solid though right very
hard for white to attack anything in
this position upon d6 is the base of the
structure and it's impossible to get to
this till night
getting to c4 would be really nice but
it's very far away from it right so and
not to mention that after bishop e3
because i'm not threading bishop d2
let's say a thread right strategically
holding onto the queen side
the move bishop e3 doesn't present me
any immediate problems maybe i can
defend this pawn
maybe you can attack this pawn instead
play move like queen d7 so when you take
on a6 instead of taking on b2 you take
on a4 right that way there's no pass
pawn right and this one
you can imagine that this one goes into
some kind of equality right i hold on to
my pawns on the on the queen side since
this queen is defending d3 and at some
point i'll get my knight in opposite
colored bishops why should either side
really be better so the engines are
thinking white is fine no matter bishop
e3 or bishop d2 perhaps stylistically
you would like to choose one side over
the other i agree that i would take
black
but the engines don't really think that
white is at any disadvantage okay zeros
and uh thanks for joining the
conversation as we have a social media
yes yes let's go
from youtube uh joseph's ian flores asks
who is the greatest chess player that
never became a world champion oh well i
think i'm sitting next to
nice
a good one
right
wow um
when you think about the history the
interruption of the world wars the fact
that a lot of chess was stopped
uh because of world wars and
who didn't get a chance i mean akiva
akiva rubenstein has always been held up
as one of those players in the history
that never got a really big chance of
becoming a world champion
david bronstein of course
he played and became challenger and it
was 12-12 and he loses game 22 that
allows
uh
bod vinnick to
tie the match and in those days
the world champion had
in case of a tie he got to retain his
world championship title but
you know for me personally one of the
players i would have loved to have seen
play a world championship match
vasil yvonne chuck
oh that would be so much fun and the
seal was on the top of his game
whoo
he excited the world
how about you uh
how about you um
alejandro nice to see you my friend i
think
alejandro who did you think
was very deserving never got a big uh
got a shot there are so many names out
there and i'm going to throw a couple
just because we have to
you got to put them out there charis
paul carries paul caris obviously he was
known as paul cares the second second
because he was so often the second of
the candidates
he well he got his shots yeah oh he had
three
matches with anatoly karpov that's all
determined it's just who didn't become
world champion right there's a lot of
players that were very good uh they
might not have got into the world
championship match but even players that
did get there i never became
not
not that i don't think he will ever
become world champion i do hope he does
fabiano caruana
[Music]
one of the best
fanboy one of the best players in the
history of chess right not just by me
there's so many
lists out there
the results the opening prep the quality
of his moves
everything
but
not quite there there was a certain
magnus carlson on his way the way that
there was a certain gary kasparov in the
way of many other great players exactly
so
whoo
nice question
and uh
boy
upon more and more reflections all of
these names just uh coming up i just
wanted to take our attention back to the
game of hikaru for a moment against
richard because it just
felt to me that the game was slipping
away from hikaru
we had been looking at ideas of f4 we
definitely were rejecting knight e3
there was the 93 bishop takes e3 and we
were just not on that path h4 on the
board bishop f6 93 rook rook d2 and
again you see
what's happening here doris you're not
you're not doing a good job here with
the queenside pawns in fact that just
about this point you start thinking to
yourself
how do i pull my emergency shoot how do
i just make a draw and
we are up to date with the players after
move a4
as white you start thinking can i play
c4 and just uh
shut this game down i think that hikaru
well i don't know it
it it's impressive to me alejandro that
richard rapport a player
who is not known for playing feshnikovsk
can suddenly in the middle of the most
important tournament of his life
pick up a defense that it's not in his
playbook
and play it like a champion they're good
these guys are good when we think about
these players
they like knowing everything right and
it does fall a little bit in richard's
prep he must at some point thought about
it because even though he plays four
knight sicilians in the four knights
sicilian way nobody has played knight
db5 against him right and try to see if
you're actually going into his fashion
variation and here what he did he just
didn't play in the four knights he just
went straight into knight c6
and hikaru said all right let's play
this fashion cuff and richard was ready
uh this game is about to end in a draw
nothing happened since we left it no
real reason to go back in it timor
rajabov and young
are about to sign the score sheets uh
they're going to draw their way out of
this one
right or against four of us okay and
there's nothing to talk about here
try your best
you could do it absolutely not with that
game
kings youtube
the engine's saying knight g6 minus
three
resign it's not
hard
i'm not really sure what he's planning
to doing in the knight g6 actually he
has to play f4 to stop knight f4 check
and bishop takes g5 that doesn't stop
anything
what ouch you take yeah i think on v2
i'm crying you're you're crying
this is falling apart i mean if you have
knight a4 maybe you can look at this
position but you don't uh you have to
play knight e4 okay and this is perhaps
the only
moment moment you have to calculate the
engines are saying bishop d8 is winning
i thought rooks e4 was winning roxy4 is
also winning
uh but bishop d8 is just super strong
everything is
it's getting what is it shish kebab
i think this is a whole different dish
at this point
yeah the whole grill in it right right i
mean rookie 2 will be a threat at some
point followed by rook c2 uh knight f4
will be hanging in many cases this
knight is
once i hit this knight with bishop b6
it's kind of hard to defend the only way
to continue is knight takes d6 right
check and hope for the best if you take
on e2 with the queen obviously i take on
on d4 you can't play that knight takes
e2 rook c2 you're down to rook it's a
lot of material but
come on i mean this is look at your king
you're looking at e2 look at the f4
everything's happening with check too
right yeah
no i mean uh
that's a very very naked king why do
we
say
don't
push the pawn shield in front of your
king
yeah that's the cover that's the
protection that's your shield and that
position you had with the rook coming on
the second rank
that was looked like a full disaster
yeah and perhaps it's not so easy to
evaluate from the beginning okay if you
think of this position and in your
mental
you think the root comes three two is it
enough for a rook
once you get the position in front of
you you see well yeah yes but
maybe from this position
it's not as easy okay and that's the
only reason i could imagine that alirez
is allowing this variation because
knight g60 will meet with f4 there's no
choice there's no choice there's
absolutely no choice in this position
knight hf4 looks like the more logical
version
bishop takes and this is what i was
worried about see i got to this position
mentally yeah because 94 looks
completely forced to me and i thought
rook c4 was very strong it looks
wonderful yeah the engine thinks that
bishop b3 somehow still survives i
thought bishop died was strong here now
that i have even more stuff i thought
bishop takes g5 yeah bishop g5 was the
enemy looks like
an entire grill why it's surviving and
it's by a miracle no way yeah it's kind
of a miracle you have this kind of weird
rookie one and you're still not dead
because you have to keep the pin oh but
even if you give up the queen
and just think oh my god oh dear oh
you're taking so many pieces and this
king again the king the king the king
wide open guys
the king the king stop
no defenders exactly there's just no
defenders yeah you're gonna have trouble
mating it without a queen
but who cares
i made it
i can just create threats until i win
material nice
this is very bad guys
all right as we prepare for our
commercial we once again
would like to remind uh you that uh one
game has finished it was a draw between
duda and timor a game that doesn't
affect our standings but on the other
side of the break our dear friend
grandmaster jonathan tisdale is going to
join with us and we're going to ask him
all kinds of questions about
magnus's
state
as world chess champion see you on the
other side
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the u.s
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faint
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2022 candidates
tournament these are our current
standings with one game
uh completed timor and duda both split
the point and they currently stand after
11 with a score of five to timor versus
four and a half before do that but we
have this huge fight going on
on this board between fabi and dinglerin
these two players are tied for second
coming in today's game with hikaru
nakamura we think hikaru is going to
make a draw and when we left it we left
it just about these parts
we had seen the retreat knight g8 bishop
e3
also the computer interestingly enough
the engine liked the move bishop
to d2 with the idea of playing bishop to
c3 bishop e3 to my eyes looks like a
very
normal move and there's some complicated
ideas here uh for black one involved
playing the move queen d7 and uh trading
if you will uh the apons as well as rook
takes b2
uh and the question is
was this pawn an asset or a liability if
you look you see that black structure is
very very solid ding took a different
approach altogether after bishop e3 he
said you know what i'm just going to
defend my pawn what are you going to do
fabi said well i don't have anything
better
than queen
d2 defending and then
and
ding said well that's nice f7 f6
since my king is on a dark square i'm
going to shut down this diagonal i'm
going to make sure
that that diagonal is never open
and i'll leave it to you
f2 f4
trying to pry open the f-file alejandro
actually looked at a line like this
where the f-bombs got traded and this
knight i think the actually the bishop
was sitting on d2 this night was getting
re-routed to c4 square uh nice big big
fight going on here i like what i'm
seeing i love these opposite color
bishop middle games dorsa we just have a
new move as well e5 takes f4 well i got
no choice there pretty much it takes f4
and i think during digging his thinking
news oh excuse me
i was about to say i think ding is
thinking is now is the time to bring my
knight into play with knight e7 and
knight to uh c6 no
he lashed out with the move g5
this has to be so concrete because what
a bad looking move oh look at this he's
got something oh
he's saying but i got a double hit what
a yasser
knight f5 you got to admire you gotta
admire the understanding
the yasser ism's coming to the
candidates gift me the party did i hear
yasser
thank you well there we go so uh first
of all
the move g5 should only be made when you
have something as alejandro was about to
say very concrete this knight on g3 is
crying right it doesn't have a square to
jump to
when the knight on g3 saw the move g5
you go whoa
isn't that something and now i've got a
square to go to but
this is the concrete uh dinglerin is
chasing upon
is he making
yes by yasserism where does this pawn
stand is this pawn kosher for knight f5
or
[Music]
that maybe there's a trap right i was
thinking can you go d4 whoa no no whoa
whoa whoa rook takes me two i think i
think d4
wins
what
am i missing something or
uh what what what that pawn is gonna get
yeah because if you take on d2 and i
take on e5 you still have to move this
rook
and i get my pawn all the way to
either d6 or just like i'm still trying
to get the zen of the position here
because
a queen takes e4 runs into queen takes
b2 and that's just lost that is a a
whole p of a pardon me a whole rook
after queen takes queen takes okay so d4
uh if we trade
takes takes let's say rook era
i'm thinking i i i want to play bishop
takes
e4 can i push e6
push e6 i'm not so sure
about the following bishop takes e4
e7
knight takes and i got
so something going on here i could take
on d6 right like go on oh sorry uh you
you like this uh rook takes pawn takes
you can take on d6 with
the knight i think with the knight
okay
so
i
whoa
yes that's what i was going with yes if
rip takes b2 instead of pawn d4 and
knight d6 might be
actually
much more
knight takes d6 you've got uh
that is disgusting
wow
knight f7
that's easy to miss that's really uh a
nice move so knight f5
dig
did ding lyrin miss
rook takes b2 knight takes d6
alejandro that looks great for
white knight takes d6 is a decisive
advantage for white right yeah the
endgame is just lost let's go on a
little bit right right knight takes d6
you don't save yourself by playing king
g7 no at the very least i would have
knight c4
but probably you have better right rook
takes d2 check here knight takes e5 we
kind of reach by force and now the thing
is d3 is defended i'm attacking your
rook the rook has to move uh rookie two
doesn't actually come with the tempo
because knight c4 defends
yeah and the remaining piece power
is obviously in favor of white this
bishop will take on c5 pretty soon this
bishop isn't taking on e4 anytime soon
this knight is also very far away from
the action
winning for white
knight takes d6 in this position
rook takes check king g7 knight takes e5
you could consider going for the other
pawn rook on a2 problem is the knight d7
comes on the board you take on a4 i take
on c5 thank you very much actually the
interesting thing even rook takes c5 is
stronger than knight takes e5 but knight
x5 is pretty strong anyway the knight
goes anywhere even d4 d5 is this is no
this is lost i mean the only reason you
play into this variation is because you
missed knight takes d6 right and even
then i'm not entirely sure how to
evaluate queen e1 the engine is like
white
yeah but knight five plays itself i
don't think there's another move
i i have to ask because we didn't talk
about the evaluation after pawn d4
because we were just you know talking to
manga i'm curious as well uh equal
actually
take on d2 take on here we are right on
rook d3 it is the only move right we
were right on knight d6 we were right on
this and we were right on this
and we were right we got we left it here
i thought pawn takes e5 knight takes c5
was better for white because weeknight
weak a6 pawn but you can just take on e4
instead right and after this this this
that's the vacuum cleaner you got the
rook to a5 so the pawn doesn't go
anywhere three versus three draw
so d4 is a draw
but knight f5 you just cannot take on
the on on b2 because of this beauty of
knight takes d6 five he spots it he's
integrates he's in a great position
let me interrupt you to say we have the
man the myth the legend himself jonathan
tisdale
online jonathan good to see you
yeah good to see you guys uh your
glasses look like they're a little
thicker since the last time we saw each
other
how are you doing
the true both the frames on the gl and
the glass yep nice
uh i'm fine i'm glad uh to finally get
through to you and just before the event
ends right
um
jonathan uh we gotta ask you the
question directly because we've been
talking about it now
normally speaking the candidates it's a
winner take all tournament
there's one challenger
that player goes on to play the world
champion isn't it wonderful isn't it
wonderful but we've been
making noises that
the television
angle to this question is there
yeah well what's the current state of
magnus's uh
how how has magnus address the issue of
the world championship match
i don't think i know anything uh
that you don't already know um this
started i think more or less because i i
had an interview with with magnus just
before the his match in dubai with nepo
right and he dropped this really strong
hint that it was going to be his last
match and when i tried to press him on
it he said ask me after the uh after the
match and i haven't had a chance to ask
him but he has um spoken to uh podcasts
and
people in the uh
media here who he's very friendly with
his you know his guys
um
his old friends and this sporting
podcast and stuff and his statements
have not been crystal clear yet but
they've become increasingly stronger
that
you have to take him seriously when he
says he is not
he's less to please less pleased than
ever
to to play a title match is how i'd say
it
wow and uh you
you've known magnus basically since he
was a little boy
and you take his
comments very seriously because he's not
the one to pull punches he tells you
exactly the way he feels
yeah exactly
magnus
yeah i mean it's quite the opposite in
fact you ask magnus a tricky question
and he will give you a horrifyingly
direct and
thorough summary of his opinion yeah i
mean he's he doesn't pull punches and he
he not only says what he means if he
says he's going to do something he
follows through
i that's why i you know i you have to
take it this seriously but the
biggest um positive so far is that he
hasn't said 100 he won't do it if he
says that i'd be astonished if he does
play but
he's kept this open and he's always
had this attitude
you know i mean it's easy to forget now
that
when he was um
you know the the heir apparent in the
you know the early 2010s if that's what
you call it that i mean he was so
against the
uh
the cycle the whole title cycle that he
dropped out of it right um
and he has you know said he doesn't like
defending it and he doesn't like it
defining him i think that's maybe
the most
eloquent way he's put
his relationship with the title
what do you think would be his ideal
formats
just try everybody from the beginning
just
he does like the idea of no advantages
to the champion i mean he's not trying
his his attitude towards the title isn't
protective at all yeah he has said many
times he'd like
some sort of completely open system i
suppose closer to this world cup kind of
thing than
what we have now but i mean he's also
been very clear and he's very fond of
a rapid-based
event i think i think the current way
these uh his magnus tourists set up i
think
is a bit like his dream version of how
to run a
a a championship event and i think he
sort of sees engines forcing people to
play so quickly that it's
at some point what we call classical
chess will be pretty fast nothing like
what
yasser and i used to play
good day
right
but uh if for example these melt water
championship
events
where
they really are open and they're fast
paced
uh jonathan i gotta tell you i mean the
well the norwegian television ratings
have been
spectacularly good that is
it wouldn't be the worst thing that ever
happened to chas
no it reminds me a bit
of an interesting thing greg shahadi
said on twitter a couple of years ago
and it was one of these things where
when he said it it was clearly a
divisive thing to say and i agreed with
him 100 and disagreed with him 100 at
the same time so it was very memorable
but what he said was something about le
as to the effect that if
if we started running chess events now
no one would ever dream of making them
classical they'd all be rapid right
and so that there's a sense that we're
carrying this you know historical burden
that games have to last
okay now they can only last all day
instead of several days like they didn't
when uh when we were young yes but um
basically
everything's going faster
and we see the necessity with the
engines to speed things up as well
and it's really hard for me to argue
against that that if we were starting
from scratch today we'd think oh yeah
you know it's a bit like the problem
qriket has
you can either play for five days or you
can
play rapid yeah so i think it's
it's very easy to understand how you can
see the game becoming
fast classical rapid
rapid rapid
rapid blitz you know and so on
alejandra jump in with a question for
our good friend
jonathan tisdale if you please well
first of all great to see you i was one
of the few people that was actually
awake for breakfast in dubai it's a very
good breakfast company with jonathan was
regaling me with all his stories guys i
have to agree with the conversation it's
something that i've been saying for
years since i started doing broadcast
for the st louis chess club i've thought
the game needs to speed up we have
candidates are going they're regressing
the world championship to me this time
control is a regression it goes to our
traditional system to what we're used to
but every single new tournament
is going faster
yes
um
i'd say two things to that um
we
we're still supposedly see the need for
a classical title
um so presumably it's got to have older
well i want to say older slower
classical rules one thing that i do
think is really positive about the last
match through
and the candidates is that we brought
back good old-fashioned time control of
no increments before the game's actually
ending
which was the original idea
and it's not just because i like to see
people
in the same kind of time pressure that
was normal when um yaz and i were kids
you know i mean real time pressure i
mean
it adds
that element of
error creation
and excitement that we've been trying to
achieve by just speeding the game up
um
and you know
you get all of your time at the
beginning so you could actually have
more time for the game
um
it's you know up to you to to invest it
properly
um so i think this is a really great way
of
sort of compromising while we're working
things out that people have real time
pressure
um you have going to have a higher error
level which is what i suppose people
want yeah you want to increase the human
factor right and reduce the engine
factor
the problem for me with that is i can't
this i can't see it lasting as a
solution for very long because every
time you speed the game up
your classical lovers are going to go
people can't play really great games at
this speed right and then they do and
you speed it up and then they do so i
assume that it'll take a couple of
months before everybody knows how to
invest their time properly you won't get
so many time controls they will be in
the more less the same place
so
yeah
yeah i think we're gonna see it fast and
faster i'm all for like having you know
revising the specific rules every like
seven to ten years just you know come
back to it make sure it's still relevant
to the player to the world champion to
well the game because i do feel like
after pandemic chess
has changed quite a lot
um yes but i do have uh another question
for you
i see that well as an author and as a
such a
amazing chess player and i also see your
beautiful bookshelves behind you so i
have to ask
um
what are your top three favorite chess
books that you must read anybody
everybody if you don't read it you got
to quit the games
oh that's really tricky because i i of
course i'll try and make give you a
weird answer um
well i gave you three i was gonna go for
a tough choice how many books how many
books did you write jonathan
well one of it has to be right right
i don't i can't really answer i can tell
you one of the books i've always
recommended i don't think anybody's read
that's fair and that's and i won't even
be able to remember the name now
but it mihi's shuba's book on dynamic
chess something thinking
dynamic
all i know is i think it might just be
dynamic chess by michael mike
it's the few books that i've found
incredibly inspiring and um
showing me chess from a different angle
and also literally laughing out loud
constantly throughout it it's full of
fantastic stories
personally i wish i'd read jonathan
rousen
when i was young but unfortunately
jonathan reynolds said
um
or chess for zebras the deadly sin
zebras is my favorite i think because it
goes most deeply into
very normal problems with chest
psychology
and mental attitudes
and ways you can um
mislead yourself and all sorts of really
deep topics that nobody tends to teach
you or you tend to think of yourself i
mean to me it was
personally i think i found it one of the
most instructive things i've ever read
and i immediately thought geez if i
could have if he'd only been born before
me things might have been different
but dude i i want to slap you how come
you did immediately i mean immediately
say michael talls
uh 1960 world championship match book
that's
just like holy smokes that's just
unbelievable if i can find out my
bookshelf it's falling apart
it's a fantastic there are so many there
are so many
yeah so and then of course there's the
one we did together yes yeah well thank
you i wanted it i was i i was leading
you to the water there you weren't
drinking um
on ebay or whatever it is to re repeat
back to you you're recommending shuba's
dynamic chess
any kind of stuff by jonathan rousen
uh really you like a a great deal okay
those are
i mean i think there was a very very
good choices by the way you wrote
also i think
what it is play better chess now which
which improve your chess now very catchy
title misleading title i thought it was
a great book i mean did you get any
royalties
it's still it's still ticking in
actually um
yeah it's
no i mean people tell me it's some kind
of a classic i mean i loved it i thought
it was a great book i like jeremy
sillman too by the way i like authors i
i like branch dean i like john nunn i
think they're brilliant authors i like
larry christensen our old colleague i
mean we have to mention him i like john
watson and john i think he did a great
job with uh this chess strategy book
that he has i'm trying to remember the
name of it yeah but it was pretty modern
chess strategies maybe modern modern i
think it's modern chat strategy yeah and
uh devratsky anyone yeah yeah
i was gonna say but that's a little too
obvious the other thing is right now i'm
really fascinated with what matthew
sadler's doing okay really fascinated by
you know being our uh translator and
guide to the uh
the overlord world
i think his books are really fascinating
right um and there's a guy and that this
is another unfortunate thing because you
know i'm i'm not not an active player
anymore so when i do read a book i don't
tend to pay so much attention but
there's a
guy a new guy around um
i don't have it here
it starts with a k and he's written a
book finally but he's he tends to write
about things the topics that i've always
thought should be written about oh i
know what you're talking about he went
to college with me davor in culiacevic
yes
that's the guy
hey you got it on maryland
what was the clue
what the heck was that that came out of
nowhere
what were your roommates get out of here
i mean that's when you know you're a
chess player right like oh started okay
interesting subject that was good enough
for me i just read this book
you guys ought to have an act together
yeah folks i've been
really impressed with those i thought
tremendous work on long neglected
subjects
i absolutely agree i think i
yeah he did a really good job on both of
those books highly recommended well
jonathan are you joining the discussion
late
the player
who never became world champion
that you think oh my god the history of
the world would be completely different
if x
had become world champion
i didn't realize you're going to get
surprise questions
[Laughter]
you just surprised us with that
author uh
it was from our social media our
audience wants to know we have a very
discerning audience by the way
so i i suppose i have to go back in time
and sort of take off all the great
um
all the obvious candidates um you only
get one sir
i'll i'll pick one for you i'll pick one
especially for your audience it would
have been um
it's hard to cook yeah he might have
changed the
the time
space time continuum of chess how about
hikaru
oh ooh
there we go
you you you took us back uh there with
that one i like that answer wow
wow uh
turning our attention
about how the world's changed right yeah
turning our attention to the topic of
today which is the 2022 candidates
what has surprised you the most about
the tournament
your predictions that have been
unexpected
the play you tell us
okay
i went on record just before the event
saying i had no idea whatsoever
about what would happen uh i could see
anything happening and i'd want two
rounds
to to give uh
uh anything resembling a prediction
after two rounds i said i would have
safe boring money if i was gonna put it
down on the event and i i thought fabi
was was the
the um the favorite right after seeing
them warm up right
at the halfway point i still thought
fabi even though he was behind right
because i thought
he looked like he was in
pretty close to vintage fobby form i
mean in terms of
being
methodical and
unflappable and i also thought he looked
like he was in the best physical
condition which i thought was going to
be a very
key factor
um so that yeah
i i will confess that was my
what became my strong opinion as soon as
you know or as late as as i formed one
um
i don't know why it took me so long to
think that the two guys who'd done it
before would actually be the favorites
it wasn't intuitively obvious at the
time no no and i was i certainly wasn't
alone in that there were a lot of
distractions you got young guys and
always you think you want the romantic
angle one of the young guys
you know might do something terrific
uh you know
ding's got good numbers i think things
been terribly handicapped
actually by what because i mean
like
by a sort of lack of logistical support
maybe i mean he turned up late he's been
inactive he doesn't have a second does
he
not that he has a second but not with
him his team is back in china
okay but who who is it do you know no
they didn't reveal they just said that
he has
yeah it would be very strange if you
didn't have links to anybody or anybody
helping it but still you know it's a
very long event right
so i i feel a bit sorry for him in that
respect and i think we're seeing now
him warm up yeah wouldn't surprise me if
he finishes oh the yesterday game
was very very strong jonathan we want to
thank you so much uh for taking time out
and joining us
it's first of all it's a great great
pleasure to see you remember 1976
memphis tennessee those were the days
huh
[Laughter]
well you called me curly
i still do
i don't call you curly anymore
but i must say it was
also nice to see my you know my
breakfast chum from dubai and his
incredible
psychic ability to to know what i'm
talking about
it's a connection it's just a connection
that we built up over that breakfast
buffet
jonathan thank you so much thank you for
joining us uh we uh
good to see you my friend
yes always yes take care everybody bye
wonderful man jonathan tisdale everybody
probably ask our producers to do is when
they take out that interview clip it
will be wonderful if we can actually
have a name of those books all written
down i know my my uh my lecture comers
and my students would love that because
that's the question i always get one
i mean everybody gave so many good books
now i gotta go update my library
pathetic pathetic library who reads
books anymore uh by the way alejandro he
did mention and you guys connected on
the author uh remind everybody who
jonathan said
davarin kuliasevich it's actually
spelled k k-u-l-j-a-s-e-v-i-c
it's not an intuitive i got it
pronunciation common spelling but the sp
with the spelling you should be able to
get it right
he's a structure he's almost 2600. okay
which federation
i believe croatia okay
i want to say i'm right on that one
right
uh i'm going to interrupt the
conversation to say that after knight f5
i think dingler in
spotted a huge hole in his the plan when
he played the move f5 a pardon me when
he played right here the move g5 bishop
e3 queen e5 followed up with this
obvious double attack
there was no question he had his eye set
on rook takes b2 he got to this position
maybe was reaching for the pawn and saw
that knight takes d6 was a cold shower
and he had to pull back and he played
the move 97 we've got 97 97 queen e7 on
the board no question about it you don't
play g5 and invite the knight to f5 but
did this spoil his position alejandro
yeah it did i mean come on you know that
it did of course it did you you don't
play like this unless there are
immediate tactical reason to do it
actually didn't work so he realizes
halfway through
that his idea doesn't work he needs to
get off this ship before it crashes into
the iceberg right and that's what he did
with the move 97 but by this point i
mean he's in trouble waters
97 knight takes e7 only move queen takes
e7 is the current position that we have
on the board the engine is giving a very
very strong advantage to white the move
rook f1 is the more logical out of the
two ones that white can play in my
opinion but quincy two i think is also
good i love that move because i want to
get my bishop on the long diagonal i
think that's very true rook b6 will be
played and i think i think this is good
bishop d2 bishop c3 with an advantage
the only issue it invites to move d4
and if you get d5 d4 in
it's a different ball game okay perhaps
why it's still better because of the
weakness on c5 and stuff like that but
we're not we're trying to get as much of
an advantage as we can right now you get
into an opposite color bishop and game
with an extra pawn yeah it's not enough
okay so queen c2 was played by the way
rook b6 and i think rook f1 here speaks
for itself speaks for itself hit that
pawn d5 is not really possible it's just
such a logical move right however the
engines have this crazy idea that this
bishop on c3 is really good right so
give up a pawn whoa
ooh me gusta
you have to take it you have to take it
otherwise i take on c5 clear
you can't think with a pawn that's
hobbies bishop d2
v6 and you know what harass this guy
even further
bishop a5 also possible and on rook b5
which i guess you have to go to now play
them with rook f1 starts running bishop
c3
and i don't know if white is that much
better
but it's very dangerous for the black
side here could you please take the move
a5 backwards yes and you want to play a
bishop a5 bishop a5 is also good maybe
it's even a more logical yeah rook c6
rook f1 and get the bishop to c3 without
allowing d5
uh the only thing that surprises me is
that the engines don't think black is
busted really you think black is not
doing okay why it's better
but it's not busted you have to move
king g7 and this resource
of the rook defending on f6 and perhaps
that's why the engines wanted to bring
your rook to b5 okay instead of c6 it
looks ugly but the rook does defend a
crucial pawn but it's like a tempo it's
just tempo that the black is barely
hanging on that's barely hanging on i
mean you even have queen d2 threatening
queen takes g5 h6 h4 you actually have
to take
not easy not an easy position for digler
and tons of tries for white play on one
goal this is what favi fans want to see
wow okay that's huge and what about our
other fight dorset for first hikaru
nakamura versus richie we were thinking
maybe the game was ending in a draw
whatsoever yeah bring us up to date on
this one what's going on everything i
see it's
they're just you know trading stuff off
little by little um although the the way
that game is going it's going to all be
focused on the king side now that that
one remaining queen side pawn is getting
traded off and having the knight might
be a little bit better but i honestly
don't think there's going to be
anything serious there que pasa why why
isn't white just won a pawn i mean um do
i have something wrong because no no you
you you have the move rook b5 heroes
black
rook b5 yeah you know yeah i know i know
i know and it was played but you can
imagine that if black purposefully went
into this position is because he wants
to get in he still has a couple of
problems to solve i don't think he's
completely out of the waters yet because
of the moves this move h5 right h1 is a
great move by hikaru
if black got in h5 we're not even
talking about a game anymore right h5
and rook takes b4 then it's a draw got
that part so h5 by hikaru h5 and you
don't really want to take no
shades of
the game he won against um
even even if you play check i think it's
even stronger i beg your pardon of
course uh let me at least do it with a
gain of a tempo
uh bringing uh the knight to f5 no no no
uh h5 g takes h5 the game flare is a new
i miss
my opponent
no no no because that knight on g4 seems
to be eyeballing that f5 square a little
too much can i just play pawn five and
just get rid of the whole thing
maybe so uh f5 uh
but
are you winning your pawn back that
easily i mean because i was not h6
oh gosh
uh i got a blind spot good morning saint
louis
i eat that guy yeah i think you have to
take on h5
yeah but then again i mean i hate karo
for choice right yeah you'll play this
on it's probably a draw but okay
who would you rather read you'd rather
be right i mean right uh hikaru is
sitting there saying uh
jonathan tisdale should have said for
the good of chess
i should be world champion did he did he
stun you with that one he sure did me
yeah yeah i like the answer because i
think hicarus
underestimated as a classical player
okay yeah yeah we know he's very good at
blitz he's very good at rapid right but
people usually forget that he was number
two of the world yes he was 2800 yes he
was such a strong classical player
forget about bullet blitz and rapid just
look at his classical results amazing
just amazing scintillating chess when i
said that favi was one of the top
players of the world that never became
or hasn't been so far same with chicago
so far right they're still in the mix
uh world champion it's because their
classical results are amazing and
hicaro's really up there from people
28 hundreds that haven't become world
champions
there's some that you think wow this guy
is really really talented even compared
to his peers absolutely shame on us but
happy to have
um jonathan tisdale join us but truth be
told we have lost contact with ali reza
and nepo and we got to play catch up
guys
we think that ali reza just really over
played his hand enormously he played
g4 h4 g5
rushed his king side pawns forward up
the board to his own detriment and then
came the combination knight takes f4
bishop takes f4
queen takes b2 and we were thinking
uh oh
bad things are happening for
white
and after the move knight e4 you're just
barely staying in the game and rook c4
there was also a move bishop to d8 that
also got our attention that's a crazy
move but rook c4
and we saw this sometime before and that
involved
bishop e3 oh no
how did we get that rook b1 maybe this
was right this is how it all went
yes
and oh my gosh uh
we did mention a potential yeah we we
mentioned this position
yasser after
rook a1 and we were looking at this cool
ideas of bishop takes e3 right give up
the queen yes and take on d4 that's
right but nepo says there's another way
to do it where i'm not down as much
material okay rook takes d4 what he
played
easy to calculate those lines retakes it
was absolutely forced everything else
just collapses the entire e file right
so you take the queen you take my queen
i have to take with the bishop otherwise
i said everything still hanging at least
with the um
yeah bishop takes d1 is forced bishop
takes e3 knight takes d6 which is kind
of the point so do you attack that we're
an exchange down for quite a number of
pawns it's three pawns three patch keys
all of them passed and connected
not with each other
thankfully for white but you do have two
pass pawns here you have two pass pawns
there white has a pawn not going
anywhere anytime soon but okay let's be
honest these guys are still very far
from coronation as well right black for
choice is it completely winning
not sure
you take black every single day right
it's very difficult to survive this for
the white pieces i think right very
practical decision i think by an apple
perhaps the engine says there was a
better way
this one looks pretty good he doesn't
need to win he just needs to
not lose and this is i i i'm having a
hard time imagining anything but
happiness for those four baby queens
right right i don't think four check
two yes oh my gosh
look i mean what's better than being
three pawns up four correct
that's why you get the big bucks dorsal
uh yeah this you're right maybe there
was an easier navigation but in truth
this is simply excellent and it's like
nepo i mean father christmas you
mentioned it it's been going on for two
weeks already
whenever he comes up against an opponent
is like farouza just played a 250 game
bullet match
i would like to i would like to have my
opponents play 250 games a bullet before
i play them at six in the morning he got
to bed and now he's suffering
yes
once again they're head-to-head uh dorsa
how do they do against each other well
airsoft does have one win against nepal
but nepo has two and they have one draw
as well which happened on the fourth
round of this on my apologies
one of the wins of nipple did happen in
this tournament round four i was on draw
otto cruz
but uh for nepo uh nepal's looking
across the board look i beat you in the
first half
and i'm really happy to be playing you
again here in the second half with black
uh give us an engine eval of this
current position it sure looks uh minus
two only what do you mean only that's a
lot well but it was also a material edge
and it felt to me like black was the one
having the threats how much did you want
that's why i thought it was more than
two uh but what is uh white supposed to
do right here right now rookie two is
what keeps him in the game
rook e2 yeah it prevents knight f4 so
yeah not an obvious move but he did play
bishop b3 by the way defending
the
j i wanted to put rook e2 on my board
but my
my my engine overrode me you know it was
like auto auto spell
it happens when uh ferruccio doesn't
have that much time left in his clock
either oh 11 minutes
this one is going to be a long one okay
i think nepo is going to press this
forever but it's not an immediate win
the pawns march eventually right but you
still have some problems to solve the
knight on d6 does hop around b7 is
hanging in some lines
not
as clear cut okay it's still winning i
think for black but it'll take some time
work you know i was looking at this game
between hikaru and richard rapport
and this was the position that they had
okay bear bishops symmetrical everything
all right
no problem making a draw maybe black is
for choice right oh how how did
how come he's down a pawn wait what
i agree
this is a very easy draw okay but you
shouldn't be suffering but you shouldn't
be suffering from these positions when
you are a little bit off form right that
you didn't find the correct version and
you said okay this one is a draw too
yeah i'll suffer it but i know how to
make it this is still pretty easy
because material is very reduced uh
these three versus twos are should not
be a danger right but you're up a pond
that's why do you think you know pawn
whatever i'll try right once in a while
once every blue moon black actually
falls for a fork or allows my pawn to go
somewhere right yes it's a draw
yes at this level they should do it
easily but you know what else they
should do not get into this yeah not not
be suffering
i don't think this was necessary yeah
i'm sure it was not and i think hikaru
with each
move that is going kind of going
dude
you know you're giving me reasons to get
optimistic yes i agree
wow bishop c3 on the board will keep an
eye on that again for those of you who
are joining us late we do have one game
sort of like one game around should be
that's true yeah you're right that has
been the trend we've already gotten the
draw out of the way so but fabi let's
come back to fabi and dingler in because
this he played i think a very practical
move here rook f1 that's a move you're
always going to want to make especially
uh when they can't play d5 yes and you
want to stop f5 and it's all about
bringing this bishop to the long
diagonal
bishop d2 c3 but i got to tell you i
love that idea of b4 that move b4
in particular really
seemed to wink
at me
uh
where somehow
now with the rook moving to f1 it sure
looked like bishop c6
but rook f1 can't complain
uh b2b4 still potentially
in
fabie's pocket alejandro uh
does this give dingler in an opportunity
maybe to defend that he doesn't didn't
deserve no no still it's still a very
dangerous position for uh the chinese
player here okay this idea of bishop
deto bishop c3 is always looming f6 is
always a backwards pawn the rangers are
saying king g7 just to start defending
it
and you would like to play queen e5 i
think right
trying to get rid of the pawn on b2 so
that this bishop d2 doesn't get to c3
the problem is that for first of all i
can just play b3 and sidestep all that
right the second is that if i go queen
c4 and this is queen coming
f7 might be a big deal for example king
here rook f5 i'm going to ask you
do you want that bond
bishop takes g5 everything would win
after that
yeah you are not taking that pawn so
queen e5 looks a bit unnatural i think
king g7 is where i would start again
very difficult position for ding
something that he gave himself right
he'd rather have his pawns in a more
stable position but he's put all his
pawns c5 d6 f6 and g5 weakened because
he thought he had this tactic of queen
e5 and takes on b2 what a cold shower
right for a player when you realize
halfway through the combination that
your tactic doesn't work right and you
have to just switch gears there's a far
saying for what ding did to himself
basically um i'll give a translation to
uh troop twist
which can i think in america would be
like shot himself on the foot it's a
difference it's not different because
we have different torture methods in
iran
[Laughter]
but shooting yourself in the foot is
something that americans are pretty good
at too i mean we had the wild west and
you know
those guns you know sometimes they
didn't come out of their
feels like holsters
but i also wanted to ask for alejandra
that the move h4 is kind of oh my gosh
we do have g7 on the board the move h4
is just i don't know if just yet but
it's looking pretty pretty
yummy to me attractive well i mean if we
transfer the bishop to c3 and you've got
a h4 or queen f2 uh if we play h4 right
away
is there a reference maybe queen f2 this
is what you wanted to slide it across
i mean i don't want to be in a position
where i have to defend black's position
but yeah i can see why h4
dorsa would
i mean
i'd find that move attractive um a move
that also i would find attractive now
any time
i'm thinking
black has one resource seriously uh he's
got to play for d5 so if i put the rook
on c6 which block yeah you wish block
thank you there you go now we're talking
uh wish block you're not playing that
it's all about if fabi gets to redirect
his bishop this way complete domination
i mean
you're you're probably
well you're likely to be able to grab
material the question is do the presence
of the bishops of opposite colors
give ding hoax
how big a
numerical advantage is the engines uh
uh take on this position for fabi it's
1.3 that's a lot it's pretty serious
it's uh not winning
but certainly a lot of pressure right h4
is a fine move it still likes this idea
of a5 get that
off has you were saying yeah sure this
rook on b6 or c6 defending the pawn on
f6 is kind of important
uh they don't see like a direct
breakthrough right there's still a lot
of work to be done here for favi follow
it down to seven minutes and 30 seconds
but it's not a big deal he only has four
moves to make okay okay and it's not the
type of position where you think
black is going to threaten something and
you have to calculate your way out of it
right if anything white is the one
calling the shots so plenty of time i
think for him to make time control
dingley ren has 42 minutes so he
definitely has no time pressure
uh looks good looks good for favi
but still tons of work to be done i have
to say dave has had a pretty nice time
management in this tournament
in my opinion i mean even if he gets
himself in like unknown positions i've
seen other players take 30 40 minutes
thanks but he was very i i don't
remember him
being like taking it 20 25 minutes i
agree wholeheartedly he's played
in my opinion much like nepo
a very practical
uh tournament where he's he's been the
guy pushing and calling the shots and
and and making his decisions
i want to say confidently you know um we
do
before we take a break i just wanted to
say that knight takes b7 by ali raza
bishop b6
is on the position and
i i mean it's
getting
intriguing
intriguing about what oh pardon me uh i
missed something yeah i saw the bishop
angling for f7 i thought d6
and i was calculating rook e3 with the
idea of bishop h3
attacking this bishop and i was going to
play bishop takes but unfortunately i'd
suddenly
recognize that oops
[Laughter]
in the words of jackie gleason uh i
blundered i blundered yeah you didn't
blunder there is a blunder bishop e3 was
terrible
what what was terrible bishop b3 when we
went back to this position where you
wanted to play we wanted to play rookie
too
yes right here right now we thought
rookie 2 was forced he played bishop b3
bishop c5 bishop b6 beautiful chass
beautiful chess rookie 3 just can't be
stopped engine approved rook
on black's agenda is rookie three
tickle
tickle big tickle big big big tickle
um
and
the numerical fart
four
four oops well
for nepo i mean it's just coming
every day
brings another uh prezi this feels like
when you get your christmas gift
and a bowl and there's also a gift card
on top of it right
i once had a crazy christmas that went
like this essentially i missed christmas
i was at a chester yeah right i mean so
everybody was like delaying their
christmas presents
uh but
they got early and then i came and then
it was like it was a new year's and
something else so it was like i was
getting all of these christmas presents
everybody that already opened up the
christmas present so i felt like wow i
mean this is just great thank you very
much thank you very much
and this is what uh i can't recall ever
i've had good tournaments no question
and i've had my fair share of luck in
those tournaments that i've won
but this is getting ridiculous
everything uh nepo's getting everything
and
and
and it's tough for the rest of them but
you know you know what yes sir while
nepo is um filling up his belly with
those points yeah i think we should also
go
take a quick break i'm with you 100 yeah
by the way what do i have here oh yes
we've got these some of my favorite
merch i have a few of them at home as
well
yes there are tumblers i believe they
are temperature controlled so you can
also use for hot and cold
and in my experience holds up to four
hours but
you can have better luck too
lovely
we'll see you on the other side of the
of this break as the 2020 candidates
will return
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our live
coverage of round 11. it has been
the yon
nepo
show as he has taken down
uh the number two seed ali raza and uh
it was not a good luck today for ali
reza this position the very end position
bishop e4 check bishop g2 is a rather
beautiful
uh
pattern of checkmate
g1 being covered by the bishop over on
b6 you have to move your king after
bishop e4
ali reza recognizing that after king h2
bishop takes e4
huge material losses at directly ahead
he threw in the towel
and nepo
boy he just keeps
clicking and the winds have been piling
up
dorsa he leads the tournament by a point
and a half coming into this round he's
hoping the other guys draws but it
doesn't even matter because
two and a half two and a half extra
points
extraordinary it's extraordinary uh what
he's doing in this field uh
i really wish you know like i know
usually naka does like streams after his
games and recaps i wish i could i could
see into jan's mind i think he would be
just like dancing like singing and i
don't know what he's doing but
how is he actually keep how is he
not exploding with joy exactly no
exactly
alejandro this has just been an amazing
sequence for yan and it just all and
this is where we're standing this is
what we're talking about two and a half
points
with bobby and hikaru and ding still to
play and to try to score
but i mean the only thing secretariat
streaking away with the triple crown
this tournament's over yeah yeah this
tournament
might be one with an extra half point by
jan
i think he scores half out of three and
he wins the tournament right
it's that bad it's that bad
this has been
a combination of everything that could
go right when your opponents fall into
prep when your opponents are jet lagged
when your opponents are playing until
6am
playing bullet
against daniel narodicki for no apparent
reason because they checked out of the
tournament and then you get to play them
with black right everything
has gone right for yana pomnyachi and on
top of that the world champion who
doesn't seem to want to really play you
i don't know how happy he's going to be
about that because nepal at least knows
magnus right he can see what he did
wrong in his magnus and it was such a
crushing defeat in favor of the
norwegian that you might blow off that
that rematch right but i wouldn't blow
that rematch off i think that depo
especially the entire team of network
will take those lessons they will
analyze what went wrong and they'll be
ready to even maybe not win
much a better much closer
match so i don't think he would mind i
don't think he would mind the challenge
to prove himself up there
but
it's the question is who is nepal
playing
because napo is in right that was it
this is over guys right three rounds to
go but this is over there's no way
and behind you you have uh
the potential answer to your own
question who is nepa playing is he
playing fabi
bobby still is nursing an advantage here
okay he made time control black is
seizing the defensive brothers rook from
b2
all the way back to f8 oliver went back
to f8 because he realized this is my
weakness this is my big weakness in the
position it's the pawn on f6 as long as
i hold on to it white won't be able to
penetrate probably just played the move
b4 trying to open up more diagonals and
more avenues to this king he wants the
initiative opposite color bishops means
that the side with the attack the side
that is creating the threats is decide
with the advantage so in this case
fabiano corona sea tanks before is
possible and perhaps even necessary but
if i will just take return put the queen
on d4 maybe put the queen on b6 improve
the position try to make
uh black's position break at some point
that you won't be able to hold on both
sides not trivial to do by any stretch
of the imagination black is very solid
all of the weakness that he has are
easily defendable you can't really
attack d6 and f6 at the same time
because the bishop can only control one
diagonal at a time so plenty of work
here to be done and the other person
that is in second place
is this one between uh richie and hicaro
this one i think is just a draw
an extra point for hikaru right so he's
the one trying no question about that
but i don't really think that with this
such a reduced amount of material
you can pose
serious problems right it doesn't seem
realistic you can maneuver your knight
around
but at
some point you know you're going to have
to resolve the tension and maybe you put
your pawn on e5 you take on f5 and you
put your knight on c4 and you play e5
yeah something like that and he could
have done that earlier if i can point
out uh this particular position after
the move bishop d4 he one king g3 bishop
e3 and if you take take check king e6
you immediately think this is a draw
because the knight is tethered to the
pawn for the moment yeah for the moment
and the only way to untether it
f4
but now somebody has to guard this pawn
and that somebody
is the king
the moment the king loses touch with the
pawn on the f4 square i'll capture it
right knight takes f4 king takes e5
you're out of pawns at the draw exactly
so this is kind of an easy draw
and perhaps that's why keeps the game
going with the move knight b2
it's probably still a draw
but again
probably
means that there's still a chance
right for hikara to trick his opponent
will he fall for a fork will he just go
crazy put the bishop in the wrong
position there's still chances and this
is why we're critical of richard's
approach to this end game it didn't feel
that there was this was necessary
is it still a draw yeah this is i would
feel very confident holding this against
most players i just wouldn't want to get
into it when i had better options yeah
exactly
going back to the game of fabi for just
a second i think this is for ding
lyrin's
perspective
this is actually one of the worst types
of positions that you can have as a
player
you're essentially on the back foot
you're defending you're defending
holding holding holding the bishops of
opposite color
makes it easier for your opponent to
attack you on the dark squares
very very limited uh counter chances
that that black has and and sometimes
being a champion
is holding bad positions this is a bad
position
how would you
evaluate uh fabi's chances of winning
this alejandro
[Music]
probability of winning this one
i'd say
i'd say it's between 50 50. 50 of the
time you win at 50 of the time you draw
it and zero percent of the time you lose
it and the classical right in a
classical game yeah yeah i i think i'd
be
more or less
so very difficult uh
i mean ding definitely dingler in
definitely in a very
difficult and awkward position here i
like this move b4 by the way
because sometimes it's not just the
weakness on f6 you need to create
weaknesses like for example as you were
pointing out if you can get a situation
like this well the queen
can easily uh jump to d4 and then you're
starting to bite on two weaknesses
and finally if your queen could also get
onto
this square you're hitting d6 with the
bishop and you're hitting g5 so i
imagine at some point a trick will work
right whether it's a break with e5 where
it's a take on f6 and take advantage of
the pin
you're trying to set up a trick right
this is how you win these positions it's
not so much that you're better you're of
course you're going to be better forever
but you need to start setting up threats
and
how these games usually turn out is that
the more threats you create and the more
pressing they are they're it's kind of
like tic-tac-toe
at some point you have so many threats
that you're defending at the same time
that comes the moment that there's two
separate threats that you cannot defend
from both
and that's what uh the move b4 tries to
create as you mentioned you separate the
pawns you separate the weaknesses so
that black has to run run around
defending them
uh instead of just defending solidly one
weakness like he is right now on f6
issue is it's not so easy to get to the
weaknesses because they're next to each
other right the pawn on d6 and the pawn
on f6 are next to each other that
they're not on opposite flanks that
means that transferring pieces to the
defense of it is kind of trivial
now i have to bring this up especially
because again i teach a lot of chess
right now which i don't think i will be
doing in the next few months
but um i was thinking that uh usually i
do tell like when i was a kid and i was
learning strategy blah blah my teachers
were telling me about the principle of
two weaknesses right and i read about it
a little bit later but i don't think it
was very relevant to me after a certain
like i wasn't really thinking about okay
that's one weakness that's another i
wasn't really doing it like that in my
game
yeah but i did see a video from one of
the youtubers that i recommend to my
kids um
hanging pawns it's a nice youtube
channel the the guy is very um
very solid with his knowledge and it's
very good for if you're trying to get to
your uh strategy
basis and uh he had a recent video about
the principle of two weaknesses so i
wanted to kind of ask you
guys
your opinions about where do you stand
on the
principle of two weaknesses well uh
it's funny uh i despise nimzovich nice
i despise them i think yeah i think uh
yeah generations of chess players have
been you know like wasted
uh
from his works but now having said that
he did articulate this idea of course
way before nimzovich was ever born
people were you know attacking a
weakness and saying oh i can't break
through
by just one weakness oh i know i will
create a second weakness over there so
they were doing that but he was the
first to articulate and say you know
once you have a weakness you've got to
create a second and if you can't create
a second it's going to be very hard for
you to win like if we look at this
position you've got this weakness on f6
and it's for sure you're hitting it
really really hard but
truth be told it's very well defended
exactly and if you can't break through
on that weakness and you're not going to
be able to
you won't win the game unless you can
create a second weakness in this case
maybe the pawn on c5 can be weakened by
what alejandro was saying separating
them out
and that's what you do and you do it
consciously i mean it's a certain moment
you get better and better better where
you go
oh uh yeah i i've come to
my limits i've done the best i can at
this moment also notice that and i think
this is very important too
that
with the move h4 you're trying to create
a weakness on g5 right yeah okay
but
don't be anxious to trade pawns keep
that tension why
because if the bishop ever were to be
here
and for example let me just put
something like this
the pawn if it was already traded
you'd never have the option for an h5
check interest and you would never have
the option of potentially checkmating
your opponent that's actually quite
pretty stage five so the idea is is uh
when you're in the driver's seat
not only are you trying to tie your
opponent down
but you're trying to create a second
weakness and you're trying to keep the
tension
don't be anxious
just to
take the tension off the board it might
happen that it's actually
good for you to be able to play h5 and
queen fight just a few things that you
pick up along the way and
in our discussion with tisdale i think
it was you uh
alejandra who mentioned john watson's
book
on a modern chess strategies and i think
john did a great job
at explaining um how through the
generations the modern chess players
have picked up so much knowledge so much
information that it's second nature to
them and jonathan tisdale saying gosh
darn why wasn't that book published when
i was around when i was growing up i
could have accelerated my knowledge and
understanding another topic that you
also mentioned the attention and like
when to take when not to take i usually
tell my kids to
if they don't have to don't take leave
the tension because it's psychologically
annoying to the opponent because
you know they have to always be on alert
is he going to take it is she going to
push it should i keep it you know that
kind of just leave that question for the
opponent right but i have my you know my
my reasons i like to teach just how to
play annoyingly
with understanding
as dutch would like to say we'll
understand it yes yes so that's also
another good point to not necessarily
trade off and to just let the tension be
but it's very interesting to see the
things that i teach my my kids and like
1500s it's you know still is very
relevant in the high level chess and it
still comes up here and there so sure
well also keep in mind that chess is a
game of patterns yes and these patterns
whether they're
these checkmating patterns they recur
time after time and time and after time
so the greater your knowledge about
certain patterns uh you will you will be
seeing them recurring um
all the time throughout your entire
career
now uh ding
in his last move by the way bishop to d7
he's basically saying okay
um my bishop might or might not redeploy
to g6 but in the meantime
he
dinglaran did not want to
identify
the second weakness right so he played
the move bishop d7 but this also
uh has its own drawbacks one drawback
that it has is okay right now the c5
pawn does not look weak
but
the d6 pawn did prevent
uh this type of of a move e5 now of
course you're not playing f5 that's just
all she wrote discovered
exactly
so you're taking
okay now in these bishops of opposite
color positions
it really comes down to king position
can i as white
get to your king or do you have enough
counter play against my king now in this
position you're tethered to your rook
you can't take the bishop you
you've got to keep the rook protected
and you might be thinking aha well once
i
drop back with my king i'm going to
trade rooks i'm going to make an easy
draw well
it's not 100 true because remember we
were also talking about another weakness
the pawn on g5 i'm going to put the
bishop on f6 i want to take and of
course if i can get it the king life's
really good so i mean it was it was a
choice of
difficult moments there for dingler and
did he want to capture
and keep the pawn on d6 and prevent
white from playing e5
or with this move
is he
prepared
to deal with the consequences of e5 and
i wanted to turn it over to alejandro
and to take it away
how does fabby
uh
you know
continue how does he get
[Music]
increase his advantage
bc5 is uh let me go to the correct game
yeah sorry vtx c5 is probably the way i
would start not so much that you changed
the tension or that you gained something
too specific from it i just don't want
to allow you to take on b4 okay somehow
i feel that's easier to play for black
than the current positions okay uh d
takes e5 is of course forced another
question is how do you continue i think
the move queen f3 is natural
why keeping everything yeah you keep
everything uh and you hint at takes
takes queen h5 okay and that might be a
very strong threat
because you will be thrown in queen
takes g5 using the advantage of the pin
on the diagonal and it's not so clear
where the king goes if the king doesn't
go to g8
you might be lost let me put a bad move
in
terrible move right right getting off
like everything
but just to exemplify a position like
this might already be lost
you can't defend the pawn on g5 if you
go back
bishop takes f6 that's easy and that's
the kind of tricks that you need to
avoid now let me do it in a little bit
more elaborate way i'm not going to put
the bishop here let me just move it to
the same diagonal it is right now still
losing why because i take them g5 i take
on g5 and queen h5 now i like this idea
the engine wants to go rook b1 rook b6
first also winning but i was taking a
look at these variations and you can
start thinking
of the move rook takes f6 doesn't work
right now because rookie xf6 queen g5
king f7 right but you start looking at
these moves and you realize there's tons
and tons of pressure on black's position
i forced your king at least not to
defend this pawn
the only question that white has to be
very careful is if i trade queens which
versions of that am i winning
i like uh starting with bishop d7 takes
takes and then queen f3 the agent wants
to take on g5 i'm not as fond of it
because after queen f3 i don't think
anybody takes on h4 except for engines
and just do take on h4 okay uh i like
the mcqueen f3 hinting at the fact that
i can use the light squares as
penetration it also asks black
a pertinent question what are you gonna
do what are you playing right what is
your move the engines i know take on h4
but if it's not that move you play queen
e6 where do you go it's not so easy for
me to find moves for ding lyren and
that's going to be part of the problems
that he has in this position favi 40
minutes to make move 60 degree has a ton
of time an hour and 20 left wow so this
might be a difficult defense but he's
gonna have to time to do it right
alejandro and that variation that you
were showing by the way which was
um
where the queen got to g6 it was like
queen here king year
pawn takes pawn
somehow you had this position where the
queen was getting to g6 we were making a
yeah a move bishop c8 yes
and you
you got to this position and
uh you you could go into a bishops of
opposite color ending
where you're at the moment one pawn up
but your guarantee virtually of
making
uh two pawns up um
that's the one thing that fabi
has to be careful that he he could walk
into a bishops of opposite color ending
where he he's got a lot of material but
no win
yeah i'm not sure it's not winning it
might be a draw the engineers only give
1.2 which i suspect means that they see
a draw instead of a win okay i have to
let them think about it but i think this
is the kind of positions that you start
to calculate right this is what i meant
earlier
with calculating properly the bishop end
games where you give the initiative up
for the material are you sure that is
winning with opposite color bishop
sometimes it's true sometimes it's not
we saw it yesterday in the game between
dingley run specifically against richard
rapport where dingler and accurately
calculates that despite the fact that
it's an opposite color bishop end game
the tempo don't work out in white's
favor in that game dingler ended up
winning that one so not every opposite
color bishop and game is a draw this one
maybe it's a draw
but it's still work to be done
absolutely
i wanted to point out the the live
rating because i was looking up and we
also have an updated graph for you uh
after today's win well
this is 26 rating points but wow 10.8 of
it has been just from first nepo has
gained 10.8 just from poor fearless trip
ali uh ali
is a very good customer and he's
uh
he's paying his dues
uh in his uh maiden campaign here uh
in the candidates but yeah losing night
coming in with these really really
really high hopes he's a young player
so
we under yeah we understand youth is
basically unsound but he came in with
high ambitions and to lose 19 rating
points and then to gain uh i mean this
has got to be uh again a career defining
moment obviously um
nepo has al already been
challenger and he's won this event
most recently i understand but this has
got to be
one of his
very very best uh
um
results ever ever so our congratulations
to him as he's really lapping the field
and we have a social media question
dorsa do the honors from
youtube user albert jumping asks
the commentators talked about their
worst game which game was their best as
they can remember and why oh boy
do you have a worse game i mean i've got
a lot of bad games i have i have a war
scam but one that stands out uh of all
your losses this one is like this is it
this is it most painful okay give it um
i'll share the questions
we're gonna throw it into the trash
we're gonna talk about what we want to
talk about guys the question says what
is your best
game
exactly you know what it's your show
you know you you gotta scale and compare
it
yeah you gotta compare it
so um
this is uh this is back in 2014 i am
still playing the my last few
tournaments for iranian chess federation
i'm playing world youth championship
which is uh
it was held in south africa durban and
keep in mind that few months before this
um tournament was happening ebola was
very prominent and that's uh
and not in that country but in that that
area of the world so
but you know what me and my mom were
like ebola who cares let's have a
tournament to win and i was up and
coming and i was um almost done doing my
wiem and i was one of the top
uh in my
field which i was playing world youth
championship uh girls under 18 16. it's
my last year and i'm sitting there i'm
hopeful i i have a few rocky games but
this is the last round
i win
i get the gold sweet i don't win even if
it with a draw i don't get anything i
hate like fourth or fifth
wow that's a big drop yes i was playing
uh laura unok who had an amazing
tournament i'm playing black
i end up with a very very nice advantage
i have like i need to find a sacrifice
on a tactic which i'm thinking about and
then i notice wait wait
i already made a move i don't remember
making a move so i completely
like just black out and i make a
terrible blunder and i give the game
completely away with one move and i
don't even remember making that move
because i remember i was still
calculating i know there's like a knight
takes f2 that i need to calculate i
gotta start pushing opening c6 i'm
playing as black and i i look at my
clock i'm like wait did you forget to
hit her clock maybe i should let her
clock around and i looked and i was like
wait i wrote down my my scorches
what happened and
needless to say i lost very terribly
after that beautiful blunder and she
very well deservingly won the tournament
after that and
we're friends now but still
it was very painful your best
alejandra what was your best win one
that you would really just say
dude i'm writing a book this is chapter
one
um
has to be my win against tomaszewski
uh in the world cup of 2013 i was
playing against strong russian
grandmaster 2700 jenny tomaszewski on
the first round and we had this back to
back we drew both classical games we
drew both
rapid games and in the world cup format
you keep going down on time
until you get to armageddon
but i lost my first blitz game with
white
and that always you know it's terrible
right because now you have to come back
with black and i had all this repertoire
based on the slav
that i thought was kind of cool
but it didn't work when you needed to
win because you know white can just take
on d5 right so i played benko gambit
and i sacrificed two pawns and just blew
my opponent off the board sweet it was a
good feeling right right for me uh my
very very worst game was uh with victor
korchnoy it was an inter zonal it was a
few rounds before the end
and just withdraws i make the candidates
i just it's very very easy i have black
against victor and he just played
terribly
i was in a hedgehog i was slightly
better
and he played some real bozo move
and i saw a way i could force a draw but
i also saw a way that i thought just
wins the game for me i said why not make
the candidates and i
had this big
uh tactical hole
in it
and i lost a game that nearly
cost me the candidates i had to win in
my last round i won
my best game by far i really liked this
game i was playing against anatoly
karpov in sweden and haning
and i was as white i as white i have
played
c4 d4 e4 and f4
oh that actually gives me an idea all my
knights came out i was completely
developed and i destroyed him it sounds
so pretty and
at a certain moment he had his rooks on
the original squares and his knights on
his original squares and he developed
his king
yeah exactly how how does this happen
against anatoly karpov one of the
most solid players in the world that
it's just sort of like a complete like
what did he do
so it was one of those games i chose the
best game again i have a few others ones
that i might have to think but there was
this one game that i think that that
tournament kind of got my get me my
scholarship from this guy
this is world junior championship 2015.
um i was playing so so much chess that's
i i can't even think about it but i was
on my for wgm i'm already like two 350
something i'm playing two world junior
and um but i'm nowhere close to winning
it but i'm just one of the best like one
of the top five at the after a certain
point and keep in mind that was a 13
round event in hunting monsters
and i'm playing jean saya up to malik
and we've played a few games before and
i've never lost but i've always kind of
let her slip and in this one specific
game i i do my preparation i remember
like specific moves and i've i went into
more depth about the specific game on
our youtube channel some of
my lectures about my
love for preparation and she kind of
falls into my prep
and
it's not like a super territorial but i
have
very beautiful dynamic advantage i find
a very wonderful night sacrifice
and i kind of show her that the true
dorsal power
and my pawns at the way the game ended i
had a bishop and i had four pawns my
pawns were like on g f
d and
c
and there's a bishop in the middle of
them as well and she has a knight and a
bishop and my pawns are all going slowly
slowly i had like four beautiful baby
queens actually resigned but
it was it was a very very beautiful game
that was really stood out for you it was
a game that's going to go in your best
games book uh
bringing it back to fabi for just a
moment we just traded on c5
in at this exact moment this is where
you uh
alejandra was suggesting just this
rather cagey move i hadn't
fully understood exactly what this move
does but it just
hints
that i'm going to take on um
g5 and maybe
get some queen h4 and queen takes f
queen takes queen h5 and queen takes g5
ideas um
surprising
fabi said well let me
flip
and switch my rook to the b6 square
where i would be hitting this bond and
we can understand that the rook on b6
when it lands there lands there with
terrific force
but dingler in said well i'm going to
close the door i'm not going to let you
put your rook on b6 and now i'm asking
myself well why did he put his rook on
b1
cricket
uh i think that rook has to go somewhere
else right yeah
it's kind of stuck on it's kind of stuck
on b1 the engines actually want to play
the move rookie one they don't mind the
move rook b1 by the way they don't no oh
and five is taking on g5 okay there's no
choice you have to take back this this
pawn
and the question is do you have an
immediate way of making a threat for
example the move queen f5 now that
you're distracted by bishop right that
looks attractive it looked attractive
but after king g8 where is the exact
follow-up well isn't it now the time to
go back to f1 and play for bishop takes
f6 maybe that's the way rook f1
forces ding lyren to find a move right
it might not be the most difficult move
but perhaps something you don't think
about immediately
uh the move queen d7 queen five was
played on the board by the way yeah
maybe they're going through this
variation unfortunately for favi after
queen d7 the engines actually think
white has nothing ouch well why not
queen takes c5 yeah queen takes e5
starts counter play rook takes f6
what sun checks
did you have to reflex f6 was there some
perpetual with queen d1 i think that's
the issue yeah ah
you're right yeah that's the counter
play
it's right there if you ever step here
that becomes a check and then i pick up
with queen f1 right yeah that's yeah
actually it's mate
[Laughter]
true so queen f5
king g8 rook f1 forces queen d7 okay
if queen d7 is found by dingle ren which
means he saw all the way to from king
jade because it does say king g8 only
move
not to lose wow okay
a little bit surprised about that one
queen if i was threatening to pick up g5
so about that that's not so surprising
never mind
it's pretty forced never mind about that
right yeah okay so one more time king g8
rook f1 queen d7 only move and do we get
into these positions where i could play
bishop takes f6
i agree to trade queens but i i i
pick up some material yeah do you though
i take one
you take one i go here yeah you're up a
pawn
but that's not but that's i wanted to be
up two i'm sorry that's not sufficient
if we were keeping the d and e and
somehow picking up the c pawn would that
two would that two connect that position
we'd be very happy we keep both of those
right so how do we do it we could start
with queen d7
bishop d7 bishop f6
and then bishop b5 right right this is
the only logical move you want to attack
this one i don't care about my g-pawn
exactly and i was going to say rook f3
bishop d3 but i see rook f3 g4 maybe no
but i just also don't see an issue with
this
what seriously takes rook takes rook d5
uh
no again i'm only one up at the moment
you're only one up right right behind
the pawn disconnect that pause yeah i'm
only one up for some reason i thought i
was already one i was going to do yeah
can you jade on the board okay let's see
let's see what happens there's other
tries you could throw in this check for
example okay uh you have rook f7 and
queen r7 if you play queen f7 take
stakes you could argue that this were
coming to b6 is dangerous
okay at least i would make that argument
right the engines don't care
so king g8
seems like the engines think black is
fine
there's still pressure but solvable
pressure right
let's see if fabi can find a way
to keep the tension the engine's top
move is actually the move rook d1 whoa
just defending just defend the pawn
make black find a move right
yeah rook d1 seems to be the
the best way to continue because
everything else is so forcing
it's forcing and it kind of somehow
works for black not obvious
to a human
but the end just blitz out through the
variations right they see takes takes
takes takes they love this they know how
to calculate that no problem right so
they think rook f1 queen d7 saves black
nice
now
let's take a quick look at the other
game because i feel like that's gonna be
a draw any at any point just just
because
in the last few moves i just see uh
black is just going king e6 king f6
king just i think in the last night
the king is just going back and forth
you're so right i even i saw a line
where the king black king had gotten to
g5 just uh yeah i blitzed through it
you can see it poke its head to g5 now
i'm going back in
three move repetition is going to be uh
coming
uh
a concern if you will
i don't think there is i mean if if
hikar wants to play push he might play
pawn e5 but i also feel like after pawn
e5 is just a dead draw yeah
it would take a lot of uh
good luck for knockout to try and
make richard blunder in this one exactly
but he's trying he's trying he's trying
his knights going around in a normal
round might get him dizzy to be honest
it's just a draw right i mean the
material is so obviously reduced it's
just a draw right but i don't see why
hikara would give up that half point
until he squeezes
the last drop out of this position ah
your your your reference to the word
squeeze uh really did uh trigger what i
wanted to say earlier that this was a
kind of a position
uh where you got to tip your hat to
magnus carlson he is a grinder
and he
tends to win
these positions where he's better where
he's got something that he's that that
he's gnawing
and eventually he just tires his
opponents out and somehow magic happens
he wins these games so
you know he's one of these people that i
feel along with fabi along with dingler
too by the way these 2800s they find a
way
of winning these
awkward difficult games
yes they are
um um i just i remember the first time
um
i
played the same tournament as magnus was
2015 qatar masters and i remember the
first round in that tournament he was
playing a georgian woman um chess player
i can't remember which one i thought
right yes thank you i believe it was her
i think so
okay
and the game ended in a draw but i
remember like it was one of the last
games of the tournament oh yeah
alejandra you were there you you can
tell the rest of the story i don't know
where your story is going
no i'm trying to go with like the how
much he was trying to pressure and he
was like going left and right and it was
just taking forever but the game went in
the draw just saying but he was trying
till the very end yeah yeah it was it
was such a such a wonderful experience
for me a young hopeful chess player yeah
i mean this is what magnus does best
right yeah he dizziest his opponent
something karpov used to do where he
gets this position of power yes and
instead of releasing the tension he just
goes around a lot of people massaging
the position they massage the position
until your opponent somehow loosens up a
weakness loosens up a file loosens up
something and then you can finally
penetrate into their weaknesses and
fabi's the not that kind of player
let's be whoa
he's not that kind of player all right
turn around bobby is this kind of player
bobby is the kind of player that
calculates and calculates and calculates
and tries to finish off his opponent
he's not the type of guy that goes
around for 14 hours trying to make you
blunder d4 direct move obviously you
cannot take i assume you cannot take
this should be four mission before just
wins picks up the exchange easy enough
so
you have another idea here is white
again five plays very directly if you
get the move d5 in i think the game is
over
okay i mean this is just such a powerful
pawn in combination with the other
weaknesses that black has right so black
needs to do something direct two ideas
that i can see you gotta attack this
pawn on e4 right i don't think there's a
choice
bishop d3 yeah bishop d3 looks very
logical attacking that pawn right
and now if i play rogue b6 i assume you
just take this right
cold-bloodedly cold-bloodedly you could
go back you attack a lot of pawns still
but i took i picked up an important pawn
right yeah so if bishop d trade rookie
one feels kind of forced the one looks
awkward though
no you can take on d4 yeah
i have to take now because bishop before
of course exactly it's not defended
even queen h7 doesn't look that bad
somehow that trade of i thought the pawn
on c5 was a weakness the trait of the c5
ponder for the d3 pawn at the moment
looks like black
happy i think so it's very direct the
engine stop move is rook e8 i find that
a difficult move to play because f6 is
such an important pawn right and because
i'm always worried queen g6 i know the
bishop is defending e8 but i'm aware
that queen g6 doesn't have a good answer
for the moment it does because queen g7
remember the queen cannot take on e8
right d4 very direct simplifies the
position challenges digloran to find a
direct way of refuting the move
otherwise uh d4 d5 is going to come in
with great and decisive force so an
important moment of the game right now
i was going to say can i meet rookie 8
with rookie 1 in that position
f6 i'm just
trying i think both moves are the same
scenario you just want to distract this
rook from b1
okay so that you don't have bishop b4
right or that at least the rook is not
on the on the diagonal it still remains
a little bit dangerous for black but for
example rookie rook here takes stakes
again no bishop before tricks let i mean
if i defend this way i understand that
oh bishop c5 is just winning i thought
e5 was winning right uh but you still
have ideas remember that this end games
are not that good
no yeah you don't claim the game not at
all you probably can't claim a draw
actually
[Laughter]
uh so for example i play the move bishop
d7 here since i'm continuously hitting
this queen yeah and this doesn't work
because queen g7 right
you're not you don't have that one temp
or that one resource or that one
weakness that you need to attack to win
the game
seems like
in many variations thing is barely
holding but importantly
holding
well
wonderful because we were just talking
about how uh you know great just players
who
know when to push know when to um hold
and i mean bob is an amazing player he's
truly as good as it gets um so for me
like just
i'm trying to figure out because
he still is a little he still has a
little bit of an edge but earlier it
felt like his position was a little bit
more
squeezable right so where were you
thinking rook b1 i i'm not a big fan of
the move rook b1 and i i really liked
the kind of cagey move of queen f3
maintaining all of the pressure here
um again i was also
looking at this e5 and maybe in this
particular case
it would be nicer to have our queen on a
square like f3 frankly where i would be
hitting more units
but the fact that i thought
the rook on f1 was on its best square
possibly f3 he did play the move rook b1
and maybe
cashing his in his chips a little bit
early
one of the things i liked about karpov's
massage like style where he did
wrong foot his opponents again it's a
different era different time controls
but he was very very good at playing
quickly and getting his opponent into
time trouble and often time he
forced the critical moments when the
opponents had less time so he is very
very good at
milking the position sometimes the
direct moves d4 can do the job but also
it makes it easier for the defender
at times
when you start playing really really
directly
and
i can answer with only moves
well then it's easier for me when i
don't have to uh think too hard and
there's only one move uh one thing that
probably got this completely wrong i'm
probably going to do something really
really really bad
but i just take take you know sometimes
you do have those crazy moments
where you know you've got it a bishop
takes f6 you've got ideas of queen shaq
and bishop takes f6 and sometimes you
can
use these passers the a bond or d-pawn
probably it's all wrong i'm thinking
queen takes
and
dorsey you you had one
one where you kind of yeah cleared the
cobwebs with the perpetual one
but i'm really afraid that you might
have a different kind of perpetual with
queen d1 and queen h7 but those thoughts
of uh exchange sacrifices uh do go
through your mind uh when you have a
very good bishop on the it's
unfortunately uh the perpets yeah and
also to be honest
the the fact that opponent does get two
connected baby queens kind of kind of
creeps me out and of course
if it was just one yeah probably i would
have wanted that more exactly
and for those of you who may be late
shame on you and if you're just joining
us it's been the
nepo show as his opponents have been
gifting him points left right and center
today it was ali reyes's turn to say
uh your lordship may i offer a point and
yan said okay i will reluctantly accept
this one so giving himself a two and a
half point lead
with
the two games remaining uh all between
the players uh on five and a half points
yeah it's gonna be a very very
interesting um
day for our um players who are trying to
find a nice fight for the second spot to
be honest a little bit earlier i thought
fabi was going to
had a much better chance at becoming
that soul
second player
but i'm kind of losing hope here but i
mean
dingle has still got to defend a very
very difficult position he's got two
moves
uh bishop
to a d3
again tickling this pawn and the whole
point is to try to drive
the rook away from the b4 square so that
you can capture so bishop d3 rook e1
then you take and you're still defending
you're still defending it still looks
good for white
and the other way of trying to draw the
rook away from the b4 square is
something like rook e8
with the idea that you can take
and or take on
d4 or e4
has the engine made this determination
alejandro as to which
is black's best choice
i mean it didn't change right it's still
the root creator bishop d3 okay oh
did they choose one over the other or
they're both equally good they're both
equally good okay wonderful and it's
quite funny and the other remaining game
between naka and dropboards we do expect
to draw on that we've been expecting
yeah it's about 15 moves of just going
back and forth and back and forth and a
little left letter right you can't even
tell if you're going forward or
backwards
sorry i couldn't tell if you were going
backwards oh yeah or forward well and
crazily enough i'm actually going at
this moment i'll go forwards
and uh the king has gone backwards
and it's i i also go back and forth
between different um
camera angles and i can see that the
both players surprisingly are seriously
thinking about this position yes uh
i mean again i'm assuming
if
if i'm guessing where where hikaru is
going is he's thinking if i can get my
king to d5 well yes i'll lose the pawn
on g4 but somehow
i'll try to make it difficult for black
to be able to give up his bishop for the
e pawn and the worst i know i know
larson
nobody nobody believes come on
you get the king to d5 you push the pawn
to through two dark squares
and somehow i can't sacrifice my [ __ ]
now come on yeah i mean it's too hard
this position is just impossible the
moment you step to d3 yeah i already got
king g5
so for example bishop here king here
bishop here just patrolling
you're saying
ah i'll just go to king to g5
and we immediately went into a table
base too by the way and uh wonderful you
know whenever the computer
i thought that was really cool when they
talk about the table basis i hadn't
really understood that expression but it
was
god
mode
like the computers are in god mode now
they play absolutely perfectly and then
and that's exactly the moment that i
wish to you know argue
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay but we do have uh
social media
we're gonna be laughing so much here yes
uh one of our viewers has submitted
another question let's go for it okay
this is from youtube
sir sir do you think we still have the
hokumono you have the russian chess
school
in chess training tomorrow eskies
uh uh
are all overused for training um
no
maybe the russian chess school is the
best school in terms of the chess
training today still maybe but the
domination that they had no
no no no uh the tools that are publicly
available the internet the databases the
chess engines have really leveled the
playing field in terms of training and
trainers really a lot
and i have to say too by the way i just
think that the not only the training
tools
but the teachers themselves
have just improved so much
that it's amazing like just take a look
at for example shushalov
who is helping uh fabi in this event uh
he has been around
well i want to say for the better part
of two decades is a really really really
fine trainer and over those two decades
he hasn't been sitting still he's really
improved in his pattern recognition and
his
way of training really produces results
so i want to say
that
the russian
school does not dominate
like they used to and we have really
played catch up a lot yes it's quite
interesting because well i i grew up in
iraq
and i learned chess in iran and for me
the the concept of good coach it was
really hard to find because in iran you
know we used to have a shock and it was
overthrown and revolution and all those
fun stuff
almost 50 years ago but after the
revolution chess was actually illegal
and it was banned for almost 10 years so
if you wanted to play chess
you were breaking the law yeah you would
be jailed and you know it was a very
serious offense against
the government and so people who were
chess players couldn't really play
either they had to go to a different
country and play which was so much
harder as well back the 40 years ago
so the culture of chess in iran was very
non-existent basically
and you know after years and years of
searching i finally found a good coach
rest in peace um he was international
master uh host roharandi
he played in a lot of the tournaments
that uh like
the other parts of the world but in
inter
and everything and he also was telling
me stories on how hard it was to find
material you couldn't you know playing
tournaments how hard it was to actually
get your hand on a chest book right and
now you know we're doing sitting here
shooting youtube stuff on daily basis
yeah it's just because of how much
resources are there
yes it's still um
now it might be entirely of choices
because you have so many choices but the
the i don't think that the the russian
chess school is
that
dominant yes exactly because there's so
many readers so much resources all you
have to do is um try to weed them out at
this point but
now i mean i remember there was a time
when i couldn't get my hand on bulletins
just to just just the actual games that
were being played now you see them in
real time did you ever suffer that
alejandro did you ever have a situation
where you knew something existed that
you really really really wanted it
whether it existed in the world but you
couldn't get it whether it be a book or
a bulletin or a a chess tool or a chat
it was playing people it was playing
opportunity yeah i mean you i got to
play blitz and i think the reason that i
became a grand masters was that already
the internet chess club existed so i got
to at least play blitz against
grandmasters and i was 3 000 rated
player back in the day when 3000 was you
know
top 50 60 of the of the club that's a
long time ago
[Laughter]
early 2000s right i mean you were at
chess prodigies yeah once upon a time
but the problem was that i grew up in
costa rica i mean you had to travel
outside of the region let alone the
country to find uh title players i
didn't play a grand master until i was
14. right that was my very first time
the mo from the moment that i played a
grand master until i became a gm my
first gym
um
it was less than a year wow so you can
imagine that you know my my growth was
really stifled by not having the
opportunity of playing against strong
players and this is something that's
happened to a lot of different
federations and it's changed because
people get stronger you have strong
players everywhere there are federations
that used to not have any grand masters
right and now
tons of smaller federations have one two
three grandmasters they've popped up
they bring their knowledge with them
back to their countries and
they really improved the scene
so whereas i was boosted by the
international masters to get to the im
level i needed more than that and it was
difficult to find as far as bulletins
and all of that kind of stuff every time
we went to a tournament
man it was a waddle of cash here you go
second suitcase full of books right
let's go back home
exactly that i mean i i had that
experience too i felt like a sherpa you
know just grabbing a suitcase full of
books and i knew
coming home also to seattle i was in a
group of friends
and we shared our resources uh in terms
of books and bulletins and those types
of things that if i brought stuff home
even if i had a duplicate copy at home
they wanted it right it was like really
really nice so it was tough and now
today i i look at the players of today
and i see all of the opportunities that
they have of getting strong quickly and
i just think oh my gosh what you just
said
yeah opportunity uh yeah i was not a
prodigy not like yourselves no no no
seriously i was pretty good but
uh even as a 13 year old though
i had like a 1500 rating
and people didn't want to play me
because they didn't want to beat the
poor 13 year old kid but they didn't
want to lose to me either that's that's
the important thing so i'm sitting there
watching a lot of games i was just
watching watching and asking after the
game why didn't you do this and why
didn't you do that so i spent a lot of
time not playing because people didn't
want to play me now
on the internet i could have a handle
and nobody knows i'm 13 or 14 or
whatever the situation and
just as you said alejandro getting the
opportunity to play
uh strong opponents is huge it just it
can't be overstated what's happening uh
with fabi we just had the move bishop d3
yeah bishop d3 would we considered
rookie one taking second a4 which we
considered bishop takes d4 and now we're
here yeah
right here this is the position that we
have uh where there's still threats
this is the main thread right it's the
rook so you got to find a place for the
queen
hard to imagine there's a better place
than f7
all you have to make sure is that e5
never works obviously because the
bishop's on d3 yeah attacking the queen
on f5 that doesn't work but you do have
to be a little bit careful that when i
kick out your bishop eventually for
example here
you might want to keep it around this
area but there will be some tricks let
me point out some of the tricks here the
move rook f1 is actually very strong you
might be wondering
then why not keep the bishop on this
diagonal so that rook doesn't get to f1
right and that's the difference rook d1
bishop b5 now i can consider
e5 break apart your structure and i
think this is what ding is calculating
the engine size is still fine but you
have to be precise bishop d7 kicks out
the queen in such a way that it cannot
maintain contact
with this pawn on g5 and we know what we
feel about these end games actually in
this particular position queen h5 even
wins but even if it didn't win right the
whole point is that if you trade queens
in this kind of scenarios you're not
really winning that right so bishop
takes d4 requires some calculation
because queen f7 rook d1 is scary
because the moment you see that you have
to decide on which diagonal
the bishop goes to both have issues go
this way allows e5 go this way allows
rook f1 the thing is the engines cold
blood at least say rook d1 no problem go
bishop b5 e5 bishop d7 you're still okay
right i like that move rook e3 too by
the way questioning the
bishop because maybe on a good day the
rook could also
uh go across uh you know you could get
rook
uh rook on if i had my rook on g3 i
think bishop takes f6 might be a winning
threat that's true you could also play
rook h3
and you never know it's the sixth hour
of
d7 queen g5 uh your turn
you know what's funny is that bishop f6
is stronger
i believe you i like text is made and of
course you take my queen that's made too
sweet uh
yeah so for example this is the things
that ding has to calculate and since we
have an engine right we know that
there's a solution for everything but
everything is a lot
and he doesn't know that he has the
solution for everything rook h3 needs to
be answered with queen d7 which is
already
instinctive right right you move the
queen away from the king you never know
if rocate shade wins queen g5 you have
to calculate queen g6 you have to
calculate the queen is going away then
you sit down you calculate yeah you
realize there's nothing actually works
queen takes is not made queen g6 queen
g7 looks fine the trade of queens looks
okay so bar probably you have to go like
check here and there and here but since
white doesn't have a direct thread that
i can see you probably haven't moved to
do something right
all of this stuff easy with an engine
for dingleran he needs to make sure
rookie 3 rook h3 doesn't just win the
game that's why he might shy away from
the queen f7 he has choices to make favi
is still putting very serious pressure
this is not a boring game by any stretch
of the imagination the thing is the
possibilities for white are black are
kind of endless exactly the queen could
go to f7 c7 the bishop could stick on b5
it could go on this diagonal we could
even play consider move like rook f7 at
some point white can play rook e3 rook
d1 queen somewhere he can play e5
against he's right now threatening
bishop c5 so many things you have to
consider for both sides
whereas this is exhausting for ding
loren because he's always responding to
threats right it's not exhausting for
fabric he's simply putting pieces where
they belong and hoping that one of the
threats sticks exactly this is also one
of the things that
where in my mind chess engines are so
much stronger than human beings
this is a terrible position for a human
being to defend because you see all of
these threats all of these goes the
cold-blooded machine just calculates and
goes to you know i have an answer to
your rook h3 my answer is queen d7 i
have an answer for your queen g6 and so
forth and so on and i think for for
human players just sit there defending
defending holding holding calculating
it's so hard it really really really is
if ding
survives this you know you just got to
tip your head and say well done i mean
this is this is very very difficult
stuff
uh for black sorry
considering that
most of the game ding has been
in the passive and defensive
side
it is but possible that you know he he's
just he's very well prepared okay i'm
gonna probably continue playing passive
for the rest of this game i'm ready i'm
just trading off pawns one by one my
king is a little wobbly but i have stuff
around it so
i think that's i mean it's it's clear
that black is
um
you know yeah suffering and defending
but at the same time white doesn't
really have that clear of how to
continue so i'm i'm i'm i'm kind of
leaning towards yeah this is probably
gonna be a survivable game and
unless there's a blunder exactly well we
were talking quite some time ago
about this concept of two weaknesses yes
and right here where this pawn on f6 and
this pawn on c5 and there were these
ideas of e5
and the fact that
ding
improper
improbably
uh was able to trade off this second
weakness for the pawn on d3 was
something
you know like that's encouraging for him
like uh that pawn trade was huge
and it basically means that if he ever
gets the queens off now
his chances of making a draw really
skyrocket because there's that missing
weakness that black uh had that he no
longer has now having said that he still
is facing these very awkward issues
bishop c5 rookie three
transfer if you've transferred the
bishop back over here then how are you
going to deal with threats of e6 e5
so by no means
by no means an easy defense at all still
a lot of work
to hold the position and for fabi
well he's he's a grinder he likes this
opportunity uh
wouldn't you say alejandro i mean it's
the it's a nice position to grind out
right but uh he doesn't want to grind
out anybody he wants a win
okay this is all he comes from right
exactly the tournament's been a bit of
disaster in the last couple of rounds
yes there's a lot of ways to put it it
really couldn't have gone much worse he
loses both of his blacks right and the
one game he really needs to win against
nepo
not even close right he gets a novelty
in he's already better and then with one
move destroys his advantage and even has
to equalize the end game right so
he feels the pressure i think favi feels
the pressure to perform
and i'm glad that he got this kind of
position that's not too crazy this is a
two-result game
you never lose
so i think he's very happy about that
that a little bit of the pressure that
he brings into the game is relieved by
the fact that this particular position
offers him no problems right
is he happy about grinding ding down i
don't know but you know that ding is a
great defender
ding is such a strong defender because
he's been able to hold a lot of
positions that i think a lot of other
people wouldn't be able to do
he has so much time that he's going to
try and sit down and defend this one
but he's in for a long haul
um on your
computer i i think i'm seeing that the
chess engine is recommending queen h7
it's the second best move yes yeah oh
that's the second because to my surprise
i'm looking at that and i'm seeing the
move queen f3 queen h7 queen f3
and aren't i picking up a pawn on f6 i
guess not really uh bishop b5 bishop f6
i think i have queen yeah queen a7
another one of those crazy perpetual
checks yeah if you go to the edge file i
have this and if you go to f1 it's
illegal so it's illegal
you can't escape that one right you know
if you go king h2 quidditch 7 king g3
queen eshwar is also checkmates you know
we were talking about two results game i
just thought that i should throw that in
there too
did anybody ever say that you were a
party pooper during the dorsey king g3
walking into a queen h4 mate that's that
is that's a st louis fan girl boy
we're going to revoke your membership
here at the club
i mean after that that's ding no
touching bishop for 55 moves on winning
the game the chess curiosities having a
little bit of a um
might be spreading around my fan
membership right yeah it's it's
what we were talking about yesterday we
saw a remark remarkable game
where ding loren
the god had given him a bishop on c8 at
the start of the game
and it never moved
and thanks to that bishop's presence he
won the gate
but it was a real chess curiosity that
in a 50-plus move game 55 55 move game
the bishop never moved and he won the
game we're going to take a break as we
follow the two remaining games again we
have two results
jan wins again
uh wonderful and we have two
three players
tied for second coming into the today's
round they're still playing and it's the
game between ding lurin and fabi that
has
kept us down the edge of our seats don't
go away we'll see you on the other side
of the break
[Music]
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate chess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsible
[Music]
be intrigued be delighted the world
chess hall of fame in st louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together
the world chess hall of fame mind art
experience
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slough partnered with the st
louis chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the teen's inception slu
obtained second best university at the
pan-american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the 2022 candidates
tournament we are in round 11 with two
games remaining young nepo soaring
through
the clouds as he wins yet another game
defeating ali raza timor and due to a
quick draw in that game or rather a game
that not much happened but the two
remaining games are very important to
our tournament cross table as three of
those fighters are fighting for second
place dorsa yes and
ali i was going to say alejandro has
been saying fabi is grinding grinding
grinding but he hasn't landed a blow
yet dingler in defending a very awkward
position and he's defending it very very
well he did play the move queen h7
and the explanation for
queen f3 is that you hit the bishop if
the bishop drops back you think you can
grab the pawn
no
you would fall victim to a perpetual
check
by this queen going all the way
back and forth across the board
as you so gleefully put uh
pointed out a moment ago you could walk
into mate if you wanted to avoid the
draw well done
uh queen h4 dorsa was your uh
was your contribution to our show thank
you very much for coming next
uh but queen h7 queen f3 on the board
and i was looking alejandro during our
break
and the chess engine was just saying
minimal advantage white uh
03 in fact
yeah because the engines as we mentioned
they just have a solution for everything
the difference is that diglern doesn't
have a solution for everything he needs
to calculate and calculate and calculate
every single one of white's responses
right if you're wondering what he's
thinking about because i'm not entirely
sure that he has an alternative uh if
you put the bishop on the c file doesn't
matter where at the very least i can
play queen c3
attack the bishop then take on f6
and because the bishop can retreat to d4
queen a7 is not a perpetual right so i'm
assuming this is forced the only thing
that he must be calculating is to move
e5 exactly i think this is the key and
this is where the tough move comes in
this is where dingleran shows what he's
made of or he will suffer
if he takes on e5
it's like instant death queen d5 check
queen takes e5 your king is so exposed
and with this bishop so safe on this
diagonal eventually this king ends up
dying the engine somehow hold it but i
call it a death i call it death because
right nobody defends this with uh as a
human
e5 the best move is queen d7
you hit that bishop and you have the
same kind of perpetual ideas if the
bishop leaves
uh
this diagonal right and if you go bishop
c5 again you get this tempo with the
move rook c8 only move but sufficient
the idea is that queen takes f6 doesn't
work
at least not for a win and if you move
the bishop back somewhere then you
finally can take on e5 and because
there's no queen d5 check the
coordination of the pieces of white in
this particular version is not as
dangerous if you take on e5 i have this
check king h2 and we already know this
trick queen h7 check as usual you can't
go to g3 you have to trade the queens
and obviously that's quite an easy draw
so queen f3 bishop b5 is the only move
that retains uh this minimal advantage
for white
but he needs to find that he hasn't
played it yet he's been on the tank for
a while
and
uh he also needs to consider that after
e5 he has the sequence it's a four
sequence barely works for him but like
the rest of the position we already know
it's very dangerous he needs these lines
that barely work yeah just to hold on
move by move uh before we get to the
road ahead of the remaining players one
of the things i'd like to do is remind
everybody because i personally find it
very unusual
we made our predictions and yes you got
godzilla i understand but if you put up
our prediction board for just a moment
this is one of those rare moments when
your panel has got it right
we have chosen
the players who have the best scores go
come on tom don't leave us hanging you
know show
he's not doing
he's not pulling it out but i assure you
i chose hikaru who did you choose i
chose dingley run and we got fabi as
well so we got it all right at least one
through four
as we're going to show you the road
ahead
for the top four players
uh in the remaining three rounds and uh
let's go for ding first okay doris so
we're gonna
okay so uh for
uh tomorrow's game
ding will play against timor yep then
there's gonna be a free day and then to
finish the tournament he's going to have
a perugia and maybe that game
and in the first half
ding drew
all of his opponents coming up who's
next dorsa let's go for a knockoff
knockout
my pick he has nipple tomorrow huge game
just simply
huge
it was huge before this round started
right that is true yeah yeah it became
less huge
with the win today
and for he will wrap up his tournaments
with ding and he has drawn everybody in
the first half exactly and who's next
let's go for a fabulous fabi
that's a good choice and uh okay he's
gonna play richie uh tomorrow free day
then followed with against um timor and
that's back-to-back blacks oof
what he's back-to-back blacks against
rich against against teamwork
but he does finish with white against
alireza
okay and an opponent he actually
won against uh alireza yeah yeah and uh
okay those are uh i like from his
chances and finally our tournament
leader
nepo
uh
wow well he's just been having such a
stellar result yeah in uh the first half
he defeated richie and due to the two
opponents he finishes against and he
plays naca tomorrow
[Music]
just a few draws he's got this clinched
thing
last
candidates
he had the tournament
sewn up with one round to spare he even
lost the last round against dingler and
did nepo to become challenging to be
honest i think this one
just one more draw or two more draw and
the last chance didn't really matter for
him
it's a place he's been before uh but
ding lyrin is suffering uh alejandro i
mean like you say it's easy for us
to sit there and say dude you got this
move you've got to play bishop b5 play
e5 you've got to play this move
queen d7 but it's difficult for him to
find these
only moves well he found the first one
okay bishop b5 and now javi's thinking
and we know that bishop takes f6 it's a
draw queen h
for me queen a7 is an instant draw
so you got to come up with something
better and there we go
e5 challenges thing to find a move if
he's got queen d7 calculated and
properly analyzed
that is what will retain his half point
there's still a lot of things that you
need to consider that sometimes are not
so obvious right queen d7 bishop c5 rook
c8 even in that variation i mean we're
we're tired here but i think i glossed
over the movie e6 which one frankly
looks terrifying when d7 feels a little
um
out for me but queen d3 can i just you
know get the queens off the board and
just no but queen this requiem d5 is
just
lost
is it
must be no am i missing i'm taking a
pawn on my next turn if you play rook f7
i might even be considering
uh e6 but i was thinking if you move
your king
we take a pawn queen d7 on the board
okay so queen d7 and you gloss well you
shouldn't have glossed over that e6
because you said it your best yourself
after rook c8 e6 i'd be terrified i'd be
frightened terrified scared lonely yeah
the thing is is queen c6 i mean there's
other moves
there's other moves but queen c6 is good
enough that is you know i think
somehow i'm forgetting about my king
it's like i wanted to go queen takes f6
queen takes c5 queen f7 check
forgetting that queen take c5 is coming
with a check
so queen d7 on the board it's on the
board it's the accurate move dangler
you're a boy you're a man actually i
mean he's just so accurate when it comes
to these things some people fall apart
in defense and some people are just so
good at it and digler has always
traditionally been a good defender uh
let me see about rich's game it's still
a draw with most logical moves he did
take on g4
eventually
it's actually a table based position i
don't know why i'm analyzing this it's a
table based position uh that just says
draw
with every where most bishop moves and
king f6 or king h6
wow how would white actually want to
let's say here's king f6 what's white to
do
nice when i move the horse
hopefully you've laundered into a
blunder into a fork i mean what else can
you do
so the only reason hinaka is continuing
is he's hoping for blunder well you're
up on right i mean you play this forever
that's that's just proper chest
technique that's fair
you see that's that's like
um i always imagine that the higher
level chess goes like when you blunder a
piece you're just okay i wandered the
piece i'll continue five more rules
we'll call it a day
and my kids always ask me like when do i
make a draw and i'm like continue until
the end
right but
for some reason it was always um you
know like the higher you go the more you
trust your opponents will be able to win
this or survive this but
well there's the candidates they want to
play it out they can i i have a question
for you as a chess teacher
so you have young students okay eight
nine years old technically the youngest
is five even
okay
so you have this youngster who has a
passion for chess
and you want to nurture that passion so
they say
i really want to play you a game
and you play them again
how do you play do you play to beat them
and just crush them do you play to give
them a chance what do you do as a
it really depends i mean there's there
are a few of my students who we do a lot
of training games because there's a
specific opening that they're trying to
work on and i want to give them that
opportunity because if they play online
they won't get that
uh for most parts i will ask them to
bring like to have like a 10 10 selected
games over the week so that they can
bring it so we can talk over it so they
play their own level but if we play uh
most of the time i've noticed that my
you know when i beat my students they're
not very happy about it exactly
so i started being like okay so we're
going to give this game
15 minute total
if we're not done in 15 minutes that's
the position we'll end it at so i don't
necessarily try to drag out the position
because
i saw one of my sons cry after i beat
then i'm not it's physically i don't
want to make you cry man so
so here's my technique yes please okay
this is my technique and uh
i'm at the chess club right yes
and um
well
poor ben feingold he has a demon he had
lost a game
so he's really really tough he said yes
come here sit me down he said look what
i did look what i did look what i did in
the meantime this young
young little guy comes up and he's
watching the gaming and he's watching
the analysis so i did this and i did
that says ben this young man is watching
everything and he was really polite and
really nice so after the after ben left
he turned to me and he said would you
like to play me a game huh and i said
i'd love to
he says i gotta warn you
i'm the kindergarten champion of
illinois
nice i said i have been warned i have
been warned i get it
so we're playing and i have a big
advantage so i asked him i said well who
do you think stands better
and he says i think you have the better
position i said okay i turned the board
around oh
that's okay so we're playing we're
playing and suddenly you know he slips
up
who do you think is better he says
you got me again you have the better
position side i make
he wins the game but i make him win it
there yeah i don't purposely lose or
anything like that
but i switch the board so that it's fun
for both of us yes that's a very good
technique i use that another thing that
i use with some of my students is like i
tell them that um you know we can talk
about the moves but i'm not going to
help you make decisions right you have
to give me candidates you have to give
me lines we'll talk through the lines i
won't tell you what i mean i'll ask you
the right questions to guide you where
you got to go but i won't tell you hey
that's what you should do or you know
i'll question hey where do you think
which side you're going to castle and
you're like okay i'm going to go
shortcuts like all right well make it
happen so you have to get that
development you have to get your pawn
structure but
yeah that's that's tricky when kids want
to play and they're like i want to play
a serious game right don't go easy on me
and i don't and then they get upset and
they don't want to do it uh what is
going on uh with uh fabi he's played the
move e5 did dingler in it looks like
doing look just a second let me refresh
my board to make sure i'm not
just repeating our analysis nope he
found it alejandro he's ding has found
all of the right defensive moves he's
got all the answers as long as he plays
like an engine he's gonna be okay and
he's playing like an engine he's doing
exactly what he needs to do every
accurate move queen h7 queen d7 rook c8
sat down he found it and he's played it
so let me see if can
can i
try to trick black absolutely this is
probably the best move in this position
f2 you can still take on e5 and then
something like queen g3 trying to
um
wrong step black there's more than one
chance even queen f6 maybe even a better
way of doing the same thing that you
want to do because you don't have queen
g7 because there's a queen e6 check
it was funny because i had actually in
this particular moment queen g3 queen g7
wanted
to be able to defend
uh with this move but i i keep i keep
forgetting that queen a7 check uh is is
probably gonna save the day um all right
but queen f6 i'll fall for it that looks
like a good one
how will ding
again possibly save this it looks
it looks scary cafe
what yeah just for cafe yeah you gotta
check
oh it's actually not hard when you think
about it right true
but at the time i was just so eager to
win a pawn and exposure king
uh check queen g7 now
again if i'm trading queens it's a it's
a dead end unfortunately that one's
really grants white any advantage any
winnable advantage but
instead of working with rookie h work
too
rookie just g8 drag the game no no i
mean i'm sorry after take take queen of
six then or cr8 okay so this way that
looks like a a try
but again aren't you your king just
feels a little exposed like i'm not
gonna trade queens right i'm just gonna
try to
hang around uh
i'm not
i'm not nobody believes it come on it's
just yeah this is clear
yeah
the bishop on f2 is not participating in
the attack as long as this bishop is on
f2 oh i was dreaming i i loved that
moment
just so it was way back here i love that
moment where
somehow
uh
i could
oh yeah achieve this
this was you know uh paradise you know
my my d my bishop was dominating i could
give a check mate even here somehow
apparently the engine can save the game
this is not for human beings that i
would collapse under this kind of a
pressure what was it here
because that i mean um
i do remember that f takes e5 was not a
good choice that was why d7 was played
in fact
in the game um and let me just refresh
my board first of all i'm going to go to
the hikaru game for just a moment
no progress and they are in
the
table basis so um
if you're in fabi's shoes alejandro
what is his best cheapo there's nothing
no cheapo well i mean
yeah humor me but we just saw that we
saw e6
we saw bishop f2
we saw queen b3 what about bishop d6
just for the fun of it okay let's do it
it's the same exact problem that's fair
bishop d6 what's this
checks
yeah that's that's the problem
and e6 once again ran into queen c6
among others but queen c6 i think is the
easiest to calculate that's well there's
nothing but calculate that one is easy
um so i tried bishop f2 um
fabi is uh i mean i understand what you
were saying about
uh karpov and magnus being grinders and
and keeping the position alive and fabi
just going directly he just goes
straight
into the lion's den and says can you
defend yourself mr lyon and sometimes
they do and in this case this is exactly
what's going on with dingle wren he's
being challenged very strongly by the
way there was a lot of awkward moves he
had to find true but it seems that he's
up to the task whereas what magnus does
is he goes around and around and around
hoping his opponent gets dizzy before he
goes in for the fight
so
totally different approaches
favis doesn't mean that it's worse or
better sometimes it works sometimes you
put the pressure on your opponent just
can't find the correct resources right
but in this case dingleran it seems that
the second half of the candidates is
just a completely completely different
dinglerand than the first half yeah he's
definitely been rising to the challenge
not just in this game
but in the second half and again
dinglerin comes into this today's game
with uh two wins in a row so uh i mean
both well for fabi he needed to stop the
bleeding just to let you know i mean
he's a hard man to catch yes he's so
busy but gary kasparov will be joining
us tomorrow to give us his insights on
these this candidate's tournaments and
who he thinks is going to win the
tournament well i guess we all know
uh and we have some questions from
social media
dorsa
from twitter who likes to ask will
nipple play better against carlson this
time if he wins a canada tournament
can't play any worse so the answer is
yes i'm gonna go with yes on this one
dorset
should i keep it short and sweet yeah i
think so then that's a yes that's a yes
we have a yes
let's take a look at a little bit of the
history
of the candidates that we have all the
way starting to the magnus year of 2013
remember this is the return to the
format that we have currently of a eight
player double round robin just remember
that before the 2013 candidates
tournaments they used to play candidate
matches and they had different ways but
it was in 2013 that the modern tradition
really began
and in
that event there was a tie for first
a mathematical tie between magnus and
vladimir kramnik madness was declared
the winner by the tiebreak he became the
official challenger he went to chennai
and defeated vichy anand and in 2013 he
was here in saint louis and he signed
the contract we have pictures wonderful
because he was like in in difficulties
should he play
following his loss
the swanathondanand he was written off
the tiger of madras get out of here
you're done with you're over
who contrary he comes back
storms the
crushes the field
he becomes challenger
but again he lost a second match to
magnus carlson for the world
championship
and then came
sergey needing a dramatic last round win
defeated fabiano to become the
challenger and went on to new york city
where after 10 rounds of play
he was leading magnus
magnus wins the game
forces a tie first as a playoff
sergey loses the playoff and then it was
all fabi
yes i mean i feel you got to take over
this one alejandro as as the saint louis
the lion of saint louis can i say that
sure
why not
2018 candidates in berlin went to
fabiano caruana a sweeping performance
needing only a draw in the last round
against alexander gristrok actually
ended up winning the game anyway
beautiful and he had a wonderful
performance there went on to play magnus
carlson in the world championship in
london that match ended
also with 12 well actually ended with 12
draw 66
marathon absolute marathon of a
tournament both sides with their chances
but neither of them was able to even win
a single game against each other until
of course again in the rapid tie break
magnus proved superior
and in the 2020 slash 2021 candidates
that we had in yakaterenborg well that
was a long tournament it was more than a
year long but no
questions about it yanni pomney actually
won that event with a full round to
spare
but the world championship match that he
played in dubai against magnus carlsen
is one of the most forgettable matches
that we're going to have in modern chess
history and i think jan is happy to have
a chance to rectify that ship that at
least if he loses again that it's a
fight yes not the catastrophe that we
saw now remember that match that ian did
lose in dubai was really a match of two
halves and in the first half
he played really well he acquitted
himself well it was an even score both
sides had chances then comes this
marathon game six i believe where it
went like 140 moves and uh somewhere in
the first 40 moves
nepo was first choice he could have been
a pawn up instead he got dragged down
and he collapsed this man this defeat
really really cost him dearly he was
never the same and then the second half
of the match was utterly utterly
dreadful um we do have a move queen b3
check
by fabi on the board uh
cheapo potential alejandro with this
move i don't see it don't think so queen
f7
doesn't lose even though it allows e6
but it's such a crazy move why would you
encourage easter i don't know why
anybody would encourage that let's play
it quinn f7 was just played no way there
you go queen but dingler is a machine
that's what it comes down to it
e6 is fine but black apparently has tons
of moves that equalize here no way
really including queen c7 you're so
close right it's even a check
but that's about as far as it goes
the engines don't even give an advantage
they give zero zero e6 was played on the
board it's hard not to play e6 it's the
only reason you you play queen b3 check
right and now
shockingly to me
there's a lot of moves that drop her
black i'm stunned most logical moves
actually maintain zero zero so you're
saying go ahead queen c7 e6 discover
check king g7
bishop david 4 for example i got a pawn
on e7 to show some respect
there's nothing here queen f4 fine queen
d6 is fine
no respect no respect for this point
it's just not going anywhere it's stuck
on e7 it's been stuck on e7 forever
because this bishop is secure
right you'll never get my rook off the
file right
and you're not going to control it the
only thing that you have is pressure on
f6 right this is where you try to win
this is where you're trying to go with
this move mm-hmm
problem is that it's not quite enough
question play by the way uh queen f4 for
example starts counter play with rook c1
if you wanted to try to finish the game
immediately let me give you an example
queen here rook c1
you want to be a little bit more
ambitious rook c2 try to see if your
opponent messes up
yeah i get it it doesn't look visually
appealing
but even with the pawn all the way on e7
engines are cool blooded nothing here
that's so
weird to look you know that pawn is all
the way up in e7 the king is
you know that black king is so
unsafe but it's just not working
wow i i'm stunned i mean visually i
would have thought that the pawn on e7
black has some concerns yes and it
actually the engine actually says
the advantage that white possessed went
to zero
chess is cruel i mean you push your pawn
all the way to e7 and you get no respect
i mean what can i tell you i have to
bring this up please
this was uh the game that fabi had
versus naka yes the one that he did lose
just in the second half where he grabbed
that
h pawn i believe and he just pushed push
push push all the way to h3 and takes on
g7 and then he grabbed the jeep and i
was like okay now let's jeep on push
push push push push push push and again
you know those those are quite nice
pushes they got a punch two all the way
in that game right right it's the same
thing a king spawn all the way to the
seventh frame right and there was a
bishop on d3 i think supporters
i mean and then knock mora like
moved his pieces to knight to e1 and
bishop to f2
uh well i mean
sometimes it brings you success and
sometimes it doesn't and we do have a
few e7 check on the board and we would
be going right down that primrose path
of king g7 and this move
you know if you bring your bishop back
you draw attention to this pawn and
it's this move queen f4 and again what
i find really crazy is
that there's a number of moves queen d6
alejandro saying
that there's not only one way for black
to draw but he can play moves like queen
for queen d6 both
and i assume that you need to defend
this f6 pawn i guess there's a trick
yeah there's a trick but at some point
you realize that black has to move rook
h8
it's not it doesn't work here i think
because bishop f6 right
but the moment you see bishop rocket
shade and queen h2 you start realizing
wait a
second it's not it's not just white
having fun is uh not play on one goal
only ouch
queen h2 check on the agenda but there
is as alejandro has already mentioned
bishop takes and you could get your
kebab
on
on h8 i'm still i'm still dealing with
wish block you know it's like maybe one
of those things that you know
yeah gotta gotta get your head around
these uh new farsi terms
coming turn i'm coming to terms with my
farsi
congratulations by the way you're my top
agent in farsi thank you
i'll take it thank you it used to be uh
not camille kadari i'm thinking we had a
a a international master from kamran
shirazi oh yes
he lived in france yeah now he's living
in france he used to live in l.a and
they used to play blitz with him and
stuff uh he was he was one of the guys
who left the country because of the ban
uh against chess and chess as well yeah
i believe that was his story as well
because we had a lot a few of the chess
players who left left because of the
band and i think he was one of them but
i actually never
i can't remember ever meeting him right
um really los angeles ucla usc
used to be
maybe it still is a place where a lot of
iranian students came
uh to pursue higher education
very like i mean if you're coming from
iran you don't necessarily want to come
to missouri unless you're going
you know most people would go in new
york or l.a so like the coast the coast
there's a lot of persian people
there
and we do have by the way the move queen
f4 which looks uh
pardon me after bishop d4 queen f4 and
you just said it alejandro dinglerin is
a machine he is playing all of these top
eight
engine moves
and he's doing it
really really really well and it looks
like if he draws this game
he will have dodged
a huge bullet yeah especially after that
miscalculation uh near the beginning of
the game right where he messes up his
own structure a lifetime ago yeah this
is a lifetime indeed it was a lifetime
ago where we felt that
three results were possible and even
that black might might just get an edge
out of this dinglerang came up with this
very forcing sequence that went g5
bishop e3 queen
e5 beautiful beautiful
double attack
knight has to move rook takes b2 and
black is happy the knight moved and
dingler and
caught himself
right at this moment he got the cold
shower
thinking about rook takes b2 i'll give
you a moment but there's a refutation
that you came up with dorsa good for you
guys you but let's look at the current
position bobby didn't play what we
expected which was queen e3 and just
make it drop he plays bishop e3 and is
still trying to win
the engines don't
like this is there a queen g3 sight what
did you do played and played and it came
very quickly very quickly now because
engines are engines they don't care that
much
it's still within
holding
for white wow
but you gotta be careful now
uh oh you gotta be careful and five is
down to four minutes and 45 seconds not
that many moves left
but you got to be a little careful here
he missed queen jesus i think i'm sure
he's just g3 he i don't know what he was
thinking other than i think he was
thinking he can't lose
right but the queen g3 what's going on
suddenly everything is up in the air
the rook is attacked
the bishop is pinned he can't the bishop
can't move the desirable bishop f2 queen
takes b3 loses and if we have to pause
to kind of come back and defend this
gives black the chance that he need
you mentioned rook h8
and queen h2 uh could
rock white's world well
well it's there now we have to just
determine how strong it is right exactly
because it's not made queen introduced
not checkmate
but it's scary it's a bit scary it's
definitely very scary for me yeah so
queen d1 is the best move
okay if you go rook h8 which is fine
right the engines are saying promote
your pawn
not a fun move to play
but promote your pawn you can throw in
queen h2 doesn't really matter okay you
want to take with the bishop so that you
don't destroy your yeah you keep the
battery you keep the battery and then
you just move the bishop somewhere the
idea is to go bishop d6 and defend this
way
do i have to give up my bishop but
you're upon you mean sorry yes i have
yeah because if you play the move bishop
c5 right away
after you check here bishop c6 there's
no check on e7
it's an important resource to check on
e7 yeah this king is totally safe and
it's difficult to answer queen g2 so you
need this avenue of attack
against uh the king and at this point
it's not easy because even if you
promote with check rook takes e8 this is
a check on g2
so that's an important intermediate five
it down to below three minutes oh no
below three minutes for fabiano carana
he needs to find a move both queen d1
and queen b4 are within holding margins
but this game has changed completely
he's playing with queen b4
uh i expect rook h8 question mark
don't say why not and it's kind of a
very similar scenario here you also
promote to whatever so that you have
output promoter and i just don't have to
calculate anything else check yeah check
bishop take c8 and bishop d4 not not a
difficult move to find
it does cover f4 but i don't care about
a perpetual anymore and i threaten queen
e7 queen takes f6
still with winning chances for black
you're up a pawn right and the game
flares on you well i mean i would be
very scared and the fact that i just
gave up my pride and joy or semi you
know it would protect it well it wasn't
a protected past bomb but my past pawn
on e7 on the doorstep of coronation i
just had to throw it away in order to
give myself a perpetual check
opportunity that is
bad that's that that's
trending the wrong way i want
i mean
i flabbergasted bishop bishop e3 is her
horrendous move
yeah
what was that bishop b6 you just forgot
that queen g3 exists
and once again pardon me uh dorset the
times of the players um give me one
second it's two minutes on 45 against
30. yes and the fobby cell is gonna make
two more moves he's on 58 so he knows
the players are about to make their
second time control there's three time
controls
as soon as they make move 60 fabby will
get an additional 15 minutes as will his
opponent and then the 32nd increments
but until they reach the move 60 they
will not get any increments and after
queen b4
my goodness that
i i that that's really i mean he's a bit
lucky he's not lost right let's be
honest yeah thank you that's really
really shocking that with one bad move i
mean it's not what you would call a
howler it doesn't look it doesn't
blunder a rook
but it's a big blunder
unfortunately this is
queen b4 and
uh rook here and once again you're
saying that we're going to make a queen
or knight pardon me
we take and then we go bishop c5
no bishop d4 pardon me because this sets
us up for queen f6 check
so
upon me you set this up for queen e7
check so i can go queen takes f6
check as well
whoa um
i think it's one
i think also a lot of people ask what's
the difference between grand masters and
how why is one grand master better than
another
one of the things is keeping your
equanimity you're calm
you're going to make a mistake
congratulations you've chosen the world
of chess as your kingdom you're going to
become a grand master
well guess what you're going to make a
mistake that's fair
and when you make those inevitable
mistakes to keep your calm after you go
all right
like i just i just blundered
holy smokes but i don't want to reveal
myself i want to okay okay okay okay oh
i can still draw to maintain that inner
calm is really really hard and i think
that that's also a thing that separates
the best players i've seen so many of
the just strong test players whenever
they like make mistakes they like look
at the board they shake their head was
that me yeah they look you know like
especially when it happens to everybody
i can recall few of my very very lovely
experiences too like um you make the
move you you're still thinking about it
and while you're writing it down like
wait
did i just do that right seriously i did
that and
it's very common that you can also like
while you're do your opponent sees it
too and your opponent is also looking at
you like
dude did you really do it and that's
that that moment of realization is so
priceless
i mean it's hurtful for the person who
blundered but it happens to everybody
but
i have bluffed my way out of a lot of
these as well
guys yes we have moves okay we'll come
back to the floor bobby dodged a bullet
right now oh he had two minutes left and
i was trying to understand why do you
promote first
yeah why don't you just play bishop d4
right away right i mean what's the
difference check here check here most of
the most moves i'll just answer with
knight what's the difference
and the engine is giving this bizarre
move
rook h4 oh but jesus
kind of a stranger threatening queen h2
and maybe rook finish to rook f4 is
strong okay and when you promote
oh
you never find this right you never find
this in two minutes he just chose one
move over the other
he got lucky bishop d4 was not the one
he chose he chose eight which is correct
okay he made a queen doesn't actually
matter like doesn't matter what he makes
you're kind of required to take it this
one does require you to take either
right now or the next move okay rookie
is an easy draw because i force the
brooks off the board yep you that's it
that's it so you probably think with the
bishop you could throw in the check
uh on h2 but
it doesn't help you very much so you
might as well take with the bishop right
away okay and then five would have to
make one more move
and that would be move 60 the engines
are pretty adamant though that here the
move is bishop d4 a very logical move
that being said what's wrong with check
the the problem with check is that it
disconnects your queen and your rook
right you're going to have to spend a
tempo on it so after bishop f7 if you go
bishop d4 for example i pick up that
bishop check here check and i this is
not defended right when the queen is on
b4
right here this bishop is defended on d4
right right so check f4 doesn't threaten
the bishop that's the difference
sometimes
sometimes you just need to be lucky now
tell us a story how do you bluff your
way out of a blunder okay let's see
which one oh that's what
there's been a whole history okay
well a very um a very fun bluff that i
can recall was um this was back in 2016.
like i'm playing tournaments non-stop
like i'm flying
the here and i have to be back and play
the last round of this tournament then
i'm going to that league and then i'm
going to airflow it's like a non-stop
event it's so much fun
and so i played this tournament i scored
my first i am norm and then i'm so close
to crossing twenty four hundreds like
twenty three ninety eight and i'm like
okay just two more raiding points
and i go to this tournament in austria i
just need to play two around because
it's a bundesliga and i'm playing and i
when uh um i'm playing this
somehow we get into a
weird technical difficulty i said i
adjust but opponent didn't hear it and
she won the
the arbitrary ruling and
so i lost an extra pawn and i'm like
okay okay okay i lost my phone i need to
win this otherwise i'm not crossing 2400
and not getting your title yes
so i i have to
win and i end up bluffing and bluffing
and you know i pretend like i actually
plan and i win that but that was not the
bluff game
i crossed 2400
i go and i have a little too much drink
i still have to play around tomorrow
and it's a team event so i don't want to
let my team down i show up and i'm
still you know
a little a little too much drinks from
the night before and i'm playing black i
have a worse position but i'm way strong
like my rating is way higher than this
girl she was like 20 100 um like just
cross 2 400
so i have a terrible terrible position
but i remember that when i was the lower
rated when and i got an offer from a
higher rated
draw
it you know trips me off my game like
you know maybe you know maybe i should
just grab the draw this girl is like 300
points more than me
star power yeah so i can say i think
that's what we call the magnus effect
the and so
i try to like repeat a little but i the
third time that she's trying to repeat i
say no just to mess with her my position
is definitely worse and then again
she tries to repeat and instead of
repeating i just offer her a draw now
it's up to her if you say no to my draw
offer it means you think you can win and
she thinks for 45 minutes and i'm just
walking in the playing hall and then i
come back and i'm i sit down and i'm
just like i relax i'm just looking at
you like what do you want to do in this
position
and i think that that look of like
why are you continuing this she just
accepted my draw offer and i didn't lose
the game that i should have lost and i
kept my 24 hundred and
a major title yeah but bluffing is one
of my favorite favorite techniques in
chess yeah i'm gonna steal a story of
alejandro alejandro was playing in a
collegiate event
where
he was a rookop an exchange up an
exchange up and
essentially a draw
earned the team a seriously good medal
and as he was writing down his move his
opponent took the rook
that he left on pre so it was just a
king and a rook versus a king and a
minor piece and the minor piece had
attacked the rook and alejandro's
checked the scoresheet and said yeah
yeah he he did move to
my rook he forgot to move his rook
alejandro
he blundered a whole rook alejandra yeah
cost his team what did it cost your team
national championship only the national
championship wait a second everything
went wrong that round because it wasn't
just my blunder somebody else had to
blunder at the same time
for us not to win so in this position
this is an important moment right white
has two moves that
arguably solve its problems okay both of
them are findable but especially now
that he has an extra 16 minutes right
right he just got his time control back
if you move the bishop anywhere random
let's say like bishop b6 yeah
you run into the risk that after bishop
c6 i can take on g2 with check and then
take the work on e8 recapture that's a
problem
true so
better ways to do that one is uh
rook takes it bishop d2 seems to be okay
but it's still dangerous rook takes
bishop takes and after bishop c6 queen
g4 kind of holds
i think the better way of doing this is
just calculating
wow thank
if you take perpetual this one is hot
this one's easy
perp
yeah here here here
and
the nicest thing for white in this
position
is that for example
this oof
that dropped oh i've been there wrong
pawn right wrong color pawn wrong color
pawn
so if you pick up both pawns
draught becomes a huge favorite with the
rooks off the board
and there's no really good way of
avoiding it take stakes
same thing thanks checks
if you go king g6 i got queen e6 if you
go king j8 i take if you go king hey i
got queen f8 go king h6 i got queen f6
so i have an answer to all of your moves
right uh this should end in a draw
yeah
probably right absolutely yeah you would
think so the engines aren't so sure that
it's an immediate perpetual but they do
think it's a draw so they think the game
goes on but eventually it's drawn anyway
it's hard to win anyway because even if
i just take my queen defending the pawn
on b6 right and i just do that i put my
queen on b6 or c7 or whatever and i move
around with my king
i don't know how you win so bishop g5 is
correct and i think important
if you don't have bishop g5 i love that
as a bailout i think it's a great
bailout bobby must be looking at that
right now right saying that yeah that
that's it that's the way i want to draw
this game before i have any more
adventures miss adventures
more adventures here adventure time is
over right it's time to make a draw
bishop takes g5 is the correct bailout
in the other game we finally finally
have a position
that
we can kind of call
steli car is trying right he's giving up
the g4 pawn in order to get that punt to
e6 and by some magic
force this bishop of the diagonal the
issue
good luck good luck with that right
here's something any squares on this
diagonal you're right yeah i mean almost
every move is is is drawing actually the
only moves that don't draw in this
position are putting the bishop on me
allowing e7 allowing e7 and i don't
think you'd do that right so
uh everything else is just straight up
sorry we do have a move on the other did
fabby capture he didn't capture on g5
man
i think febby
we're in for the long run because now
what what happens black's up a pond
you think draw is favorite
but it's a game
uh yeah no i mean now it's dingler in
with the sunny side of the torture and
again the two players are coming into
this game with very different paths
dingler in two wins in a row my gosh i
mean could he do a hat trick that would
be unbelievable fabi coming in with two
losses in a row
maybe it's reflecting in the play that
we came in today saying
has fabie ran out of energy that these
last two games the last few rounds have
really zapped him and he doesn't look
good
here we just seen him blunder blunder
right here this uh huge move bishop g
bishop e3
allowing queen g3 and tables have turned
uh maybe not
completely completely completely but boy
dingler in
is suddenly saying uh my gosh i have a
chance for soul second
dorset that
when
you
having a bad tournament how do you stop
the bleeding how do you say okay like
i'm shutting this down because i'm
playing like an idiot well i'm gonna
shoot myself on the foot and say this
do you remember my us championship in
2018
i hope you don't yeah
i wish i could there it is
it was my first time playing it okay and
it was just so long
you're playing all of the top yeah in
the us yeah i got the last place
i mean i recovered after that but during
it i didn't i just had a very strong
start i had advantages in almost all of
my game in the first few rounds and i
blew it a little here and there and i
ended with a few draws but i i just
couldn't make any of my games work so
there you have your answers sometimes
the tournament is just gonna just i
remember wesley so he came into a
singfield cup uh he took the last place
i think the first year and then he came
back and he won first place so
take some inspiration from wesley no i
had a very fun time playing in the 2021
and i got bronze and it was very
comfortable but all right we have a
result we do yeah
has drawn richard rapport okay and well
we expected that
wait wait wait did they actually
wait wait wait they're still playing oh
hush
hikar nakamura has drawn against richard
rapport that means that it's up to
dingley wren and fabiano corona to
determine if he's there alone
okay they're still playing they are
still they're still sitting here
it is
actually impossible to stop i know but
let me enjoy this with a jeep on it's
actually impossible so can't you knight
the pawn and get yourself mated you can
also make a bishop if you really felt
like it right and get yourself made it
that way too okay he took the pawns
shocking yeah the game didn't draw so
this it's all about this game guys
it's all about this last fight
fabiano gets dingley right will hikaru
be in a tie for second with two other
players or will one of these players
because at this point of the six hour of
game i don't know if going to blunder a
rook
will one of these two players
catapult himself on top
say
you know what napo two points is going
to keep my hopes up a little bit even if
it's just to play better in the next
games
and if daenerys wins another game geez
that is a surge
wow three in a row that would be just
remarkable one of the things though
we've been talking especially with
jonathan chisel again a big shout out to
our friends his for joining us on the
show where we're talking about these
marathon games and the marathon
classical time controls
and you know sometimes you do feel like
games like today like this game that
dingler in is on now on the better side
that it's a kind of a form of torture
that you know your endurance contest
where you know
chess blunders
this could have been decided uh hours
ago if they used a different time
control instead of you know like forcing
them to play and exhaust themselves you
know that's what actually saved the
commentators a lot of them
the really good news is our production
team would be happy the commentators
would uh rest the voices and that's what
we're going to do we're going to rest
our voices we do have three results
we've got this pending result between
fabiano and ding loren and we're going
to see you on the other side of this
break
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mm-hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2022 candidates
tournament
in round 11 we have three games already
in the record books
nepo has won
yet again
uh to take a commanding two-point lead
as hikaru nakamura is finally drawn we
have one game remaining between two
players who are fighting duking it out
for a tie for second or a soul second if
somebody between fabi
or um
dinglering could win they're in clear
yes i just wanted to say that there was
a missed opportunity already for fabi if
abby is now currently upon down back on
move 71 he could have simply played
bishop takes
g5 and there was a number of ways of
making a draw thereafter by force
fabi did not calculate that move he
instead he played queen g4 and now is
currently suffering
as we've just seen this move um
queen g4 last played
oops morgan moves queen d3 checked
and look at this
queens exchanged
and
again it's a
two result game
uh for
ding as he's looking to try to
drop his rook oops excuse me on the
second rank and harass this pawn
on g2 um
wow for ding he was on the back foot he
was the one trying to save this game and
now suddenly he's in the driver's seat
seat still because of the presence of
opposite color
draws the most likely result but wow
what a turnaround this has been
and as we were saying as we came on the
show should he win that will be a
hat-trick his third time winning in a
row wow when it was so very very
difficult
our colleague in madrid anastasia uh got
to madrid where she's had a chance to
interview a number of the players and
send us some reports recently she got a
chance to speak with nepo
who as we know is streaking away with
the tournament let's see what she
had for her interview with nepo
congratulations on your victory today it
was very impressive how do you feel
about it do you feel happy after winning
one more game
well i'm surely i can't say that i'm
excited about this game here but
i couldn't understand
what was he doing but clearly
he's not showing
anything close to his no no his normal
chest
uh well uh i guess okay this whole play
like g4h4 is ever optimistic but uh
i feel like more or less he plays every
game for for a win but
i'd say
here
i mean there is there was like no
basement at all for why to play like
this because okay black has all these
pieces developed so it's just
refused it's easy
yeah after he played this g4 move and
instead of instead of h4 did you
consider him to play a four and after
what did you plan to play i couldn't uh
i couldn't guess his move starting with
f3 so
i mean okay english one is more or less
a natural but then okay
uh he fought for so long so i thought
like maybe instead of a4 you will go for
some g4h for start but okay it's clearly
it never works because i mean it's like
uh because this is you know these are
the laws of the game here i mean you
can't really you can't really go like
and push like this
uh without any development but
yeah i guess
at least it was creative
that's for sure and i wanted to ask you
like what do you think
you are doing special during this
tournament that things are going so good
so far is it something about your
routine or anything else i don't know
i'm just playing the chess
preparing
some restless
as much as i can yeah and then i keep
again preparing again playing so it's
more or less
normal routine but
i don't even know what to mention
have you had chance to check the game of
fabiano today and what do you think
about it i i mean very briefly but i
think he's pressing but uh it's far from
being
yeah do you think that uh second place
is also important in this event the
candidates tournament have you thought
about it that that's a question too
uh
to some other players because okay i'm
not really into all this you know toxins
people who speak lights about it yeah
thank you very much jan and all the best
in the next round
i always get the feeling whenever an
interview whether it be anastasia
myself
maurice ashley
he wants to get off the stage it's sort
of like yeah i can't really speak about
it
but he knows it's going
unbelievably well in whatever it is
whatever the routine is it he's just
thinking please lord let it happen again
while he's at it he should buy a lottery
ticket i tell you i mean he should be
with magnus in las vegas uh she had
asked him specifically
uh about this position
and nepo said yeah you know f4 was a
kind of right idea and he started
thinking started thinking and i couldn't
believe it when he came up with g4 and
followed it up like with h4 like what is
he doing i don't know and
yeah i mean it was basically right here
he was presented with this opportunity
to make this very powerful combination
which is clearly in his favor and then
he went on to win the game about the
game between
um
fabi and digler in he was looking at it
but he thought three results he thought
fabi was pushing and that was earlier
we've got that one game between the two
uh going and uh
well uh he's pushing alejandro
is it uh
is it um
how do i say it uh
does he have does dingler in have any
realistic chances
i mean it's chances right you are more
active you do have this problem with the
king on f2 you imagine that if a rook
comes to the second rank and you pick up
the spawn the game is over clear
draw is a huge favorite right i mean
draw is just a huge favorite in this
position but you still have to be
accurate for white 11 minutes for 5 is
also a problem because there is no extra
time he will only get the 11 minutes
plus the increment
which is what he's going to be surviving
on and he still has to find a few
accurate moves i think that if he
doesn't find certain activity or certain
way of putting his pieces
he might be in a position where he needs
to suffer in an indefensible way
here i think the move g3 kind of screens
to be played exactly i wanted to ask the
same thing i think you should have to i
think you should play g3
maybe stick your rook on well c3 and e3
yeah and i think he did he's doing it
the other way around i think he played
the move rook c1 which also makes a lot
of sense right if you play for example
the move f4 i don't react right away but
i start
the usual defensive method in opposite
color bishop end games is that you
attack the base of the pawn clear so you
play rook c5
also holds a5 which is kind of nice and
if you're ever forced to defend this
pawn the game is over yeah you never mix
progress right you put a bishop on f6
you're a happy camper yeah it would just
be completely over so the england rant
has to be a little more clever than
playing the move f4 which allows this
rook to attack on the fifth rank right
what that clever is
i like rookie seven rook d7
okay i think like like that rookie 7
rook let's say c5 rook d7 right right at
some point i have to make this move
this move has to be played at some point
exactly
uh so i think g3 it's a good time to do
so can i arrange a rook takes g3 kind of
sacrifice so let me start with rook d2
chat rook david 2 check yeah
i want you to go there i go rook check
on d3
let me give it to you for free yeah i
understand king f2 yeah of course and i
take
oh and
zero zero
zero zero that should be right well yeah
but there's i thought there were
practical chances for black it's
practical chances for black if that's
the right pawn
uh-huh but we keep going back to that
right if i sacrifice my rook for two
pawns so if the pawns were not on a6 and
a5 but for example on c6 and c5 you
couldn't just give up your rook for the
two pawns i think i think if it's on c6
and c5 it's just that lost because the
bishop defends the pawn right if it was
on any other square then maybe
but the way it is right now
no chance um
if you don't mind why uh is it so easy
for you to give up the rook for the two
pawn i don't think you just make
progress at all unless i go here
g4 yeah g4 and here i think i start
i start putting my rook behind your pawn
okay
i think i go rook c8
i guess bishop somewhere because you
want to play f5 i was gonna go king g2
g3 maybe but this was just stuck yeah
you're already stuck really g
what am i missing g3 what am i missing
g3 rick g8 oh sorry
yeah of course i have to go king f2 is a
is a move but uh but then you're not
yeah i'm not uh i i want to be able to
push my pawns in a nice way yeah you
want to push them on on dark squares
right right which is why maybe here you
consider going
not king g3 but bishop moves an f4 check
yeah but i mean the pawns hanging where
are you moving the bishop right
huh okay so uh but that would be my
way of trying to work
try as well rookie seven plate i expect
because rook c5 rock d7 now no nothing
is forcing favi to play the move rook c5
i'm sure there are other moves in the
position it's just that putting the rook
on c5 because it eyes the fifth rank
makes sense exactly i think you can
start with g3 i'm surprised the engine's
not showing it
g3 loses to bishop d3
what oh right you don't have rookie one
here right because rook takes cs7 the
bishop you can't tell obviously you
can't talk to right
seventh hour of commentary whatever it
is
yeah g3 obviously loses to bishop d3
so
rookie seven you have to be a little bit
more clever
can i put my bishop on b6 i always like
this guy anchored
bishop d3 rookie one producers are
saying nonsense because it's also the
sixth hour of of play rook c4 is a draw
bishop d6 is a draw rook c3 is a draw
rook c5 is also a draw but you got to
choose them accurately at this point
right right there are trips there are
traps and uh
pitfalls
everywhere here for fabi and i think
that's what the difficulty is especially
when the tables turn we were talking
about a position in which all the
pitfalls were for dingler end where favi
was putting pressure putting pressure
putting pressure and zing loren
accurately defended defended defended
laundry by fari has changed the roles
and we got 8 minutes and 40 seconds
against 28 of dingley ran so also time
pressure is going to be a factor well
once again the players are now in the
third time control where they have
already has gotten their 15 minutes and
then they're going to be playing now and
forever on 30 second increments they
will get each move that they complete
and press their claws
press the clocks they get their 30
seconds and he's played them with rook
c3 and he's going for the g yeah rookie
three bad move and instantly dinged her
and returned it
rook d7 really sounds not a good move
bishop d3 was a good move
oh
remember that your rook's overloaded
yeah right is the rook end game a draw
maybe maybe not maybe maybe not right
right i'm not sure i don't i don't
actually know if it's winning or not
the g3 winning g3 the players are kind
of getting going towards
that potential of rook the two check
king e3 rook g2
where
uh
black might try to engineer
a i don't think i ever put this king on
e3 i think i just put it on e1 really
well of course why so you don't
sacrifice okay
right good point
let me just uh catch up with the players
sorry dorsey yeah
and what do you think about this
position dorset do you think it's a
chance well chances for ding clear yes
but realistic i think it's just going to
be a draw and unless there is a blunder
otherwise if you just
i mean black's position is good but the
common trend that we've been seeing in
this tournament is
one side gets a better position
they push push push but at some point
there is no more improvement so the
position is just better but stuck and i
feel like that's something that's going
to happen in this game too especially
because we've been talking how important
it is that that a six pawn is the wrong
colored pawn for that specific bishop on
e4 right because even if you know we
lose the rook we lose the bishop we
exchange the drugs we
lose the bishop and we get rid of the
kingside bishops and we give up all of
our white pawns
that black pawn on a6 will never be able
to clean so
right especially because of that i'm
very
comfortable um with our with white's
drawing chances
but
it's been a very very
ups and downs games exactly well one of
the things i might say that if i was in
black shoes and i got a position like
this i put my king on g2 and i put my
bishop on f3
now i would be thinking about rookie two
check and the king would be forced to
walk into a discover check with a bishop
of a black bishop on f3 black's king on
g2
i've got rook check and then the king
has to walk into
into a discovery which might win the
game see those were the blunders
i was saying but uh i see that you're
trying to you know bring your stuff in
white camp and i'd just like to remind
everybody that this is the same game
that white had a bishop on h6 and a
knight on g7
right and and
and at some point white had that pawn on
e7
right so now talk about the penetrating
opponent's camp
it's all gone that's ancient history
ancient history by the way everything
you were describing of a position where
black has a light squared bishop on e4
and upon on a6 and nothing else and
white has a king and the promotion chord
when
you were first taught that ending that
black that the game's a draw even though
black's a bishop
and the pawn ahead
what was your first reaction when you
discovered that game was that position
was a draw i asked prove it yeah you
couldn't believe it either yeah no i
mean it was just weird because
for me
um i kind of knew it but i i i couldn't
believe it i always thought to wait
like
why would you voluntarily get to that
position and then i was playing a
tournament in um like a classical
tournament in abu dhabi and um i was the
one pushing and my opponent was just
like he was highlighted then he was like
you know what i'm done with this
position let's just get rid of the
pieces and then i was stuck with the
bishop
and the pawn and i was like no
i know this is a draw but why
so
my first reaction was when i learned
that that position was a draw i thought
chess was a draw
because there's no way
that the advantage of the opening move
could be worth a bishop
and a pawn
no for me it was just his chest was a
force drawer no no well that that's that
changes your perspective but i i
couldn't believe the idea that
you have advantage but you just can't
push the idea of never being able to
improve or never being able to push was
what really tripped me off but
i mean
i was what like 10
and
for me the world was my ocean
much to learn um we
we're seeing a different approach by
ding lorraine uh here um
alejandro he's played the move bishop d3
which is a clear indication to me he's
he's planning to play f4
takes takes put his pawn on f3
and secure his bishop on e2
um it feels to me like he that's
that would make an e that would allow
fabi to make an easier draw uh your take
on
on the approach that uh dinglerin is
having
i mean there's no approach right the
game is a draw so you just have to
choose something right i assume actually
that he's gonna play the bishop b5 and
try to get this kind of positions with
rook on d2 rook on e2 expel the king and
then i i don't know hope for something
but as long as the king's on f2 oh and
point alejandra again you know your
thing
okay
well you have your king on f2 i don't
think that you push your pawn on f4 i
think that would be make white's chop
too easy exactly
that was my my
thinking as well
all right uh
guys it just seems i'm not saying that's
the curse of the commentators or
anything like that it's but
one game
out of the four that always goes to the
maximum
and we can't escape our uh task uh
uh
what's the override and the under that
we're gonna be here for another hour
another hour uh not that considering the
amount of time they play on increments
and they could theoretically be playing
for many hours on increments i guess in
theory right right
expressive double
uh what do you think uh alejandro you
think we're going to be here for quite
some time it's the candidates guys
candidates brings out the worst and the
best you saw what hikaru did to richard
oh torture 40 moves of nothing right i
have to ask
do you have a memorable experience that
it went all the way to king the king oh
many times i'm sure sure sure yeah just
you know
many times that that wasn't really
uh the most memorable was the game that
couldn't devour china
this was a game in the old days all
right guys
he's done it
he's what he's blundered what according
to the engine he's blundered
trying to figure out why
so the engine says rookie 7 is winning
figuring out why because roxy 2 bishop
d3 ah it's actually so easy
and you get to play rookie to check you
get rookie to check and king h3 you get
both
so then the king will be trapped on g1
i'm getting mated and with the king on
h3 i'll be able to play rook such a
bizarre move also to put the bishop in
the
scope of the scrutiny right yeah
like even if you move the bishop put it
on e5 i guess
or maybe just just don't just you have
king he won and get your king away from
one is a logical move get the king away
from the king's side yes sir
yeah we think that rookie 7 wins the
game
and ding lorraine could take
clean clear second
wow
and he's done it he's played the movie i
think it's over i think it's just not
not that hard from here because let's
explain why let's take a look at why
let's make nothing moves right
rookie to check yeah as we said he
played it king king g1
it's not completely trivial yet
but okay i make a waiting move also
killing the king and the problem is
you're going to play king h3o and drug
g2 why don't you just play king h3
immediately i think i start with this
right right so next move is rook g2
check
if we make a move for white for example
rook c8 the engine wants to play rook c8
yeah
and your king is now after king rook f2
it's stuck
after us the king is stuck
you don't get mated immediately but i
think you lose rook after is winning i
think this one is a little bit more
winning
the point is that when i go bishop c6
that bishop on behalf of the bishop is
hanging yes yeah and and i i think at
this point the rook our bishop trade is
just game game right right yeah because
everything if the if you guys trade the
bishops with your king on each one
it's over oh yeah completely over
exactly no no rook and pawn end game is
a draw when your king is
on h1 and he's done i mean
fabby uh fading fast again we talked
about stamina oh you were asking me
about the hour of play right yeah fabi
came up with an answer we're not playing
for another hour
unfortunately for him i'm kind of
stunned i am actually shocked because
again for the better part of four or
five hours of broadcast
fabi was really doing the pressing and
then he had to give up a pawn and he
could make a draw by playing bishop
takes g5 which was not a difficult
calculation fabi played queen g4 instead
gave his opponent a few chances still it
was going to be a draw and this last
move bishop c7 was a real just howler
why did you he didn't need to play
bishop c70 i guess he played it rather
quickly too right alejandro yeah yeah
played it almost instantly exactly and
now we are seeing with this move rook e7
that suddenly the white king
is going to have to go backwards and
it's going to be stuck
on the first rank and with king h3 and
rook
checked he loses this he's a half out of
four
yeah that's a collapse that is a brutal
collapse guys to be i feel like you know
he had such a he had a very
nice
uh first half of the tournament but then
you know he says nepo just running away
with the tournament and he has one bad
game he thinks he can come back then he
makes a drop against nepal with a slight
advantage and then the pre yesterday he
i feel like he just didn't really get a
chance to play
kind of unlucky because duda just
decided that it was his turn to play the
game of the tournament for himself he
played a really really good game against
fabi this was not a very well played
game by fabi uh kudos to ding loren ding
was just
in there he was saving saving savings
what i'm dreaming
right back to back
blacks wins back-to-back wins
with black with black
amazing oh and rocky to play the media
well i mean not a lot of choices europe
was hanging yeah
well yeah now isn't it time to just kind
of chase that uh bishop away yeah you
want to chase the bishop away from the
attack on g5 so rook d2 is is fine
um rook d2 is apparently the most
accurate move in this position and then
you play king h3 exactly yeah
exactly yeah listen made immediately
right king h3 bishop no it's not made
rookie two already played by dingley
wren yeah i don't see another move
because if you play bishop e7 for
example and i think he will play bishop
e7 just to keep control over this pawn
on g5 the engine's way of winning is
bishop d3 not super hard to find at this
level right the king is boxed and you
want to mate it so king f3 or king h3
are necessary the thing is uh neither
one of those mate you want to move the
king to the third rank to mate
so you open up
king takes g3 not so much that you're
taking upon which is sweet
but also the fact that you're
threatening mate with rook d1 bishop e7
on the board bishop d3 is lights out
absolutely uh is there my apologies is
there anything is bishop d3 and only
move because i mean it said i think
i think at this point uh there are a
number of ways of winning we just think
bishop d3 is the most direct it's just
very obvious too yeah you block the
defense bishop d3 you're threatening to
go king takes g3 which threatens a back
rank mate
uh you defend
the pawn on g3 of the move like this and
now you play king here what's the what's
the point the point is i can set you up
that he can't go to f1 bishop d3 played
well he expected this bishop to e4 and
now remember we were talking about those
really evil discovery discover checks
well rook takes g3 is going to be
discover check and mate
uh to begin and
this is this is why you want your king
away
from the corner and bishop d3 on the
board that's it uh the game is over made
in 20.
mate in 20.
okay
that one right
can't argue with that
computer tournament aegon and the hague
and my friend roberto sifu
it's done fabian
wow shocked shocked in the studio shock
around the chest world
shock
that favi took this advantageous
position
and lost it right completely
what a collapse by fabiana carrano and
our
congratulations to dingler in as he
comes out of nowhere out of the cellar
let's be clear and he has just had a
brace of three wins in a row
to
give himself
clear second place dorset look at this
there's a separation now in the
tournament hall
look what happened to our three second
place guys one stayed
one got half a point and ding lyren said
well guys
see ya
nice timo rogers office said they're
going why is it i'm in clear fifth place
all by myself
nobody's asking why alireza isn't clear
at last oh my gosh
tomorrow's berries guys let's take a
look at when we got nepo against naca
that was white though
the english red is white against rajabov
oh
my goodness my goodness an opportunity
and a richie
for a very very struggling fabi a very
badly fading fabby us
what's going to happen there and finally
do duda and farouza
to round out our four pairings i'm
stunned yes i just wanted to uh
well you guys made fun of me
for the first half
no we didn't we made fun of them for 10
times
i said it was a long tournament and
never have i ever wanted to be so wrong
i wish i was wrong i wish ding wasn't in
second i wish fabi wasn't second but
that's not the way this tournament is
going ding surgis
and one of the commentators well he kind
of saw thing he's a good chess player
speaking of ding uh can we take a quick
look at his road ahead
yes indeed
yeah let's see what does he have
it's a great it's a very relevant
question three
the forget the scores for just a moment
but these are his three opponents
tomorrow
white against timor black against the
last
place in the tournament who ding is
hoping will go for another 5 000 bullet
game session right and he finishes with
white against hikaru
ding is looking at this tournament like
what just happened i have an opportunity
to emerge from the ashes yeah big time
wow wow as he
clears clear surgista i i'm kind of
stunned uh alejandro uh please bring the
broadcast home for us final thoughts of
yet another eventful round i'm stunned
as well guys alireza's disappeared and
epos surges even further ding lyran says
hey remember me now i'm clear second
this tournament has
completely
changed from the first half completely
the only thing we have in common
nepo unstoppable everything else flipped
on its head
and i think with that yeah that's a good
way a good place to
end it thank you all for joining us and
staying with us staying true to us tell
your friends where you're hanging out
we're gonna be seeing you all tomorrow
as we try to recover dorsa from another
long day of broadcast good night
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you